SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON NATURAL
RESOURCES PHARMACY TECH AND
ENERGY WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
MORNING AND A RESPONSIVE IN THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN EMERGENCY INTO
PROTECT PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WHO
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS. BENNETT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING A MASK
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY JUSTIN
SONORA PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES
TO ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
CAPITALS. WOULD SOMEONE BE ABLE
MEMBERS ABLE TO. PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY HOWEVER TODAY ALL THE
MEMBERS. OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE WE
HEAR AND HE- HEARING ROOM. DOES
PROVIDE TESTIMONY FOR THE CA-
WERE TO. REMOTE FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE. MUTE YOUR
PHONES AND COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID ELIMINATE ANY
ACOUSTIC. FEEDBACK PASSED EVERY
TIME YOU WHICH WE RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU USED TO REACH THE HAND
FEATURE ON THE PROGRAM EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE
POLICE SELECTED ME BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING R. I. T.
PERSONNEL PUT YOU BACK UP. YOUR
TED ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME. WHEN THEY WERE REFERRED TO
FEDERATED TRUST THE COMMITTEE TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'RE-
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO THE HERE TO THIS
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING- REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. CAN BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR
ALL MEMBERS WISHING TO
PARTICIPATE. AND PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED
ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT IS
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL NOW SIT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATE SHOULD NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 THE EX EX. CODE IS
THREE FIVE THREE ONE. TWO EIGHT
. PRETTY CHILDREN. ON HOW THE
CAL. TELL COME SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
ARE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE MOVED
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATE DOT
ONE. ZERO PLEASE PRESS IS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
THE OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS COULD BE A
SHORT WAIT MUST RECEIVE RELY
NUMBER YOU WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
YOUR MOM FOR THE MODERATE TO
CALL YOU. YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON ME THAT
YOU WILL NOW BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER TO. FOR US TO HEAR. YOU
CLEARLY INTO THE VOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU TOO MUST MUTE YOUR
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING HERE. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM. DURING
THE HEARING WITH AS IS CUSTOMARY
IN. ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE- FROM REMOTE. MEETING
SIR. IT THERE CAN MUSIC PUBLIC.
WILL BE HEARD. AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS OF INTEREST.
PERCENT OF CLASS. FOR EVERYONE
FOR. PRESENT HERE TODAY PLEASE
KEEP YOUR MASK ON COVERING YOUR
NOSE. AND MOUTH THE WHOLE TIME.
WE DO NOT LET. YET HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE WILL. PROCEED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND- AT THE TIME WE DO
HAVE A THREE MEMBERS WE WILL. WE
WILL DO THAT. CHEN MY SCHEDULE
TODAY- ITEM NUMBER FOUR- ON THE
VOTE ONLY. WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE VOTE ONLY AND MOVED TO THE
DISCUSSION PACKAGE THIS IS- OUR
NUMBER FOR COMMERCIAL FISHING
INSPECTION. AB TRAPS S. B.
EIGHTY NUMBER. SIX CORRECTION
IT'S NOT MOVE THE DISCUSSION
WILL BE WILL WILL BE MOVED FROM
THE VOTE ONLY AND- HEARD AT A
LATER DATE. WITH THAT SAID I
HAVE. WE HAVE THREE SECRETARIES
THREE DIRECTORS AND NOT SURE OF
OUR- WATER RELATED AGENCIES
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO STATION
NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN WHICH IS OUR
DROUGHT RESILIENCE RESPONSE
PACKAGE- WE'VE- SET UP NINETY
MINUTES FOR THIS I WOULD ASK YOU
ONE OF THE RULES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS WITH THE AGENCY.
HEADS IS ACCOUNTABILITY WE'RE
THE CURRENT TRIAL PACKAGE THAT
WE APPROVED LAST YEAR PROVIDES
FOR THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN GERMAN SHEPHERD
RELATED PROJECTS YOU HAVE A NICE
LITTLE PACKAGE THAT WAS PROVIDED
BY PROVIDED TO US WHICH IS VERY
GOOD WHAT IT WOULD LASSEN.
SECRETARIES AND DIRECTORS. TO BE
MINDFUL SAID SOMETIMES WE A- UP
THE PROPOSAL I'M JUST PICKING
THIS AT THE- OF THE SKY WERE. WE
DON'T HAVE. DISCUSS ON YOU KNOW
WE GOT WATE CONVEYANCE WE GOT
ON THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FIVE.
FIVE MILLION HAS GONE UT FOR
STAFF WORK AT NINETY FIVE
MILLION IS STILL WAITING IN THE
QUEUE. AND WE'RE WAITING FOR
INDIVIDUAL CREE MYSELF IF
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO UPDATE
US ON SOME OF. THESE THINGS WERE
NO MONEY SEEMS TO BE GOING OUT
OR WE DON'T HAVE A CLEAR DATE
SOMETIMES IT DISCUSSION FOR THE
DESCRIPTION HAS BEEN- EXCELLENT
ON WE'RE HAVING FEBRUARY THE CUT
OFF DATE APRIL WE'RE GOING TO
FUND IT AND MAKE THE MONEY IS
OUT THE DOOR SO THAT'S THAT'S
BEEN HELPFUL FOR THE- FOR FOLKS.
FROM RIGHT LET'S GO THE FISH
ISSUE NUMBER. HE SAID- HI. LET'S
SEE WE HAVE SECRETARY CROWFOOT
FROM THE RESOURCE AGENCY
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD FROM KELLY
PA AND SECRETARY ROSS FROM- THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE- WHO'D
LIKE TO GO FIRST. GOOD MORNING.
SECRETARY PRO BUT I THINK I'M
I'M I'M I'M NOT CHILD TO LEAD
OFF THE DISCUSSION. IT'S GREAT
TO BE WITH YOU IN SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
BROAD WATER TEAM ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION. I HAVE TO SAY IN
ALMOST TEN YEARS IN STATE
GOVERNMENT I CAN SAY THAT THE
COLLABORATION THE ALIGNMENT HAS
NEVER BEEN STRONGER ACROSS ARE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS AND
THAT'S AM HARD WORK COLLECTIVELY
PRESENTING HERE TODAY. I'LL
START BY PROVIDING SOME CONTEXT
AND OF COURSE I'LL STATE THE
OBVIOUS WHICH IS EXHILARATING
CLIMATE CHANGE. WORSENING WHAT
WE KNOW IS THIS WEATHER WHIPLASH
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA AND THE
ENTIRE WEST. THIS WINTER IS
INDICATIVE OF THAT WORSENING
EXTREME WEATHER. BOB INTENSE-
DRYNESS. FOLLOWING TO VERY HOT
AND DRY YEARS. FOLLOWED BY WHAT
WAS OF THE Y. BOB. AND THEN
DECEMBER. ON RECORD FOLLOWED BY
AT AND NEAR REAL SETTING. DRIED. SO I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
NEED A CAN. TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
OUR END BUILDING ARE IS. BOTH TO
SPECIFIC RESPOND TO THE DRUG
CONDITIONS WE FACE RIGHT NOW.
AND TO BUILD OUR WATER IS TO
BOTH AND- MOVING FOR IN THE
YEARS AND TO COME. ARMOR GLAD TO
REPORT THAT THANKS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ASSURED INVESTMENTS
YOU MADE WITH THE GOVERNOR WE
ARE MAKING PROGRESS BUILDING OUR
WATER RESILIENCE. LAST YEAR YOU
ON THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR
AGREED ON THAT FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF FUNDING OVER
A THREE YEAR PERIOD. BOTH
RESPOND AND IF YOU DROUGHT
CONDITIONS AND STRENGTHEN OUR
WATER RESILIENCE. AND ADD YOU
IDENTIFY YOUR WHITE HOUSE D.
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF
APPROPRIATIONS- FOR THIS BUDGET
YEAR. YOUR POINT ON ACCOUNT OF
I'M REALLY GLAD TO READ THAT ARE
DEPARTMENT HAVE DONE A GOOD JOB
I WOULD SAY GREAT JOB ARE
WORKING TO GET FINDING OUT- MORE
QUICKLY OR MORE EFFICIENTLY THAN
EVER BEFORE WE HAVE UPWARDS OF
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT REPORT BILLION
DOLLARS COMMITTED. HALFWAY
THROUGH THE FISCAL YEAR NOW IN
THAT REFLECT THE SHARED URGENCY
THAT YEAR WHEN THE GOVERNOR HAD
DIRECTED FOR US WHICH IS BANNED
AS KIND OF RESILIENCE FUNDING AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. BUT POINT
TWO BILLION. REQUIRE AMPLE. AND
ALL OUR ROAD MAP WHAT EVERY.
WHICH WE CALL WIRING PORTFOLIO.
I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS NO
SILVER FOR TO CALIFORNIA'S WATER
. BUT ULTIMATELY IT'S BUCKSHOT
INVESTMENT WHERE WE NEED TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF. REGION
ACROSS THE STATE THE BILL THEIR
RESILIENCE TO THE WEATHER WATER
CHALLENGES RECOGNIZING THAT IT
IS NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL. I'M
WATER RESILIENCE HAS GIVEN HOW
BIG AND DIVERSE ARTS STATE AND-
THE INVESTMENT WE'VE MADE THAT
WE CAN TO MAKE PUT IT A BETTER
TO HANDLE THE DROUGHT THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY AND I SHOULD THEY WERE
VERY MUCH PLANNING FOR A THIRD
DRY YEAR OF CONTINUED DROUGHT
GIVE AND THE LATE WINTER
WEATHER. PHOTOGRAPH BETTER
POSITION TO PROTECT THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE FACING
WATER RELIABILITY CHALLENGES.
PROJECT CAN HELP RECOVER DATA
FISHING WILDLIFE AND OF COURSE-
THAT BROUGHT HIGHEST PRIORITY
ENSURING FADE. DRINKING WATER
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS- I WILL
RESULT OF THAT TWENTY ONE I. ON
THE POINT TWO BILL DOLLAR OVER
THREE YEARS BEST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO PROPOSED PACKAGE DOES
INCLUDE INVESTMENTS DISCUSSED
LAST YEAR. INCLUDING A HUNDRED
MILLION PER WATER RECYCLING
HUNDRED MILLION CHURCH IMPROVE
REGIONAL CAN BANDS MOVING WATER
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR IMPROVEMENTS TO WILDLIFE-
CONDITIONS WHILE. WHILE I
CONDITION BUT MY COLLEAGUES WILL
TALK ABOUT IN GREATER DETAIL.
ALSO OUR PROPOSAL INCLUDES
FUNDING FOR SALTON SEA
RESTORATION IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT ACT. BUT. MANAGEMENT
PROJECT AS WELL. OUR PROPOSED
BUDGET NOT ONLY AT THE YEAR OF
THE BYE BYE TWO BILL DOLLAR
COMMITMENT ALL FOR PROPOSED. AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FIFTEEN
DOLLAR OF NEW INVESTMENTS BOTH
DROP RESP AND WHAT RESULT.
CERTAINLY BILL ON THE IN THE
THAT WE MAY IN THE PAST WHAT
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON- FURNITURE
TO YOU WATER AT THE- AS POSSIBLE
. ALTHOUGH INCLUDE. HUNDRED
DOLLAR TO W. PORT LOKO WATER.
EFFORTS AND AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
MILLION BUT OF FOOD NETWORK
SECTOR WAS WILL TALK ABOUT.
IMPROVE ON FARM WATER. YOU DON'T
KNOW GOD TWENTY. ARLEDGE'S AFTER
LAW. MAKING ACT AWAY OF LIFE.
AND EVEN MENTAL MODEL HELP A
RESPOND TO THE JOB CONDITIONS
THERE ANYTHING WATER USE THAT
BUILDING WATER. ALSO EXCITED
THAT A PROPOSAL THIRTY MINUTES
VALUE MIN DOLLARS BE JUST B THE
DEPARTMENT OF RESOURCES WITH THE
AIM OF REPLACING ORNAMENT TURF.
I KIND OF A LONG NOBODY WALKS
SONIC THE TOMORROW. I SHOULD
MENTION THAT THAT PROPOSAL ALL
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION TO PART OF VISION WHILE
. I CONTINUE TO RESPOND TO AND
GET AHEAD OF IN. THANK IMPROVE
ARE OF PLANNED UNDER MANNER AND
HATCHERY THE ADDRESS THE HUMAN
WILDLIFE COUNT. AND A PRIVATE
PLAN AND ACTION TO PROTECT FISH
AND WILD. DIRECTOR BY WILL CALL
BUT TALK MORE ABOUT. YEAH
PROPOSED BUDGET. GIVEN INTO THE
FOR CAN'T CONTINUE TO INCLUDES
TWENTY MILLION TO REFINE THE
URBAN AND- COMMUNITY RELIEF FROM
. BIGGER PRO THAT WERE LAW YEAR
AND APOSS WATER RESOURCES AND
THAT GREAT GET OUT FUNDING TO
WATER AGENCIES NEED STATE
SUPPORT FOR- DRAW RESPONSE. BY
AM SO IN OTHER HIGH TWENTY MAY
DOLLARS FOR THE PROGRAMS IN
POLLS. AND THEN TWENTY FIVE NO
DOLLARS THE WATER TO. IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE BUT DRINKING
WATER IN. SUPPORT THAT ALREADY
EXISTS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN. I
BELIEVE THAT BLUE OR SHARE ASK
ABOUT TO TALK ABOUT THAT. LAST
WEEK I THOUGHT HUNDRED MILLION
OF NEW FOR. BY INCLUDE TO HONOR
FIFTEEN DOLLAR CAN. THAT WOULD
BE OUR- A PART OF THE BRAIN
BUDGET PROCESS. AT THAT POINT
WE'LL HAVE A BETTER. OF THE HIGH
- THROUGH THE END OF THE WINTER
. AND IT REALLY ON. WHERE AND
HOW THE FUNDING BE. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DOLLAR CONTAINS CAN BE
MOST THE FACT TO. PROF
INDICATIONS. AS OUR LA OFFICE
NOTED BOND USED TO BE DROP
RESILIENCE ARE GOOD BAD. EVEN IF
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN TROUT. WE
KNOW THE A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN
YOUR TIME RESPONSE THAT CAN BE.
ALL WITH A FOCUS ON BILL OUR LAW
TERM RESULT. THANKS JERICHO THE
CONTACT CARE AND I WILL TURN IT
BACK TO YOU IN MY CAR. THE LOS
SECRETARY- BLOOMFIELD. CONTINUE
TELEFILM NEWS. THANK YOU JAY
WHITE HOUSE KEY- AND MEMBERS OF
THE- REALLY EVER. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY- AND I APPRECIATE. BUT
IT'S BECAUSE IT'S REMARKS THAT
HE MADE AND ONES YOU GOING TO
HEAR. IN A MOMENT I'M FROM CHAD
HAVE SAID SECONDS ROSS- REALLY.
YOU KNOW AT WE THINK AND KINDA
COUNCIL A DEAL WITH WITH MULTI
DE AS OF CHANGE THIS IS A THAT.
IS FRONT AND CENTER- I READ A
PAUL REED THAT JUST OF CAL.
ASSOCI THE DROUGHT WE'VE BEEN WE
- BACK IMPACT OF CLIMATE AND
REALLY AS AS SEX YOU CRAVE
MENTION. YEAH THE STORM SOME
IMPROVED AUDREY OUT- BUT THEN J.
HIT AND IT ONE OF THE AND DRIEST
MY ON RACHAEL AND- TODAY IN OUR
STATE. HERE IS GOING TO BE IN
THE MID SEVEN- AND I REALLY
POINTS TO JUSTKNOW AFTER. TO
DRY A- REVS CURRENT RESERVOIRS
IS BELOW. TWENTY NINETY LEVELS
CURRENTLY- WHICH REALLY I JUST
GO THE NEW FONG WATER CONSERVE.
MOST READ THIS ALLOW LEVELS
SEVEN. THE REAL TEST- BUST OR
COME WILL COME SPRING WHEN
CONTROL RESTRICTION LIFTED. AND
RESERVOIRS CAN REFILL WITH
SNOWMELT RUNOFF- I'M BACK AS AS
WE SAW LAST YEAR SOME OF THOSE
AND BAMBER LIGHTLY HERE FROM.
OTHERS BECAUSE TODAY THAT RUNOFF
EFFICIENCY HOW DRY IT AND- YES
SOIL IS AND HOW HOT THE AIR IS
REALLY HAVE COMPLETELY CHANGED
THE MODELS THAT WE HAVE RELIED
ON IN. IN TIMES GONE BY SO. WE
CAN DEFEND SAY JACK THAT THE
WATERS REMAINS UNDER STRESS- AND
WEATHER EXTREMES WILL CONTINUE.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WE NEED A
HUNDRED AND 40% OF AVERAGE
PRECIPITATION THIS RAINY SEASON
TO GET BACK TO NORMAL IN
RESERVOIR STORAGE- AND CLIMATE
CHANGES BORDERS INCREASING AND
SUBSTANTIAL UNCERTAINTY AND BY
THE PATENT SO WITH VERY LITTLE
PRECIPITATION ON THE HORIZON.
THE STATE AND SIERRA SNOWPACK
HAS GONE FROM A HUNDRED AND 60%
OF AN AVERAGE OF THE BEGINNING
OF JANUARY TO JUST BELOW AVERAGE
ON SEPARATE FAST- DECEMBER
JANUARY AND FEBRUARY I
TYPICALLY- THREE WETTEST MONTHS
SPENT RIGHT NOW. WE JUST
CONTRADICTS HOW THE WEATHER WILL
CHANGE HOW MUCH PRECIPITATION WE
WILL GET IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS
AND HOW THAT WILL MANIFEST IN
OUR RESERVOIRS SO. WE NEED TO
USE OUR WATER RESOURCES
EFFICIENTLY AND- ONE OF THE BIG
MESSAGES I THINK BACK AT
SECRETARY ROSS. AND MYSELF IN
OLDER PEOPLE YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM TODAY CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
GONNA EMPHASIZES THAT WE NEED TO
NORMALIZE- THIS SENSE OF WATER
SCARCITY ARE WE KIND OF HAVE
GONE FROM THESE BOOMS AND BUSTS
WHERE ONE YEAH WE THINK WE'RE
GREAT. THE NEXT YEAR WILL BE
THAT WE HAVE NO WATER LEFT I'M.
SO THIS AS AS THINK HOW PREPARE
. AND WE'VE BEEN IN FOLKS. THE
OF EMERGENCY SO IN A THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE REALLY THINK
ABOUT THIS AS- I CAN TO. ISSUE
THAT NEEDS YEAR IN YEAR OUT
FUNDING YEAR IN YEAR OUT
RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT JUST DOING IT ONE YEAH
HOPING THE DROUGHTS OF THAT. AND
THEN MOVING ON- TO THE NEXT YEAR
AND THEN HAVING TO REBUILD. WHEN
WE FIND OUT WAY BACK IN DROUGHT
SO. AS WE KNOW THESE DRY
CONDITIONS INCREASE THE
CHALLENGES OF MALE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES THAT
STILL STRUGGLE TO GET ACCESS TO
CLEAN SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. I'M TO YOUR
POINT WE A VERY HE DIDN'T FOR
THIS. IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THE HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION BAND THAT WE GET
EACH YEAR FROM THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER FUND-
WE HAVE A FINANCE- AND A PUBLIC
PROCESS TO WORK OUT HOW THAT
MONEY WILL BE SPENT HOW IT IS
BEING SPENT. AND DASHBOARDS. ON
THE WEBSITE AT CHASKA WILL
HIGHLIGHT. THOSE SAE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
INVESTMENT. INCLUDING CHECK
GETTING THE MONEY OUT THE DOOR
QUICKLY- SOMETIMES AT TODD IN
GOVERNMENT WEEKS REALLY FOCUS ON
PRIORITIZING THAT MAKE EACH
OTHER MONEY GETS THE COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED IT THE MOST. MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING THINGS
LIKE CONSOLIDATING THOSE SMALL
SYSTEMS- ALL THE WAY LOOKING AT
THE RIVER JUST PROGRAM- THAT YOU
HELPED FUND IN THE LAST BUDGET
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE. SMALL
SYSTEMS THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE- OF NOT BEING ABLE TO
SEVEN CUSTOMERS. I'M BECAUSE OF
NON PAYMENT- I SUPPORTED SAYS.
AS CHAIR HAS. A GROUP OF
MENTIONED NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL MAKES CLEAR THAT WE
NEED. AN ALL OF GOVERNMENT
APPROACH ADDRESSING OUR CLIMATE
PROBLEMS. AND THAT THAT VERY
DEFINITIVELY INCLUDES DROUGHT.
BUILDING UPON THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET INVESTMENT OF FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION. THIS BUDGET
ADDS ANOTHER SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO SUPPORT.
DROUGHT RESILIENCE AND
RESPONSIVENESS AND THOSE MONIES
WILL PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE TO STRUGGLING
COMMUNITIES. AND HELP US PROTECT
THE FUTURE CRIME AND USED
DROUGHT AND FLOOD CONDITIONS.
AND A FEW MINUTES- CHESKY BILL
WILL HIGHLIGHT THESE INVESTMENTS
NOTABLY AT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. IN A JOINT- CDS EIGHT
AT THE TOWN OF WATER RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
INITIATIVES AS THE GENDER.
DESCRIBES THESE FUNDS TO BE USED
TO EXPAND AND REGIONAL THANK
COUNTY BASED DROUGHT A MAGNITUDE
PROGRAMS SUPPORT INTO. AND
PERMANENT SOLUTION TO DRINK
WATER- AND OUT AND THESE THAT A
CAB OF DROUGHT. AND FUNDED
PROGRAMS ALSO SUPPORT. WATER SO
. SMALL SYSTEM AND DOMESTIC CAN
. I'M WE FOUND OUT. THE
COMMUNITIES THAT SUFFERED AND
ALLOW TO STAR DROUGHT. STILL
SUFFERING SOME OF THE YOU KNOW
IT FEEL MANY OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THAT THE TROUT AND DID
AND WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD THROUGH
THE MORTARBOARD AND OTHER
AGENCIES PROVIDE PROVIDED
CONTINUOUS SUPPORT IN THE
INTERVENING YEARS AND SO. JUST
END BY SAYING THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS THE INCREDIBLY
CRITICAL TO OUR RESPONSE AND
PREPARATION TOOLS RESILIENCY IN
THE FACE OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
EXTREME WEATHER FLUCTUATIONS-
AND SUPER APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
AND HAPPY AT THE END OF TO MANY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES- JOHNSON ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT- SO
SECRETARY ROSS- IN OUR OUR
DISCUSSION ITEM SHOW THAT OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S ASKING FOR IN
ADDITION TO THE EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY THIS BEING SPENT FROM
LAST YEAR'S DEAL. ONLY TWENTY
FIVE GO TO. THE SWEET PROGRAM
AND THEN ANOTHER FIVE GOES TO
YOUR MOBILE IRRIGATION LAPS ON
ON CONSERVATION SO- I WOULD BE
INTERESTED TO LOOK AT YOUR VIEWS
ON THE EXIT ARTISTI ELIA WILL
POINT OUT THAT 80% WATER USES
FROM AGRICULTURE AND THERE MAY
BE. POTENTIAL FOR MORE
CONSERVATION WOULDN'T INVESTMENT
THERE BUT PLEASE GIVE US A
REPORT. RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY- I'M SPEAKING
DIRECTLY TO THAT POINT IT'S
ACTUALLY TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S PROPOSED- IN ADDITION TO
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WITHIN THE- BUDGET AGREEMENT
FROM- THIS LAST YEAR THAT WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR THE NEXT.
FISCAL YEAR FOR THE SWEET
PROGRAMS ONE OF THE THINGS I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT ITS SWEET IS
ONE OF OUR FIRST- CLIMATE SMART
ACT PROGRAMS THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE LAST ROUND IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN. SO WE'RE
BUILDING ON THE PREVIOUS
INVESTMENT TO CONTINUALLY EXPAND
ACRES THAT ARE UNDER THE MOST
PRECISE IRRIGATION
METHODOLOGIES- AND BEING ABLE TO
KEEP UP WITH HOW RAPIDLY.
AUTOMATION AND INNOVATION IS
CHANGING TO IMPROVE EVER MORE
THE WAY WE USE WATER IN
AGRICULTURE- SHE WENT TO IMPACT.
OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES OF
IMPROVEMENTS AND IRRIGATION AB
ACTUALLY RESULTED IN 14% LAST
APPLIED WATER 438% MORE CROP
PRODUCTIVITY AND VALUE OF THOSE
CLOCKS. SO WE KNOW THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT WORKS AND I
APPRECIATE THE L. A- POINTING
OUT THE IMPORTANCE OF CONTINUING
TO IMPROVE CONSERVATION AND
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY- THAT
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS WOULD
BUILD ON WHAT WE CHEST- HAVE.
BEEN ABLE TO CLOSE THIS YEAR WE
HAD AN APPLICATION PERIOD THAT
CLOSED ON JANUARY EIGHTEENTH BUT
THIS WEEK PROGRAM. WE WILL BE
ABLE TO AWARD OVER TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY PROJECTS- BUT WE HAD
A REQUEST FOR OVER FIVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PROJECTS SO IT'S STILL
A VERY. OVERSUBSCRIBED PROGRAM.
IT NOT ONLY READ. WATER YOU.
THAT REDUCES ENERGY USE WHICH
REDUCES GREENHOUSE AND IT ALSO.
IRRIGATION AND I NEW TRIP
MANAGED EFFICIENCY. I WANTED
THINGS I DID WANT TO POINT OUT
IS THAT THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IS BEING PROPOSED SPECIFICALLY
FOR TECHNICAL SYSTEMS AND DIRECT
MICRO GRANTS TO VERY SMALL
FARMERS AND PRIORITY POPULATIONS
WHICH ARE. ARE SOCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED FARMERS THIS IS
BEING PROPOSED- BUILT ON THE
SUCCESS OF THE VERY SMALL
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
DURING COPELAND TO ASSIST THIS
POPULATION BUT THE DOLLARS TO
HELP THEM. SEVEN TO NO MARKET
CIRCUMSTANCES. NO BUSINESS
PLANNING- AND KEEP THAT FIRE
GOING ON VERY VERY SMALL ACREAGE
THIS. ASSISTANCE AND DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO OUR SMALL FARMERS
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ON FARM
CONSULTATIONS EDUCATION OUT
REACH MOBILE LABS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE IRRIGATION SYSTEM MAY
HAVE IS AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE
AND WILL BUILD ON THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
HELP THESE FARMERS. APPLIED
FORCE WEEK PROGRAM I'M REALLY
PLEASED THAT OF THAT OF THE
GRANT THAT JUST CLOSED 35% OF
THE APPLICANTS THAT THIS
CATEGORY PRIORITY POPULATIONS
AND SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
FARMERS. I DO WANT TO JUST CLOSE
BY POINTING OUT THAT. BASED ON
PRELIMINARY NUMBERS OF DROUGHT
IMPACTS IN THE LAST YEAR AND A
HALF OF WATER SHORTAGES IT'S
ESTIMATED THERE ARE ABOUT. THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
ACRES OF BALLOT ACRE. ACRES THAT
HAVE BEEN BALLOT WHICH WAS IN
ALL A DOLLARS IN LOST RATHER.
AND SO ONE ON FARMS. SO OUR WORK
CHANGE. IT IS DOING A GOOD AND
WE ARE VERY PROUD OF THAT
SUCCESS OF THE OF THE PROGRAM TO
DATE. AND I WOULD NEVER TURN
DOWN ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO
INVEST IN THE RAPIDLY CHANGING
TECHNOLOGY BUT WE FEEL THAT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO MEET THE
NEEDS AS THEY HAVE BEEN
SURPRISED BY OUR FARMING
COMMUNITY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR. THANK YOU. I'M SURE
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES WILL HAVE A
QUESTION OVER THE THREE HUNDRED
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE NOT FUNDED
WITH THE ADDITIONAL MONEY THAT
THAT YOU HAVE BUT- WE'LL GET TO
TAP. ALL RIGHT- CHERISHED GIVE
ALL OF YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE MORE
THAN A PASSING INTEREST OF THE-
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S TAKEN OUT A CAP AND TRADE
OR THE BUDGET PROPOSES TO TAKE
OUT A CAP AND TRADE. RATHER THAN
YOU KNOW THE MONEY THAT'S COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
MONEY THAT'S COMING IN THIS
BUDGET THAT WOULD. ALLOW CAP
ENTRY TO BE USED FR OTHER
WORTHY PROJECTS SO. I'LL LET YOU
GIVE YOUR REPORT WITH TASKS-
THAT LOOMING IN THE BACK IN THE
PACK IN THE- BACKGROUND. APRIL
WE SHOULD THAT NOT SURE WHAT
BECAUSE AND- NO THE WAS IS A WE
HAVE BEEN A OPPORTUNITY DO IT IS
THREE WATER CLIMB AT IN A WAY
THAT IS VERY RE I KNOW FOR MANY
SIR THIS PASS YEAR AS WE HAD TO
RISK TO A CAN THROUGH THE STATE
AND MANY COMMUNITIES- LAST LEVEL
- I KNOW YOU THESE YEAR WHERE I
THINK WE HAVE TO BE MIND THAT WE
MOST RECENTLY JUST WENT THROUGH-
AN INCREDIBLE PROUD OF RECORD-
THE HEIGHT OF WHICH WITHIN
TWENTY FOURTEEN TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN SO VERY RECENTLY- AND
WHAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY IS THE
BENEFIT OF A LOT OF- CONTINUE ON
THE PATH FOR. FROM THAT TIME-
I'M PROUD OF THE FACT THAT
ACTUALLY THE STATE WATER BOARD
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN HAS BEEN
ABLE TO INVEST NEARLY TEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN THE STATE-
THAT IMPACT INCLUDES LOANS AND
GRANTS FROM THE MAJOR STATE
REVOLVING LOAN- PROJECTS- THE
CLEAN WATER SRF AND THE DRINKING
WATER SRF BUT ALSO PROP ONE BOND
DOLLARS ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THERE- THAT ARE
CRITICALLY GOING INTO AND
CREATING A RESILIENCY TO DROUGHT
NOW AS WE'VE JUST WENT AGAIN
THROUGH THIS LAST YEAR- SO- I
THINK THAT WHAT YOU KNOW I'D
LIKE TO MAKE SURE AND MAKE NOTE
OF HERE IS THAT. WE ARE NEEDING
TO CONTINUE TO PREPARE FOR DRY
CONDITIONS THIS SUMMER- YOU KNOW
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY OF
IS BEING ABLE TO TOGGLE ON AND
OFF DROUGHT OR FLOOD I
INVESTMENT SO WE'RE NEEDING TO
BE MAKING IN OUR SYSTEMS AND
INSTEAD IT'S REALLY BAD AS
SECRETARY. PROFIT SAID ALLISTER
VIEW OF THE CHAO THAT COME
CHANGE UP ON A WILL SYSTEM. AND
YES THE STATE AND AFFORDABLE
FUNDED ONE. OF WHAT IS THAT TEN
BILL DOLLARS. OVER THE LAST
YEARS. I IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT WE'RE IN THE SECOND. WE'VE
NOW GONE THROUGH TWO YEARS OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT. AND ARE
VERY PROUD ACTUALLY OF WHAT THIS
INVESTMENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
ALLOW US TO DO. AND REALLY
BRIDGING THE GAP EQUITY GAP
DISTRICT. AND YOU KNOW EXISTED
FOR DECADES IN OUR COMMUNITIES-
TED TED TED NOT JUST RESPOND TO
DROUGHT. BUT TO RESPOND TO THE
MANY OTHER STRESSORS THAT I KNOW
OUR DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS BASED
INCLUDING. FORCING CONTAMINANTS.
ARE EMERGING CONTAMINANTS OF
CONCERN LIKE P. FAST ALL THINGS
THAT REALLY ARE STRESS THE
AFFORDABILITY OF OUR WATER
SYSTEMS. AND WASTEWATER SYSTEMS
AND WAYS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO BE
VERY MINDFUL OF- BUT HERE
TALKING ABOUT TRUMP AND OUR ARE
DROWNING VESTMENTS- AGAIN I'M
PROUD THAT IT'S A CONTINUAL LOVE
OF EFFORT HERE. KNOWING THAT-
THERE'S ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS WE CURRENTLY HAVE-
OUGHT. FOR PROVIDING I HOLD
WATER TOO BECAUSE OF DRY WELLS
FROM THIS LAST SUMMER AND FROM
EVEN UP. SOME WELLS FROM FROM
PREVIOUS- TROUT WHERE WERE WERE-
REALLY FORTUNATE FOR THE- D. V.
COLLABORATION AT THAT WE HAVE
WITH SELF HELP ENTERPRISES.
WHICH WAS REALLY DEVELOPED IN
THE LAST DROUGHT IN HERE A LOT.
TO RESPOND QUICKLY- IN THE FACE
OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING CONDITIONS
. THIS PAST SUMMER- SOME OF
THOSE EIGHT HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS-
CURRENTLY MONTHLY. ARE
EXPENDABLE A MILLION DOLLARS
NEARLY- IN THE PROVISION OF ALL
WATER SO. WE HAVE TO BE VERY
MINDFUL. THAT BETTER THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT- MAINLY DOMESTIC
WELLS IN STATE SMALLS- BUT IT'S
A CONTINUUM OF RESPONSE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES WHERE. YOU HAVE TO
MISTER WELLS YEP STATES FALLS.
AND THEN YOU HAVE LARGER SYSTEMS
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO ALSO
RESPOND TO. AND THEY'RE THANKFUL
FOR THE- COORDINATION THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES.
WHERE WHERE. WHERE BEING
MINDFUL. IT'S NOT JUST ALL THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE. THAT HAVE
AS WE ALSO DRAW DOLLARS THAT YOU
TO YOU ARE WE ALSO HAVE THESE
LAW PROBE. THAT WITH MY PART
INTEREST LAW- COMING DOWN THE
LINE WORKS TO RECEIVE BILLION OF
DOLLARS FROM THE FIVE
GOVERNMENT. TO IN OUR DRINKING
SYSTEM INVEST ARE WASTE SYSTEM.
AND CONTINUE AND HERE YOU KNOW
THE BUT THOSE. WATER RECYCLING
AS WELL- WHICH IS SUCH A GREAT
COME. OF OUR RESPONSE FOR AT
LARGE- TO DROUGHT SO THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION THAT ASKING FOR AN
EMERGENCY DROUGHT RESPONSE WILL
ALLOW US TO AGAIN EXPAND. THIS
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE HERE MAINLY
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
THROUGH SELF HELP. AND OTHER-
LOCAL SERVICE PROVIDERS IT
REALLY HELPED EXPAND THE
CAPACITY OF THE STATE TO ENSURE
THAT COMMUNITIES- ARE ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO GO DRY. AND HERE WE
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT. OUR
DROUGHT RESPONSE COVERS NOT
JUST. THAT DRINKING WATER SIDE
BUT ALSO- AT THE LANDSCAPE LEVEL
AS WE ADMINISTER WATER RIGHTS-
AND THEY'RE PROUD OF THEFACT
THAT. HERE THE STATE BOARD THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY IT IS
ACTIVELY ADMINISTERING- WATER
RIGHTS WERE LOOKING AT'S WHAT'S
HYDROLOGICALLY AVAILABLE WE'RE
MATCHING UP WHAT WE UNDERSTAND
IS. THAT THE DIVERSIONS AND
PRIORITY OF. THE BURGERS AND
WATERSHED. AND CURTAILING AS
NEEDED GIVEN THE INCREDIBLE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS THAT THAT WE
HAVE. THAT IS ACTUALLY STE THE
FIRST TIME IN HISTORY BUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS ACTIVELY
DOING THAT- AND SO I JUST WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S BEEN. A
VERY DIFFICULT YEAR FOR A NUMBER
OF COMMUNITIES- IN THE STATE
BUT- COORDINATING HERE WITH OUR
SISTER AGENCIES WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO S. SECRETARY ROSS SAID.
REALLY BE ABLE TO FILL THE NEED-
BUT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THE
SUMMER WILL BRING. AND HERE I
CONTINUE TO PLAN FOR WORST CASE
SCENARIOS THERE. SO THANK YOU
CHAIR. THANK YOU- BUT MOVE TO
OUR NEXT NEXT GUEST THAT WOULD
BE A THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER ARE
RESEARCH WE HAVE TO. AND NAME IT
ARGENTINA MATH. GOOD MORNING AT
CHEROKEE SKI A NAY MISS- LIKE
JONI THAT'S ALL I'M REAL I MUST
BE OLDER A LOT OF PEOPLE AT ME
LIKE WHO HECK WAS. RODWAY GEO
FOR SOME. IT'S I HONORED TO BE
THIS TO YOU ALL- AND WORK- THAT
COW IS TO SOME OUR CA- DURING
THIS YEAR OF DROUGHT- AS THE SO
SPOKESMAN- THIS IS- CERTAIN A
THIRD YEAR OF DROUGHT THE
DROUGHT IS NOT OVER- BY ANY
STRETCH AND NOT ONLY IS IT NOT
OVER I THINK WE'VE WE'VE
EXPERIENCED- THE WEATHER
WHIPLASH THAT CREATES A LOT OF
CHALLENGES AROUND- HOW WE PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE. ALSO IN MY VIEW
OFFERS A DEGREE OF- HOPE THAT IF
WE DO THE RIGHT THINGS AND MAKE
THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS- OUR
COMMUNITIES CAN BECOME DROUGHT
RESILIENCE AND REALLY WEATHERED
THESE VERY INTENSE PERIODS WHICH
WE ANTICIPATE- COMING MORE
FREQUENTLY AND LASTING LONGER-
BERMAN. OFFERS OF ALL OVER OUR
FOR- GIVE YOU AN UP. AS TO WHERE
WE ARE- YOUR COMMENTS. ABOUT THE
KIND OF- WE HAVE THREE. GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON- THANKS TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND THEIR SUPPORT IN THE
PREVIOUS- BUDGET CYCLE- THOSE
ARE SMALL COMMUNITIES ARE URBAN
AND MULTI BENEFIT- PROJECTS AND
THEN PROJECTS THAT SUPPORT A
BETTER GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT.
SO FOR OUR SMALL COMMUNITIES AS
THE OTHER PRESENTERS HAVE
MENTIONED TYPICALLY IN DROUGHT
IT REALLY IS OUR SMALL
COMMUNITIES RURAL AREAS THAT
EXPERIENCED. THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS IN TERMS OF WATER
SUPPLY RELIABILITY IN CLEAN
WATER. AT THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
PASSED THE SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
TWO WHICH DIRECTS THE DEPARTMENT
TO ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE- IN
CONJUNCTION WITH STYLE
STAKEHOLDERS FROM SMALL
COMMUNITIES. TO HELP US
ESTABLISH A PATH FORWARD FOR
INVESTING SO THAT IS THAT IS
HAPPENING BUT IT IS NOT SLOWING
DOWN THE THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
DO RELATIVE TO GRANT MAKING- AND
THAT IS BASED ON- IMPORTANT
REPORTING THAT WE'VE DONE- IN
THAT WE DID TO THE LEGISLATURE
OUT LAST YEAR LAST MARCH WHICH
ESTABLISHED THEY ARE A LOOK. AT
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THE
MOST VULNERABLE SO WITH THAT AS
A ROAD MAP IS THE DEPARTMENT
HAS- EXPENDED ABOUT NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
PREVIOUS BUDGET- WE'VE MADE
FIFTY GRANTS- TO WORTHY PROJECTS
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES. THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE ANTICIPATE-
SPENDING THE REMAINDER OF THOSE
DOLLARS IN TWO ROUNDS OF GRANTS
ONCE IN MARCH AND. ANOTHER IN
APRIL SO WE DO YOU AND- THAT- TO
HAVE MILLION THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED BY THE- IN THE LAST
BUDGET WILL BE COME. DISTRIBUTED
OUT BY THE END OF THIS FISCAL
YEAR- OR THE URBAN AND- A MULTI
BENEFIT PROJECTS BUT I SHOULD
SAY FOR THE SMALLS OF SMALL
PROJECTS ARE SMALL COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE RECEIVED ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS-
OF REQUESTS TO DATE. SO WE
DEFINITELY KNOW THAT THERE IS A
REAL NEED OUT THERE FOR QUALITY
PROJECTS TO FUND. FOR OUR URBAN
AND MULTI BENEFIT PROGRAM THAT
IS TRAILING BEHIND FOR A COUPLE
OF IMPORTANT REASONS. WE HAVE
MADE- GRANTS TO TWENTY FIVE
PROJECTS FOR ABOUT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WE ANTICIPATE ANOTHER
ROUND OF GRANTS IN MARCH THAT
WILL BE MUCH BIGGER- WE DID
RECEIVE ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN REQUEST IN
OUR FIRST FELICITATION- WHAT'S
BEHIND THAT THOUGH I THINK THERE
ARE SOME PROJECTS THAT. THAT
WERE ELIGIBLE AND PART OF THE
REASON THEY WEREN'T ELIGIBLE IS
THERE WASN'T THAT READINESS- BY
THE WATER DISTRICTS TO COMPLETE
THE APPLICATION. PAST TWO MONTHS
WE MADE THAT FIRST ROUND IN
DECEMBER ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE
BEEN DOING OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS IS WORKING WITH THOSE
FOLKS- TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR-
THEIR APPLICATIONS ARE COMPLETE
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE YEAH-
ACTUALLY MAKE MORE GRANT AWARDS.
THIS MARCH AND WE DO ANTICIPATE
. REALLY SIGNIFICANT- CHUNK OF
THAT FUNDING WILL WILL BE PART
OF THIS NEXT ROUND OF GRANTS-
FOR BOTH THE SMALL. COMMUNITY
GRANT PROGRAM WE ARE WORKING
INTENSELY WITH OUR TRIBAL NATION
PARTNERS- WE HAVE ABOUT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND A GRANT
APPLICATIONS THAT WE'RE WORKING
ON WITH TRIBAL NATIONS THAT FIT
INTO THAT SMALL COMMUNITY
CATEGORY AND THEN FOR OUR URBAN
A MULTI BENEFITS WE A PROGRAM WE
HAVE SET ASIDE ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. TO ADDRESS
NEEDS AN UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES- AGAIN OUR
EXPECTATION IS THAT FOR THOSE
TWO GRANT PROGRAMS I'M D. W. R.
WILL HAVE ALL THOSE GRANT MONIES
BY THE END OF THIS FISCAL YEAR.
FOR SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER-
JUST THIS BUDGET REQUEST
INCLUDES- ANOTHER SET OF FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS THAT FOCUSED OR
PROJECTS THAT FOCUS ON
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE- A COUPLE
IMPORTANT NOTES ABOUT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS COMPLETED- WHAT
WE CALL FLYOVER- WE- THE
INTERESTED- TECH- WHERE WE
ACTUALLY MEASURE- SOILS. FROM
FROM HELICOPTERS AND WE CAN'T
THAT HELPS US IDENTIFY THE
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
THE MOST SUITABLE CONDITIONS FOR
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE WE HAVE
THAT DATA- THAT WORK WAS DONE
OVER THE SUMMER THAT WAS VERY
MUCH IN FORM- OUR GRANT MAKING
IN THIS SPACE. BECAUSE WE KNOW
GROUND WATER RECHARGE IS GOING
TO BE ESSENTIAL IT'S NOT THE
ONLY THING THAT WE NEED TO BE
DOING IN CALIFORNIA TO BRING
GROUNDWATER BASINS INTO
SUSTAINABILITY BUT IS IT IS ONE
REAL CRUCIAL PILLAR- AND SO ARE
OUR BUDGET. REQUEST THIS YEAR
INCLUDES ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO
HELP SUPPORT THOSE KINDS OF
GRANT APPLICATIONS THEY WILL BE
COMING FROM THE LOCAL
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
pPLANS. THE DEPARTMENT- AS YOU
MAY BE AWARE- THE DEPARTMENT.
HAD EARLY DEADLINES FOR OUR
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
GROUNDWATER BASINS LARGELY IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BUT OTHER
PLACES ALONG THE COAST. WE HAVE
RECEIVED ALL OF THOSE PLANS ARE
THE DEPARTMENT HAS- RENDERED ITS
JUDGMENT AS TO THE ADEQUACY OF
THOSE PLANS. BUT THE IMPORTANT
POINT THERE IS. AFTER THOSE
PLANS ARE SUBMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT THEY ARE SELF
IMPLEMENTING AND SO WE DO HAVE
A- A REAL PIPELINE IF YOU WILL
OF- OF PROJECTS THAT NEED TO BE
ADVANCED THROUGH THIS KIND OF.
FUNDING PROGRAM I'M SO THAT'S
WHERE D. W. R. IS WITH OUR OUR
GRANT DOLLARS TO DATE- WE ALSO
HAVE A COUPLE OTHER IMPORTANT
REQUEST A BUDGET REQUEST. ONE IS
FOR CONSERVATION AS THE
SECRETARY MENTIONED. WE HAVE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
REQUESTED FOR OUR URBAN- WATER
AGENCIES TO DO MORE WITH WHAT
USE- THERE'S A OF RIGHT NOW ON
PAYERS AND THE- BEHIND THIS
PROGRAM IS- ESPECIALLY SOME OF
OUR LARGER URBAN WATER
DISTRICTS- THEY DO HAVE IDEAS
THAT WE THINK ARE- OUR NOVEL.
AND THAT ARE ONES THAT WE WANT
TO PROVIDE EFFECTIVELY SEED
MONEY IF YOU WILL FOR IDEAS THAT
WE CAN- WE CAN EVENTUALLY TAKE
TO SCALE IN CALIFORNIA. FOR OUR
SMALL DISTRICTS WE DO HAVE
TWENTY FOUR OF TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM REQUEST
IN FOR US SMALL WATER AGENCIES
TO ALSO DO THAT- IMPORTANT
CONSERVATION WORK. AND THEN
FINALLY WE HAVE A SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST IN A FOR.
A TURF REMOVAL PROGRAMS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE DID IN THE
PREVIOUS DOUGHT- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD DO IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH WATER DISTRICTS
WHO ALSO HAVE. THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS UP AND RUNNING AS WE
MOVE INTO A THIRTY YEAR OF
DROUGHT. AND THEN LASTLY I WOULD
SAY- TO YOUR TO YOUR EARLIER
POINT TO SECRETARY ROSS ABOUT
AGRICULTURAL CONSERVATION- DO
KNOW THAT- I AM WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMISSIONER OF
THE BUREAU OF RECLAMATION. ABOUT
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT COULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THESE VALLEY PROJECT
AND ITS WATER CONTRACTORS ARE
PREDOMINANTLY AGRICULTURAL
CONTRACTORS TO PARTICULARLY
DURING DROUGHT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES PLAY A ROLE IN
HELPING US TO REDUCE
AGRICULTURAL WATER USAGE. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
WILL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
SECRETARY ROSS AND OUR FEDERAL
COUNTERPARTS BOTH WITH THE
BUREAU OF RECLAMATION AND- US
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE. SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON THESE
IMPORTANT TOPICS HERE TODAY AND-
I CERTAINLY. YOU YOU LAB CLEAR I
THE- FOR I'M GETTING DOLLARS THE
DOOR- AS I WITH ALL DELIBERATE
SPEED PARTICULAR. IN THE CONTEXT
OF. THE DROUGHT EMERGENCY THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU AND WE WILL BE ASKING
ONCE WE GO THROUGH ALL THAT
ALEJO WILL BE ASKING. EACH OF
YOU ABOUT THE- THREE POINT EIGHT
BILLION THAT IT'S COMING TO
CALIFORNIA ON WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN IN THE
COMPETITIVE MONEY THERE WAS.
SILENCE ON YOU KNOW WITH THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
COMPETITIVE- IN THE IN THE WATER
AREA THAT ON THE NATURAL WE GET
1012% BUT WHAT. I'LL DO THE
BUDGET REQUEST THAT YOU'RE
MAKING THE ADDITIONAL QUESTION
MAKING NOW. WE'VE BEEN TO WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
PROPOSING MORE YOU THINK THAT
YOU'RE STRONG AS IN EACH YEAR
DEPARTMENTS ARE YOUR AGENCIES TO
COMPETE WITH THAT BUT- I DON'T
WANT TO GET A HEAD OF US MYSELF
AND I'M- GOING TO GO TO THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE. SUPPORT AND
DIRECTOR BOTTOM- I WILL NOTE
THAT ON OUR LITTLE SHEET THAT WE
HAVE YOU'RE- THIRTY TWO MILLION
FIVE HUNDRED. THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR MEDIA TROUT SUPPORT OVER
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION HAS ALREADY
GONE OUT THE DOOR AS WELL AS THE
EIGHTEEN MILLION THAT WE HAD
FOR- HERE DEPARTMENT IN A NON
GRANT OFFERINGS YOU'VE GOT FOR
ALMOST FIFTEEN MILLION OF THE
EIGHTEEN MILLION THERE SO.
EVIDENTLY IF WE GIVE YOU MONEY
YOU WILL SPEND THAT- BUT GO
AHEAD YOU HAVE YOUR REPORT. CAN
CAN CONFIRM TWO THINGS CHAIR YES
IF MONEY IS ALLOCATED WE WILL
SPEND A PROBABLY TWO GOOD
RESULTS AND SECOND. IN
COMPARISON TO THE LAST- MOST
MAJOR DROUGHT TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN BACK THEN I
WOULD ARGUE THE STATE CARRIED
MUCH LARGER ROLE RELATIVE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH WAS
SUFFERING A DIFFERENT BUDGET
DYNAMIC THEN WE NOW FIND
OURSELVES IN. TWENTY TWENTY TO
WEAR DIRECTOR NEMETH IN THE
SECRETARIES ARE WORKING HARD TO
ENSURE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
CONTRIBUTES IN THIS SPACE AND A
MATCHING STYLE WITH THE STATE.
FROM THERE THANK YOU CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHUCK BONHAM ON THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. IN FIVE
MINUTES OR LESS I'D LIKE TO MAKE
FOUR MAIN POINTS ABOUT OUR
PROPOSAL. THE FIRST POINT IS
IT'S A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
PROPOSAL BY THE ADMINISTRATION
TO PROVIDE OUR DEPARTMENT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IS SURGICALLY PLANNED
IT'S ARGUED IT TO ACTIONS WHICH
FOR TO PRODUCE RETURNS. IT'S
SPECIFIC THESE ARE ACTIONS YOU
CAN MEASURE THE RESULTS OF. IN
IN A BROADER CONTEXT IT'S
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE SMALLER
AMOUNTS WITHIN THE TOTAL DROUGHT
PROPOSAL ARE YOU HAVE IN FRONT
OF YOU. IT ALSO ACCOMPLISHES A
PARALLEL OBJECTIVE THAT I THINK
YOU AND I SHARE. AS YOU KNOW YOU
HAD OUR DEPARTMENT WORKING ON
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING FOR MANY
YEARS I SUBMITTED A REPORT LAST
YEAR WHICH ILLUSTRATES THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT'S MISSION
RESPONSIBILITIES AND CURRENT
CAPACITY IS A LARGE GAP. ONE WAY
TO SOLVE THAT GAP IS TO DO ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS IN EQUIPMENT
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO MODERNIZE
AND GET US CLOSER TO DOING WHAT
WE NEED TO DO. SECOND POINT THIS
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THIS PROPOSED FOLLOWS YOUR LEAD
LAST YEAR YOUR LEADERSHIP
WORKING WITH THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION THE GOVERNOR
PRODUCED A COMMITMENT OF FORTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS TO OUR
DEPARTMENT FOR DROUGHT RELIEF
WE'RE SPENDING IT WISELY WE HAVE
IT ON A TRANSPARENCY KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY SPREADSHEET THEY
WERE ABLE TO ENGAGE WITH YOU ON
AND THE FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS LAST YEAR IS THE
TEMPLATE FOR WHAT WE WOULD DO
WITH THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. IN THIS YEAR. THIRD
POINT THESE ARE GOOD THINGS THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
REALLY GOES TO THESE CORE AREAS
THERE'S IMMEDIATE MITIGATION
NEED WE DO TRANSLOCATIONS OF
ANIMALS THAT ARE THREATENED BY
DRYING LANDSCAPES WE GO OUT AND
RESCUE ANIMALS BETTER IN HARM'S
WAY BECAUSE RIVERS AND CREEKS
AND WETLANDS ARE DRAMATICALLY
SHRINKING. WE BRING THESE
ANIMALS IN MANY CASES INTO A NO
WAS ARC OF OUR OWN FACILITIES
THE UC SYSTEM'S ALL THE ZOOS AND
AQUARIA. SAVE THEM FROM DROUGHT
AND THEN REINTRODUCE THEM BACK
TO NATURE WHEN IT'S WHETHER. WE
ARE ENGAGED IN THE RUSSIAN RIVER
ON VOLUNTARY PROGRAMS WORKING
WITH WATER USERS TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO BALANCE USE THE WATER
FOR WINEGROWING. AND TO SAVE SAM
. WE'RE INCREASING HABITAT
PROJECTS REALLY GOOD EXAMPLES
INCLUDE IN THE SCOTT RIVER IN
THE KLAMATH WORKING WITH THREE
MAIN GROUNDWATER PUMPERS.
COMPENSATE THEM FOR BEARING
THEIR PUMPING THIS YEAR WHICH
ARGUABLY SAVED BECAUSE SALMON IN
THE SCOTT RIVER. AND THIS
IMMEDIATE MITIGATION OF FORTY
SIX POINT EIGHT MILLION A SUB
PART OF THE SEVENTY FIVE HELPS
U WITH WILDLIFE HUMAN CONFLICTS
TAKE THE TAHOE BASIN EXAMPLE.
IT'S A MASHUP OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE. CHANGING CLIMATE
CONDITIONS BEARS THAT ARE NO
LONGER HIBERNATING AND
INTERFACING ONE OF THE MOST
TOURIST DRIVEN SPOTS ON THE
PLANET. AND WE ARE FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
ABOUT SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
HUMAN WILDLIFE CONFLICTS A YEAR
THIS IMMEDIATE MITIGATION MONEY
LETS US MANAGE THAT DYNAMIC
BETTER. SECOND MANDATORY IMPROVE
RESILIENCY OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION ABOUT FIFTEEN MILLION
WOULD GO TO IMPROVING OUR OWN
STATE LANDS. A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING WE'VE JUST DONE.
FORECAST WHAT WE WOULD DO IS
THAT ARE ASKED WILDLIFE AREA UP
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WORKING
WITH CALIFORNIA WATERFALL. WE
WENT OUT TO REPLACE FAILING
WATER CONTROL STRUCTURES. ARE
ADJACENT MANAGED WETLAND UNITS
REPAIRED HOLES SYSTEMS SETBACK
CERTAIN WETLAND UNITS ALL FOR
THE BENEFIT A WATERFALL IN WATER
USE EFFICIENCY ON OUR LAND LINE.
ANOTHER WAY. WE DO THIS WORK IS
ON PRIVATE LANDS. JUST THIS PAST
YEAR WHICH WE REPORT ON IN WHICH
FORECAST WHAT WILL DO IN THE
DAYS AHEAD. WHEN WE ENTERED INTO
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE RICE
COMMISSION AND LANDOWNERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. OF BIRD RETURNS
WHERE WE COMPENSATE FARMERS TO
FLOOD THEIR FIELDS IN WILDLIFE
FRIENDLY WAYS THE SUPPORT SURE
BOARDS AND WATERFALLS AND LISTS
OF REQUIREMENTS. LET AREA THE
SQUARE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION.
HATCHERIES AND FISH PRODUCTION.
LAST YEAR WE PICKED UP AND MOVED
OFF ALMOST SEVENTEEN MILLION
SALMON FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HATCHERIES DOWN INTO THE COASTAL
ESTUARIES SO THAT WE WOULD
IMPROVE THEIR SURVIVAL CHANCE.
WE NEED TO DO THAT SAME THING
AGAIN THIS COMING YEAR. AND WHAT
WE'VE ALSO BEEN ABLE TO DO WHICH
FORECAST WHAT WE WOULD DO IS
BEGIN TO MODERNIZE ALL OF OUR
HATCH. TO GIVE YOU A QUICK.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF REPLACING
ALMOST A HUNDRED HATCHERY FLEET
ASSETS FISH STOCKING TRUCKS
TRAILERS VEHICLES. PICKUP TRUCKS
GETTING MODERN HIGH CAPACITY
TRIPLOID EXHORTING MACHINES. ALL
OF WHICH ARE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS THAT ALSO FIX OUR S.
B. B. CHALLENGES ON OUR GAP. SO
THOSE ARE THE THREE REASONS I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SURGICAL FOLLOWS
YOUR LEAD FROM LAST YEAR. TO DO
MORE GOOD THINGS HERE'S MY
FOURTH AND FINAL POINT. WHEN YOU
CONSIDER SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
BASED ON THOSE THREE POINTS THE
FINAL POINT I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
IS ALL OF THIS WORK IS REALLY.
THE FIGHT EXTINCTION. AND
SIGNATURE AND IT SEEMS LIKE A
PRUDENT AND MORE TO LAST MINUTE
THE SCALE SEVENTY FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR AND I
THINK THE NEXT ONE OF THE MANY
SPEAKERS NEXT IN THE QUEUE IS
DAVID CHIU BASIN. OKAY LET'S
LET'S GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION AND WE HAVE-
DIRECTOR SHOULD BOSNIAN GOOD
GOOD MORNING DOT AND YOU'VE GOT
THE- I JUST HAD IT HERE SECOND.
THEY EVER CHANGING RIVER-
COMMENTED UPON YOUR GATED PLAN
REPURPOSE SING FORTY BILLION
DOLLARS I SEE THE ALEJO AND
STAFFERS COMMENTS ON THAT WE'LL
GET INTO THAT LATER BUT PLEASE.
FORGIVE ENTERED NOW. WELL THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- YES I'M PRESENTING
THIS MORNING ON THE BUDGET
REQUEST FOR- THAT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A SECOND ROUND OF
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S
MULTI BENEFIT LAND REPURPOSE IN
PROGRAM. SO LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
PROVIDED THE FIRST APPROPRIATION
OF FIFTY MILLION FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND I CAN'T EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH HOW TIMELY AND IMPORTANT
THIS PROGRAM IS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACTS THAT WERE SEEN FROM. THE
LOSS OF AGRICULTURE PRODUCTION
DUE TO- REDUCED GROUNDWATER
SUPPLY AS WE DEAL WITH THE
ONGOING DROUGHT AND SEGMENTATION
. THIS IS- LET'S NOT ONLY
AFFECTS THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY BUT ALSO THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHERE AGRICULTURE
REALLY IS THAT. A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE OF JOBS AND ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN THOSE AREAS. SO TO
GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE SCALE OF
THIS ISSUE THAT THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTIMATES THAT BETWEEN HALF A
MILLION TO A MILLION ACRES OF
LAND WILL BE FOLLOWED DUE TO
REDUCED GROUNDWATER
AVAILABILITY. SO THIS IS A
CRITICAL TOOL TO HELP REGION'S
BRING THEIR GROUNDWATER BASINS
INTO A SUSTAINABLE BALANCE- THE
EMPHASIS WILL BE ON PROJECTS
THAT BENEFIT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND ADDRESS OTHER RE
PURPOSING PRIORITIES IDENTIFIED
BY- BY THOSE REGIONS- AND I
REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS ABOUT EMPOWERING REGIONS
TO REALLY. DETERMINE WHAT THEIR
FUTURE IS AND TO DEVELOP THOSE
STRATEGIES SO THE FUNDING WILL
PROVIDE FUNDS TO REGIONAL
ENTITIES. THAT WELL CONVENE
VOLUNTARY LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS WHO
WILL BE TASKED VAN WITH A
DEVELOPING THEIR STRATEGIES THAT
IDENTIFIES THE REDUCE OPTIONS
FOR THESE LANDS THAT MAKE UP
SHALLOW- AND THAT CAN NO LONGER
BE IRRIGATED- SO THE PROJECTS
THAT WE- WE THINK WILL BE
RESULTING FROM THE STRATEGIES
WILL DRIVE TOWARD OUTCOMES THAT
IMPROVES. THE COMMUNITY BENEFIT-
THE ECOLOGICAL OUTCOMES AND AS
WELL AS ECONOMIC. WELL BEING IN
THESE IN THESE AREAS- SO IT'S
THROUGH THE AGAIN THIS REGIONAL
APPROACH TO THE PROBE AND POWER
LEADERS FROM BOTH THOSE YOU KNOW
THE LANDSCAPE THE FARMERS AND
RANCHERS THE TRIBES. AND THOSE
WHO WILL FACE THE MOST IMPACT
FROM THESE LANDS GOING SHALLOW
AND THEN BEING REPURPOSED. FIVE
SO WE ARE OUT TO ADVANCE THIS
WORK WE ARE CONVENE AN
INTERAGENCY GROUP WE HAVE
CONVENE AN INTERAGENCY GROUP OF
ADVISORS- AND THEY'RE HELPING US
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM ARM IN
ARM SO WE ARE WORKING WITH STATE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES THAT
INTERSECTS. ARE ON THESE ISSUES
THAT ARE THAT ARE GOING TO BE
CHALLENGES GOING FORWARD AND IN
THESE PARTS OF THE STATE THAT SO
WHAT WHAT WHAT HAVE THIS
AGRICULTURAL. PRODUCTION AS MUCH
AS IT HAS TODAY- THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS INTEREST OF COURSE
AND NEED FOR THIS PROGRAM. AND
FRANKLY TO BE TO CANDID YEAH
LOOKING THAT. SCALE THE PROBLEM
WITH THE REALITY THAT THIS IS A
WHOLE NEW FIELD OF WORK. SO WE
ARE IN A POSITION WHERE WE
REALLY NEED TO BOTH MOVE QUICKLY
AND MAKE RESOURCES AVAILABLE. TO
MEET THE REGIONAL NEEDS AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. SO TO UNDERSTAND
HOW THIS PROGRAM SHOULD BE
STRUCTURED WE HAVE BEEN PUSHING
HARD ON OUTREACH- AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THOSE
NEEDS THAT ARE OUT THERE FOR
THESE SERVICES IN FOR THIS
PROGRAM. I THAT THOSE PEOPLE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
INPUT SO WE HAVE PUBLISHED OR
DRAFT GUIDELINES AND WE HAD A
TWO MONTH COMMENT PERIOD ON
THOSE. AND THEN WE'VE HELD COURT
FOR PUBLIC WORKSHOPS THREE
TRIBAL ONLY WORKSHOPS AND HAVE
PRESENTED AT. NUMEROUS PUBLIC
MEETINGS AND CONFERENCES LIKE
THOSE HOSTED BY THE ASSOCIATION
OF. CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICT. AND SO
WITH ALL OF THIS AND BUT WE WILL
BE RELEASING THE FINAL
GUIDELINES AND R. F. P. THIS
MONTH. AND WE EXPECT TO BE
MAKING AWARDS FOR THIS PROGRAM
IN MAY. I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
BASED ON THE INTEREST IN THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE- ARE GETTING
THAT WE EXPECT TO BE
OVERSUBSCRIBED FOR THIS FIRST
ROUND. WHICH WILL DISTRIBUTE THE
ENTIRE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS-
AND WE EXPECT THAT IT'S LIKELY-
IF WE GET FUNDING IN THIS ROUND
THAT THAT WILL ALSO BE
OVERSUBSCRIBED. SO I APPRECIATE
A CHANCE TO DESCRIBE THIS
PROGRAM AND I KNOW WE'RE
PROBABLY MOVING TO QUESTIONS I'M
GLAD TO ANSWER THOSE I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. COMMITTEE HAS A
RICH HISTORY OF ASKING QUESTIONS
BUT- BEFORE WE GET THERE I'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THEN I'M GOING TO
GO TO THE ALEJO AND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. LET'S
PAINT A BIGGER PICTURE NOW OKAY
WE JUST HEARD FROM YOUR AGENCIES
IN YOUR SECRETARIES WE'VE GOT.
THREE POINT THREE MILLION THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
ON WHAT HAPPENED WORST WORST THE
MONEY'S GOING ON WE GOT ANOTHER
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION THAT
YOU WANT TO GO NGUYEN.
SIMULTANEOUSLY WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET THREE POINT
SIX BILLION FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IS COMING AND WE'RE
GUARANTEED TO GET SIX HUNDRED.
FIFTY MILLION BUT- UNDER MY
COUNTY. WE'LL PROBABLY HAVE.
CLOSE TO THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
IN COMPETITIVE GRANTS THAT'S UP
FOR GRABS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THAT INCLUDES
SEVENTEEN BILLION FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR WE DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GONNA DO
SO I'M NOT GOING TO. LAY DOWN ON
YOU BUT SIX POINT SEVEN BILLION
ISN'T WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY ON PILOT
PROGRAMS FOR WATER STORES. DATA
SHARING LEAD SAFE DRINKING WATER
SEWAGE OVERFLOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY IS FIVE
POINT FIVE BILLION THAT
INCLUDES. THREE POINT FIVE FOR
FLOOD MITIGATION ASSISTANCE SO
CAN YOU GIVE THIS SUBCOMMITTEE.
SOME FLAVOR OF WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT WITH ALL THE-
INTERAGENCY DISCUSSIONS THAT YOU
HAVE ON SORT OF ON THE NATURAL
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO GET WHY DO
THE BUDGET. REQUEST YOU MAKE NOW
ARE A- BEAUTIFUL PAIRING WHAT
WHAT WE THINK WE'RE GOING TO BE
COMPETITIVE WITH ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND WHY YOU KNOW. AND
WHY YOU'RE ASKING I JUST WE JUST
HAD. THE PROPER CONSERVATION
THEY HAD TWO. MILLION DOLLARS AT
SORT OF A BLOCK GRANT TO GIFTS
OF SOME FLEXIBILITY SO THEY CAN
THEY CAN MOVE MONEY AROUND AT
THESE THAT THAT WERE
APPROPRIATE. ADD THAT TO JUST
YOUR REGULAR. REQUIRE IN. ARE
RELEASE. IF YOU MAY. WE'LL DO
THANK YOU CHAIR I CAN MORNING
SURE NUMBERS- BRYAN FULLER
DEPARTMENT FINANCE- I WILL KIND
OF GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
CONTEXTUALIZING THIS YEAR'S
PACKAGE WITH THEM THE MORE
RECENT ESTIMATES THAT YOU
ALLUDED TO CHAIR AND I'LL TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE ON ON KIND OF
SOME OF THE OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS AS IT RELATES TO SOME
OF THE POTENTIAL FEDERAL
INVESTMENTS M. BUT FIRST JUST A
COUPLE OF QUICK AT ADDITIONAL
POINTS TO HIGHLIGHT REGARDING
THIS YEAR'S DROUGHT RESILIENCE
IN RESPONSE PACKAGE WE REALLY
ONE UNDERSCORE THESE INVESTMENTS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF LAST YEAR'S HISTORIC.
WATER RESILIENCE IN DROUGHT
PACKAGE WHICH DID PROVIDE FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS TO SUPPORT OF THE
MEDIA DROUGHT RESPONSE AND LONG
TERM WATER RESILIENCE MEASURES
PACKAGE TAKES A MORE APPROACH
PROVIDING A MIX OF INVESTMENTS
THAT CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNMENT COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH THAT IS REQUIRED. TO
ACHIEVE AND SUSTAIN WATER
RESULTS. AS TECH PROGRAM
MENTIONED THE TOP.
ADMINISTRATION CAN TO ALLOW.
THESE PROPOSED INVEST WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S WATER RESILIENCE
PORTFOLIO INCLUDING PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR WATER CONSERVATION
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT. AND MULTI BENEFIT
LETTER PURPOSING AMONG OTHER
PROPOSED THE BEST. INVESTMENTS
WILL BOLSTER THE STATE'S DROUGHT
RESILIENCE IN BOTH THE SHORT AND
LONG TERM AND WHEN TAKEN
TOGETHER PROVIDE THE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH NECESSARY
TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S WATER MANAGEMENT MEETS.
UP FROM MY COLLEAGUES AFTER A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION
REGARDING. THAT THE FEDERAL
FUNDING THANK YOU. YES GOOD
MORNING CARE MEMBERS OR DRIVE
OVER THE PART OF FINANCE- IN
TERMS OF THE FEDERAL FUNDING-
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
MONITORING THERE IS. SOME
FUNDING THAT WE ALREADY KNOW FOR
SURE IF THEN I GOT THE
CALIFORNIA I THOUGHT AS A COUPLE
HUNDRED. STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD- THERE'S CLOSE TO
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS THAT WE'RE
ANTICIPATING OVER FIVE YEARS OR
THANK YOU WATER AND WASTEWATER
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO WE KNOW
FROM FROM THE WATER BOARD
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FALLING
BEHIND THAT. AND I RESET- AND
I'LL- BET ON THE OVERALL-
DRINKING WATER- INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OPERATIONAL NEED THAT. THE
THAT THEY NEED ARE ARE GREAT AND
SO EVEN WITH THE ADDITIONAL YOU
KNOW ALMOST FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
THAT. IS GOING TO COME FROM
PROGRAM RAN OVER NEXT. FIVE
YEARS WHICH IS IN ADDITION TO
THE ONE POINT THREE THAT AT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED FROM THE
GENERAL FUND LAST YEAR- WE KNOW
WE KNOW THERE'S STILL GOING TO
BE. A PROPERTY AS THOUGH. THAT
THE STATE BUDGET YOU KNOW WILL
BE AUGMENTED BY THAT FEDERAL
FUNDING. NOW THERE'S A LOT OF-
OTHER POP THE FUNDING THAT. ARE
STILL A LITTLE BETTER KNOWN-
WHERE THEY'RE STILL DISHING THE
GUY WAS. GOING TO BE COMING OUT
FROM THE GET FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THEY'RE STILL UNDER G. AS
YOU. ARE HOW MUCH WE'RE GOING TO
GET. THE BUDGET DOES PROPOSE THE
CONTROL. AND THAT THANKS EIGHT
POINT SEVEN. THAT WE'RE- BROKE
BEING- YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORITY THAT THE EXTENT THERE
IS- KIND OF AND I KNOW. THAT
THEY- SPEAK MATCHING. FOR SOME
OF THESE. GRANTS THAT HEN WE
NEED APPLY. THAT DOES PROVIDE B.
ADMINISTRATION I'M ADDITIONAL
ELECTRIC. TO BE ABLE THAT- YOUR
USE GENERAL ONE IN THERE ARE
OTHER FUNDING FOR THE VEIL. TO
BE ABLE. TO LEVERAGE THOSE
COMPUTER. AFTERWARD WE'RE GONNA
BE. DILIGENTLY THE DEPARTMENT
LIVING INSPIRATION. TO MATCH
YOUR REQUIREMENTS SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE MONITORING
BUT WE'RE ALREADY PROPOSING. YOU
KNOW WITHIN THAT CONTROL
SECTION- RIGHT NOW DOING THIS IS
GONNA BE JUST BEING A WATER BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER. ACROSS
THE KIND OF BIG BUDGET BACK.
POTENTIALLY GET COMPLIMENTED-
WITH FEDERAL FUNDING- WERE YOU
KNOW THE- MORE- GONNA CONTINUE
OUR INVEST. AND THEN I. OF
THERE'S A- AND I COME FROM THE
GOVERNOR A GOVERNMENT. WILL
DEFINITELY LOOK TO APPLY. AND
HAVE THAT LIKE THE- BUILT INTO
THE- PROVIDE MATCH. I'M SURE MY
CALL WILL HAVE SOME ON THAT OR
LET'S A LET'S GO TO THE- MISS.
TAYLOR OTHER THAN FLAG- BRING
THAT WE HAVE. AND THAT AND TROUT
- WHICH TAKE ON THE GOVERNOR'S.
AUGMENTATION ON THE DROUGHT
PACKAGE IN ADDITION TO LAST
YEAR'S MONEY AND THE EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION THAT'S
APPROPRIATE- THIS YEAR FROM LAST
YEAR'S ACTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR RACHEL EHLERS FROM LA-
NICE TO SEE YOU ALL- YEAH WE
THINK IT IS HELPFUL TO THINK
AOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PACKAGE AND KIND OF TWO.
CATEGORIES ONE IS THE IMMEDIATE
DROUGHT RESPONSE TO RESPOND TO
AN IMMEDIATE PRESSING CONCERNS
AND THEN THOSE PROPOSALS THAT
ARE MORE FOCUSED ON LONGER TERM
KIND OF RESILIENCE FOR FUTURE
DROUGHTS SO IN THAT FIRST
CATEGORY IT'S REALLY TOO EARLY
TO TELL EVEN JUST A MONTH AGO
WHEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS
RELEASED. THINGS SEEMED A LOT
BETTER THAN THEY SEEM TODAY- SO
YOU KNOW WE'LL KNOW MORE ABOUT
AS THE NEXT FEW MONTHS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN EVERYTHING USUALLY
FALLS SO BY THE MAY REVISION I
THINK. I WILL HAVE A BETTER
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW MUCH OF THAT
MEDIA AT WHETHER IT'S THE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
CONTINGENCY FIND OR THAT KIND OF
ROUGHLY SIXTY FIVE MILLION THAT
WE WOULD CONSIDER MORE
IMMEDIATE. DROUGHT RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES IN THIS PACKAGE SO-
WE RECOMMEND KIND OF WAITING AND
SEEING ON ON THAT MANY BUT BEING
PREPARED THAT WE MAY NEED TO
HAVE. ATTENTION LEE SOME OF THAT
MONEY POTENTIALLY MORE THAN THAT
MANY- DEPENDING ON HOW THE
HYDROLOGY DEVELOPS IN THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS AND MONTHS. IN TERMS
OF THE LONGER TERM RESILIENCE
THAT IS WHAT WE WOULD CONSIDER
THE BULK OF THIS PACKAGE TO BE
NOT FOCUSED ON IMMEDIATE.
RESPONSE BUT REALLY RESILIENCE
ON THE LONGER TERM BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S A BAD THING
THAT CERTAINLY HAS MERIT AND AS
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED BY YOUR
SPEAKERS ALREADY THE BEST TIME
TO PREPARE FOR DROUGHT IS BEFORE
THE DAY COMES- BECAUSE IT THAT
THIS PROJECTS DO TAKE A LONG
TIME TO QUIT. A SIGN AND I. CAN
YOU CAN TAKE CAN TAKE MONTHS OR
YEARS. SO WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT
IS A VALUE FOR THE STATE HOWEVER
WHEN YOU DID MAKE VERY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN THAT
THROUGH THE TWENTY. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUDGET BOTH IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AS WELL AS. THE AS
YOU MENTIONED MISTER CHAIR THE
EIGHT IN THE MILLION. PRO IN THE
BUDGET BEFORE YOU. FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR SO NOT. IT EVEN IF
DIDN'T AND I ANY OF THE
GOVERNOR'S NEW. THE STATE STILL
BE ROOM SO. PROGRESS ON THAT
GOAL. SO I THINK OUR OUR MAIN
MESSAGE HE WAS NOT THAT THIS
ISN'T A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
STATE BUT I THINK YOU CAN
CONSIDER WHETHER THIS IS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR YOUR
GENERAL FUND. THIS YEAR. GIVEN
THOSE THAT EITHER SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS AND ALL THE OTHER
PRIORITIES YOU HAVE IN THE
BUDGET. SO IT IS A HIGH
PRIORITY. AND CERTAINLY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR YOU IS
NOT THE ONLY APPROACH YOU CAN
TAKE- YOU COULD CONSIDER
MODIFICATIONS THAT REALLY
ADDRESSED WENT. WHAT YOU AS A
LEGISLATURE THINK ARE THE
HIGHEST STATE PRIORITIES. SO FOR
EXAMPLE- YOU COULD CONSIDER IT
MORE MANY FOR GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE SINCE THOSE ARE
ACTIVITIES THAT REALLY. SHOW A
LOT OF PROMISE FOR WATER SUPPLY
AS WELL AS OTHER BENEFITS LIKE
FLOOD CONTROL SO. IT'S A PRETTY
WE WOULD WE WOULD CHARACTERIZE
AS A PRETTY MODEST COMPONENT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSAL ONLY
THIRTY MILLION SO YOU COULD
CONSIDER A GREATER INVESTMENT IN
THAT AREA. THERE WASN'T THAT
MUCH MONEY IN THAT KIND OF
CATEGORY FOR. THE RECENT PACKAGE
THAT PASSED. SIMILARLY WE THINK
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER A-
PERHAPS A SMALLER INVESTMENT IN
WATER CONSERVATION ACTIVITIES
COMPARED TO WHAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED. JUSTGIVEN THAT IS
A RELATIVELY SMALL. SHARE OF
WATER USE ACROSS THE STATE BUT
ALSO BECAUSE THE STATE HAS PUT A
BIG. EMPHASIS IN THAT AREA
THROUGH POLICY CHANGES- AND
THROUGH ACTIVITIES DURING THE
LAST DROUGHT WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
PROGRESS IN IN GREATER WATER
EFFICIENCIES IN THAT URBAN
SETTING. SO YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER THAT IS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR YOUR AB
INVESTMENTS THIS YEAR SHOULD YOU
CHOOSE TO MAKE THEM. AN AND AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION'S
LAND RECORD BESTING PROGRAM WE
THINK THAT HAS A LOT OF PROMISE
IT REALLY FOCUSES ON SOME REALLY
IMPORTANT GOALS AS THE DIRECTOR
DISCUSSED. BUT IT IS A BRAND NEW
PROGRAM WHERE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
OUTCOMES YET. WE DON'T REALLY
KNOWHOW THE PROGRAM IS SHAPING
UP WITH THE DEMAND WILL BE YOU
HAVE AND HOW EFFECTIVE IT IS
WHETHER IT NEEDS SOME. KIND OF
RESHAPING AS IT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED. SO YOU KNOW YOU
COULD THINK ABOUT THAT AS A
PILOT EFFORT THIS YEAR AND WAIT
TO BEFORE MAKING FURTHER
INVESTMENTS TO WE GET SOME
OUTCOME DATA. SO THOSE ARE JUST. A FEW EXAMPLES OF WAYS THAT
YOU COULD TWEAK THIS PACKAGE TO
REFLECT PAY OR- AT ANOTHER. WE
WOULD JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE TO
AND- IS. THINKING ABOUT THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT OR
THE GANN LIMIT AS YOU HAVE
DISCUSSED IN FULL COMMITTEE THAT
IS AN IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- SO AS YOU
THINK ABOUT IF YOU WERE GOING
TO. CHANGE WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS THINKING ABOUT THAT
OVERALL CALCULATIONS OF WHICH
ACTIVITIES ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
LIMIT OR NOT SHE TYPICALLY
CAPITAL OUTLAY ACTIVITIES ARE
EXCLUDED SO- THAT. THAT MAY BE
HELPFUL AT FRAMEWORK AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT THIS PACKAGE. AND
THEN THE FINAL POINT I WOULD
MAKE IS ONE THAT YOU MISTER
CHAIR HAVE ALREADY RAISED AS
HAVE SEVERAL THE SPEAKERS WHICH
IS GREAT WHICH IS OVERSIGHT.
THIS IS A LOT OF MANY AND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND STATE
INVESTED IN WATER RESILIENCE.
AND TYPICALLY THOSE INVESTMENTS
HAVE BEEN THROUGH BONDS. AND
TYPICALLY WITH BOND LANGUAGE
THERE'S A LOT OF OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY KIND OF BUILT IN
AND REPORTING LANGUAGE AND IN
EVEN ON NOT ONLY ON WHAT
PROJECTS ARE FUNDED BUT- ALSO ON
OUTCOMES HOW DOLLARS ARE FLOWING
OUT THE DOOR. THAT ISN'T
AUTOMATICALLY BUILT IN WITH THIS
PACKAGE THAT YOU ARE APPROVED IN
THE IN THE MOST RECENT BUDGET.
WHAT'S GREAT IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING THAT ON
ALREADY TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION- WHERE WE'VE GOT A
REALLY GREAT START BUT WE WOULD
JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
REQUESTING THAT INFORMATION.
MONITORING THAT INFORMATION NOT
JUST BECAUSE IT'S GOOD
GOVERNMENT AND OVERSIGHT OVER
PUBLIC DOLLARS BUT ALSO BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
INFORMATION TO HELP. GUIDE YOUR
FUTURE DECISIONS AND THINKING
ABOUT WHICH PROGRAMS ARE
OVERSUBSCRIBED WHICH PROGRAMS
MIGHT HAVE TROUBLE GETTING MONEY
OUT THE DOOR- WHERE THERE MIGHT
BE BARRIERS OR OBSTACLES THAT
NEED. INTERVENTION FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WHERE WE'RE SEEING
GREAT SUCCESSES WHERE WE MIGHT
NEED TO TWEAK THINGS TO SEE MORE
SUCCESS SO REALLY ENCOURAGED
THAT CONTINUED OVERSIGHT OVER
THESE DOLLARS. I'M NOT ONLY IN
THE COMING MONTHS TO INFORM THIS
BUDGET BUT IN THE COMING YEARS
TO INFORM. YOUR FUTURE
INVESTMENTS. AND HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE DISCUSSION
ENHANCING QUESTIONS. I THINK
WE'LL TAKE A- YOUR. PURPOSING
GRANT I DO I DID HEAR DIRECTOR
SAY THAT THERE. JUST GETTING THE
NOTICE OUT TO THE NOW AND THINK
THAT THEY'LL THE MILLION THAT WE
APPROPRIATE WILL OVER SUPER WHEN
LOOK AT THE MAY REVISE WILL HAVE
MORE UP TO DATE NUMBERS I ASSUME
THAT THAT'S HAPPENING IN EVERY
DEPARTMENT AND EVERY AGENCY
WHERE THEY'LL THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
SAY LOOK THIS THING WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED AND EVEN THE
FORTY MILLION WON'T BE ABLE TO
DO THAT SO WE'LL KEEP THAT ON
THE BURNERS AND THE CONSERVE.
OKAY SO YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT
MAYBE IT'S YEAR YEAR OBSERVATION
ARE STAFF REPORT ON PAGE FIFTY
EIGHT STARTS DISCUSSION ABOUT
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN AN EIGHT OF
14% DROP- ED IN. I MINUTES ARRAY
. HI IN THE LAST. FIVE YEARS OR
TEN TEN YEARS SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR WE SAW AN ADDITIONAL
34% DROP THE DROPS IT WOULD SEEM
SAID. AT IT THE WORK IS BEING
DONE AND ONLY. 20% OF THE BUDGET
ON CONSERVATION IS FOR
AGRICULTURE AND WE HEARD
SECRETARY ROSS TALK ABOUT. HOW
MANY ACRES ARE BEING YOU KNOW.
FILE EACH YEAR AND THAT MONEY DO
THE- WATER CONSERVE EFFORTS TO
INCREASE AND THE CROP. HE ALSO
30% OF WAS THE NUMBER THAT PUT
OUT SO MY- IS TO SHOULD WE BE
TRANSFERRING OR SHOULD WE
CONSIDER. PUTTING MORE MONEY
INTO THE AGRICULTURE OR SHOULD
WE JUST. ARE ON CONSERVATION OR
SHOULD WE BE LOOKING AT OTHER.
OTHER THAN CONSERVATION OTHER
RANDOM MORE MONEY AND SIGMAR
MORE MONEY AND AT THE A
DIFFERENT PROGRAM IS IT IS IT.
DISCUSS ADVERSE IS RESIDENTIAL
OR THE OR THE BALANCE MAYBE IT
SHOULD BE EIGHTY TWENTY THE
OTHER WAY I I'M- INTERESTED IN
YOUR THOUGHTS. YEAH I THINK I AM
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU NOT TO
VIEW. KIND OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWO HUNDRED MILLION ON
WATER CONSERVATION AS MEANING
THAT MEANS YOU NEED TO SPEND TWO
HUNDRED MILLION ON WATER
CONSERVATION AND DECIDE HOW MUCH
IS ACT VERSUS- AND I THINK. YOU
YOU HAVE OPTIONS TO DECIDE WHAT
ARE YOUR HIGHEST PRIORITIES AND
SOME OF THOSE MIGHT BE ON DEMAND
MANAGEMENT WHICH IS- WHAT KIND
OF WATER CONSERVATION IS
LOWERING DEMAND- AS SECRETARY
ROSS MENTIONED THERE IS ALSO
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
THAT WAS PART OF THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION FOR
THE AG SWEEP PROGRAM SO IT'S NOT
JUST THAT THIS IS THE ONLY
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR THAT- BUT
BUT YOU COULD ALSO THINK ABOUT
WATER SUPPLY. WHICH AGAIN RIGHT
AROUND WATER RECHARGE IS ONE OF
THE ACTIVITIES- AS WELL AS AS
OTHER WATER SUPPLY ACTIVITIES-
LIKE LIKE WATER RECYCLING FOR
EXAMPLE- SO REALLY IN GETTING TO
A MORE SUSTAINABLE WATER.
APPROACH STATEWIDE THEIR WATER
DEMAND MANAGEMENT AND
CONSERVATION IS ONE CATEGORY BUT
THERE ARE THERE ARE OTHER
ACTIVITIES SO I THINK WE WOULD
CONSIDER UNITS AT BREAK A
MANDATE YOU DON'T CONSIDER WATER
CONSERVATION KIND OF IN A VACUUM
BUT BUT THINK ABOUT YOUR LARGER
SUITE OF OPTIONS. OKAY OF THE
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S ADDITIONALITY THAT WE
HAVE WE THERE'S A CHUNK OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THAT WERE CUT IT
SEE WHAT HAPPENS THIS SPRING HOW
MUCH RAIN WE HAVE. AND HOLD THE
FACT- I'D LIKE FOR YOU TO COME.
ON THE TIDAL WAVE OF FEDERAL
MONEY THAT'S COMING WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S THREE POINT EIGHT THAT'S
GUARANTEED THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET. AND HOW WE COULD. USE THE
CURRENT BUDGET REQUESTS. WITH
THE ANTICIPATION OF WHERE THE
MONEY'S GOING TO GO. BUT AS OUR
ALLUDED TO. SIX POINT SEVEN
BILLION OUT OF EPA FIVE POINT
FIVE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY FEMALE THREE
POINT FIVE THAT IS FLOOD COULD.
FLOOD ASSISTANCE AND IN THE
APARTMENT INTERIOR WHATEVER
THEY'RE GOING TO DO WITH THEIR
SEVENTEEN BILLION SO. IS IT. ONE
DOES THAT THE PACKAGE ROOM AND
GET WE WERE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE AYE AYE J. A. BUT SHOULD WE
BE THINKING OF READ RATHER THAN
HOLDING BACK MONEY- ADJUSTING
THE APPROPRIATIONS WITH SOME OF
THE MONEY IS LIKE A BLOCK GRANT
SO THAT THE AGENCIES OR THE
DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY
TO USE THE MONEY TO GO SEEK SOME
MORE FEDERAL MONEY VERSUS SPEND
THAT ON THE PURPOSES THAT HAVE
BEEN OUTLINED IN THE AGREEMENT
LAST YEAR IS IT IS IT WAS A LOT
OF THIS IS GOING QUICK AND WE
DON'T WANT TO HAVE I DON'T WANT
TO HAVE A SPECIAL. SESSION OR
SPECIAL HEARING AND IN JULY SO I
CAN THE SECOND CHANGE
APPROPRIATIONS SO THEY CAN DO
THIS INSTEAD OF THAT BUT YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW WHERE I'M GOING%
WITH THIS IS THAT IS THAT
THERE'S SO MUCH THAT'S ON THE
TABLE THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU
KNOW BUILDING RESILIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE THE BRICK PROGRAM
WITH THAT ALL MY SECURITY TO
BILLION DOLLARS AND AN OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE HE WE GOT THIS THING
ABOUT BUILDING RESILIENCY WE
THINK WE HAVE WE MEET HERE WE
CAN APPLY FOR THIS BUT WE DON'T
REALLY HAVE THE AUTHORITY BY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD YOU COMMENT
ON. THAT YEAH I THINK IT'S A
FAIR. POINT THE TIMING IS
DIFFICULT BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
THAT MUCH YET ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS ON THE FEDERAL-
PACKAGES IN ALLOCATIONS. NOR HOW
MUCH WILL FLOW THROUGH KIND OF
OUR STATE AGENCIES VERSUS LOCAL
AGENCIES JUST APPLYING DIRECTLY
SOME OF THOSE- GRANTS ARE ARE
STRUCTURED THAT WAY. SO I THINK
AT SOME OF THE- CONSIDERATIONS
TO THINK ABOUT ARE WHAT WILL THE
STATE MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
SPEED. EVEN ON THAT THREE POINT
EIGHT BILLION THAT WE KNOW THE
WATER BOARD WILL GET FOR CLEAN
DRINKING WATER. AND WASTEWATER
THERE WILL BE STATE SOME STATE
MATCHING REQUIREMENTS THERE SO
THINKING ABOUT- AS YOU MENTIONED
MISTER CHAIR WHAT FUNDING DO WE
NEED TO MAKE AVAILABLE TO BE
ABLE TO. TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL
OF THAT FEDERAL MONEY- AND ALSO
AVOIDING DUPLICATION AND
THINKING ABOUT IT WAREFARE
FORGETTING FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
SOME PURPOSES MAYBE THAT MEANS
THAT WE CAN REPURPOSE OUR STATE
DOLLARS FOR OTHER PRIORITIES
THAT DON'T HAVE IT- I DO THINK
IT'S A LITTLE IT'S A LITTLE
PREMATURE BUT WE- AS YOU SAID
DON'T WANT TO GET STUCK IN
SEPTEMBER OCTOBER WHERE. THE
LEGISLATURE IS NOT IN SESSION
WE'RE GETTING FUNDING WE'RE
GETTING SECTION LETTERS THROUGH
THE JAIL B. C. AND WE'RE NOT
PREPARED SO. I MIGHT SUGGEST
THAT THAT SEEKING AN UPDATE IN A
COUPLE OF MONTHS PERHAPS WHEN
WE'RE STILL IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND IT'S NOT TOO LATE-
BUT WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION THAN WE DO RIGHT
NOW. SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION OF. WHICH MEANS
IT'S A DOUBLE EDGED SWORD WERE.
FOR DOING WHAT. PLAN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY DANCE SOMEWHERE
SENATE SHOW ME THIS WORDS MONEY
THAT WE GIVE YOU THIS MONEY DID
YOU SPEND A DID YOU DO IT YOU DO
IT AND THEN REALIZED. THAT
PERHAPS WHO WOULD KNOW THAT IF
THE MONEY DIDN'T GO OUT THE
DOOR. AND ALL OF A SUDDEN WE SEE
THAT WE'VE GOT GUIDELINES IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR AND IF WE
REPURPOSE. THAT WILL. INCREASE
THE FUNDING IN THE AND THE AREA
- TEMPERS. ALL RIGHT LET'S THE-
MY COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE A- OF- SO
LET'S GO TO. VICE CHAIR DOLLY OF
. THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
- GOOD AFTERNOON. FOR SURE ADDED
I WANT TO JUST GO WITH THE OF
WATER OF. SO ON A COUPLE OF
NUMBER ONE ITEM IS- ILLEGAL
GROWS ELITE WE HAVE EIGHT ABOUT
80% OF THE CANNABIS THAT IS
PRODUCED IN CALIFORNIA'S ON
ILLEGAL GROWS AND I WAS
WONDERING- WHAT WHAT THE PROCESS
IS FOR GETTING WORKING TO GET
TO. RESOURCES OUT ON THE GROUND
ACTUALLY TO CLEAN UP THE SITES
AND TO HELP- THAT ARE
CONTAMINATING OUR FOR OUR
SERVICE WATER IN OUR GROUNDWATER
. EVERYTHING IS. GO AHEAD D. W.
R. OKAY THANK YOU- THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY FOR THE- FOR THE
QUESTION- THAT IS I THINK MORE
APPROPRIATELY DIRECTED AT MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE WATER BOARD
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE YOU ARE ENGAGED IN- YOU
KNOW CANNABIS CULTIVATION.
ILLEGAL CONCERT CULTIVATION AND
IN SOME PLACES AND HOW THEY-
MONITOR WATER USE SO
RESPECTFULLY I WILL- TURN IT
OVER TO CHAIR ASK ABOUT- AND-
DIRECTOR CHUCK BONHAM. JOHN AT
THANK YOU OF I THANK YOU THAT
DIRECTOR NAME. I WE WORK HAND IN
HAND WITH THE LOCALS WHEN IT
COMES TO ENFORCEMENT AROUND THE
SITES- WHAT WE HAVE AT THE WATER
BOARDS ARE A WATER QUALITY
PROGRAM AND I'M FORSMAN ABILITY
THERE UNDER THE CLEAN WATER ACT
THAT. REALLY HELPS WHEN IT COMES
TO THE PROSECUTION OF THE SITES-
INSOFAR AS IT REALLY BLESSING IT
UP TO A FELONY AND I WORK IN
TIGHT COORDINATION THE CFW AS
WELL AND NOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS TIED TO REALLY CONTINUE
TO UNDERSTAND. THE CHALLENGE OF
ILLEGAL GROWS BY ALSO FOCUSING I
KNOW HERE ON ENSURING WE HAVE A
LEGAL MARKET- TO INSTRUCT TO
WHERE- THE INDUSTRY CAN GO WHILE
TIGHTENING DOWN ON WHAT ARE
THESE ILLEGAL GROWS THAT YOUR
POINT TO HAVE WATER QUALITY
IMPACTS AND SO. WE THROUGH OUR
REGIONAL BOARDS HAVE A PROGRAM
THERE AGAIN ND IT'S BEEN VERY
TIGHTLY COORDINATED WITH AND
TAKES THE LEAD FROM LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- ON ON A NUMBER OF-
THE RATES AND BUST AND THEN ALSO
WHEN IT COMES TO. CLEAN UP THERE
AFTER THE SITES- DIRECTOR BOTTOM
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD. ONE THING AND
SYNERGY DOLLY I'D BE GLAD TO.
FIND TIME OFFLINE IF YOUR OFFICE
HAS FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AT OUR
DEPARTMENT PROVIDE THE MAIN.
KIND OF FIELD SUPPORT FOR
INVESTIGATIONS AND EVENTUALLY
PROSECUTIONS. AND WE DO THAT
WORK AT A COUNTY LEVEL WE'RE
CONSTANTLY IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
EACH OF THE COUNTIES SHERIFF'S.
AND WE'RE IN A PLANNING CYCLE
NOW FOR WHAT. COULD BE THE UP
COMING FIELD SEASON. NOW EACH
COUNTY ALL THE OF COURSE. DOES
HANDLE LIKE NOR DOES. WHICH DOES
HANDLE IT LIKE DR. BUT
NONETHELESS US- OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE REALLY DOES
RUN THROUGH OUR COMMITMENT TO
WORK WITH COUNTIES AT THE
SHERIFF'S AND SUPERVISE OR
LEVEL. SO IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UPS WOULD BE
GLAD TO SCHEDULE IT I'M IN THE
OFFICE WELL I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
. AS YOU KNOW. WE IT'S OUT OF
CONTROL AND- IT NEEDS TO BE A
COORDINATED- UNFORTUNATELY
COUNTIES DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO. GO OUT AND DO
ENFORCEMENT I MEAN THEY'RE
THEY'RE DEALING WITH SMASH AND
GRAB CRIME THEY'RE DEALT WITH
ALL KINDS OF THINGS IN TOWN AND
THERE'S REALLY NO COORDINATED
EFFORT I MEAN WE'VE TOURED. ED
MAINLY IN SISKIYOU- AND WE WILL
HAVE I HAVE FARMERS ARE GETTING
HAMMERED FOR WATER QUALITY
ISSUES AS I GOT ILLEGAL GROWS
UPSTREAM THAT AND NOBODY'S DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT THEIR DUMPING.
HUMAN WASTE ON THE GROUND. AND
IN CHEMICALS AND YOU NAME IT I
MEAN YOU CAN GOOGLE EARTH
SISKIYOU COUNTY AND YOU CAN SEE
THE DEVASTATION THAT'S HAPPENING
SO THERE NEED TO BE. SOMEWHERE
IN THIS BUDGET PROCESS AND READY
TO BE FOR ME IT'S MORE ABOUT.
LIKE THERE HAS TO BE A PLAN WITH
THE AG'S OFFICE HAS TO BE A PLAN
WITH. WITH THE BE A FISHING
GAME. AND THAT'S THE PLAN OF THE
WATER BOARD THERE'S TODAY IT IS
HARD TO BEAT. ALL PEOPLE
TOGETHER ALL. ON BOARD BECAUSE-
IF YOU THREE IF YOU TURN ON THE
LOCAL COUNTY THERE THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO GET
IT DONE. AND SENATOR LET ME
CORRECT THE MISSTATEMENT PERHAPS
I DON'T ARGUE OR BELIEVE WE
THROW IT ON TO THE LOCAL
COUNTIES WE'RE DELIVERING A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF STATE.
INVESTMENT IN THE SPACE OF A
PARTNERSHIP LEVEL WHAT I MEANT
TO SAY IS. IN ORDER TO DETERMINE
WHERE TO PURSUE THESE ACTIONS IN
A COUNTY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ENGAGING THE COUNTY SO
THEY CAN ADVISE AS WELL. I THINK
IF YOU'RE WILLING IT WOULD BE
USEFUL FOR THOSE OF US IN THIS
SPACE TO COME AND GIVE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
A CONCERTED COMPREHENSIVE WAY
ACROSS ALL STATE GOVERNMENT.
SHOULD WELL I WOULD I WOULD
WELCOME THAT I'VE BEEN OUT ON
THE GROUND WE'VE ASKED. THEM
YOUR OFFICE TO COME WITH US AND-
WE HAVEN'T GOT PEOPLE OUT THERE
WE GOT HELICOPTERS FROM THE
NATIONAL GUARD AND WE FLEW UP
THERE AND- WE LOOKED AT WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND- I MEAN IF THE
PUBLIC REALLY KNEW WHAT WAS
GOING ON AND THEM BUT FOR ME
IT'S JUST. IT'S JUST. IS NOT
RIGHT THAT WE HAMMER THE GUY
THAT'S TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING
ON THE- GROUND. THE FARMER GETS
PENALIZED FOR EVERYTHING IF HE-
IF HE- ÁP DOES IT TAKE FOR A
COHO FRY. HE'S HE'S GONNA PAY OR
HE'S GONNA GET REGULATED BUT
RIGHT UPSTREAM. WE HAVE JUST
ILLEGAL GROWS AND ALL KINDS OF
STUFF DUMPING AND WE DON'T IT'S
THIS. IS ALL RIGHT. AND IT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED. AND I'LL- I
WANT TO BE THE TABLE I'M ALWAYS
AT THE TABLE. BUT I CAN TELL YOU
THAN LESS WE HAVE A COORDINATED.
EFFORT THAT DOES NOT RELY ON THE
COUNTY ALONE. WE NEED WE NEED
HELP FROM THE AG'S OFFICE WE
NEED HELP WE NEED THE RESOURCES
TO GO IN AND CLEAN THESE UP AND
THEN WE NEED. IT OR WHATEVER GET
YOU WORK ON THE LEGAL SIDE OF
MARIJUANA ALL DAY. BUT IF 80% OF
THE ILLEGAL GROWS THEY'RE NOT
DOING IT AND IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT
SO I JUST WANT TO GO ON RECORD.
THAT ONCE AGAIN. IT'S ANOTHER
YEAR INTO THE PROCESS. AND WE
NEED TO TACKLE THIS PROBLEM IS
IT'S- THROUGHOUT THE WATERSHEDS
OF CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE'S
FEDERAL LAND. AND THERE'S- AND
THERE'S PRIVATE LANDS AS WELL
BUT IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED SO
I JUST WANNA GO ON RECORD. AND
I'M AVAILABLE TO GO LOOK AT IT
AND- AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
GET THE AG'S OFFICE AND SOME.
SOME TEETH IN OUR LAWS. TO STOP
THIS. THANK YOU FOR THAT THAT
SECOND QUESTION I HAD WAS ON
WATER AGAIN. WE L. LAST YEAR. WE
SO THE KALENJIN PROGRAM IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE SHUT DOWN
THESE WELLS. LAST YEAR I ASKED
ABOUT BECAUSE WE'RE ONE WHICH WE
DON'T HAVE CONTAMINATED
GROUNDWATER. SO WHO WOULD
THERE'S FIFTY POSITIONS.
ALLOCATED IN THAT CAL JIM
PROGRAM AND LET AND OTHERS FIFTY
VACANCIES AND THERE'S A THEY'RE
ASKING FOR TEN MORE. POSITIONS
AND SO. LAST YEAR I ASKED
BROUGHT UP THE SAME ISSUE WHY
DIVERSE TO ONLY TWO HIRES THE
YEAR BEFORE. SO WE HAVE FIFTY
VACANCIES AND REST FOR TEN MORE
POSITIONS WHAT IS THE PROBLEM IN
GETTING. THE ABILITY FOR
SOMEBODY TO GET HIRED NOW THIS
IS ON THE SECOND THIS IS A
SECOND YEAR I'VE ASKED THIS
QUESTION. AND WE'RE ADDING MORE
POSITIONS BUT WE'RE NOT GETTING
PEOPLE. TO THE JOBS NOT GETTING
DONE VICTOR CROWFOOT. THANKS SO
MUCH SENATOR I'M I'M MAY OUT.
OUT WITH THE VEHICLE ON JUNE MY
COLLEAGUE DAVID SHE MADE IN A
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
METHODS ESPECIALLY THE MOTHER
DEPARTMENT OVER CAL JOHN.
BERNARD ALI I NEEDED BUT I NEED
YOU. AND THE ACTUAL CURRENT THE
NUMBERS IN FRONT OF ME TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER MOST ACCURATELY I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS.
IN REDUCING THE BACON. I LEVEL
CAL. WE HEARD YOUR FEEDBACK AND
THE FEEDBACK OF OTHERS LAST YEAR
AROUND. WORKING TO REDUCE THOSE
DAY CARE PROJECTOR. FOR OUR OR
JUST OF. TO OPT. DIRECT SHE MADE
HIM I ALSO YOU- TO YOU AN ANSWER
OFFLINE- BASED ON THE MOST
RECENT DAY THAT I CAN- I CAN ACT
UP. THE PUSH IT OUT OF SIGHT- SO
OUR VACANCY RATE IN CAL J. HAS
THAT DECLINED WERE OUT OF 8%
THIS POINT IN TIME LAST YEAR AND
WE'RE DOWN TO ABOUT THIRTEEN
PERCENT- YOU KNOW THAT THE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE FACING IS- WE
HAVE A LOT OF POSITIONS TO FILL
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BUT WHAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
ALSO. IS MOVING PEOPLE UP WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATION ITSELF TO FILL
OPEN POSITIONS AND THEN ALSO AT
THE SAME TIME WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE SEEN WHICH I THINK IS
HAPPENING ACROSS THE STATE AS- A
LOT OF RETIREMENTS AND SO WE ARE
WE'RE HIRING SEVENTY EIGHT
PEOPLE A MONTH TO FILL
POSITIONS- BUT WE'RE HAVING THAT
SAMENUMBER IF NOT MORE. RETIRE
OUT OF UPSTATE SERVICE ND SO- I
YOU KNOW SUFFICE IT TO SAY THAT
WE ARE WE ARE ACTUALLY SEEING A
DECLINE IN OUR VACANCY RATE- BUT
YOU KNOW WILL ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT THERE STILL WORK TO DO TO
FILL POSITIONS. RECALLING THANK
YOU FOR THAT I JUST WANT NOW
HAVE A- ALMOST ALL ALL THE
SPEAKERS TALKED ABOUT. IN WHERE
WE ARE CLIMATE. AND SO. I DON'T
THIS IS A GENERAL. QUESTION SO
WE HAVE WE'VE HAD IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THE END
OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. AND
THE START OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WAS THE WETTEST YEAR ON
RECORD IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE CAME
OUT OF A DROUGHT IN TWO THOUSAND
FROM TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE PASSED
PROP ONE. IN THAT TIME SO WE
COULD DO. THAT WATER CAR OUR
WATER STORAGE AND SOME WATER
CONSERVATION. TO THE VOTERS HAVE
BEEN ON BOARD FOR YEARS SINCE I
THINK SINCE LIKE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WE'VE PASSED LIKE TWENTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN BONDS
TO DO WATER CONSERVATION AND
WATER. MANAGEMENT BUT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE BOOM AND BUST
OF THE CLIMATE. AND WE'RE SEEING
THIS YEAR WE HAD WILL WHAT. FALL
DENSE DRY RIGHT NOW SO WHAT IS
THE LONG TERM PLAN IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE BOOM AND BUST
WE'RE GONNA FOR THE WETTEST YEAR
ON RECORD IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WILL DROP BEFORE THAT
WERE IN DROUGHT NOW. WHAT IS IT
WHAT IS THE PUBLIC. WHAT WHAT DO
YOU WHAT DO WE EXPECT FOR THE
PUBLIC WE NEED TO HAVE WATER
RELIABILITY I HEARD THAT LIKE
IT'S THROUGH THE THEME OF THIS
BUT HAVE WATER RELIABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO RECHARGE GROUNDWATER.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE WATER. SO WHY
DON'T WE TAKE SOME OF THIS MONEY
IN THIS BUDGET AND BUILD. BIKE
SITES RESERVOIR. T. ROWE THE
GENERAL FUND. BUT A COUPLE
BILLION DOLLARS A BILL SUCH AS
MORE WHICH IS OFF. STREAM
STORAGE PROJECT WHICH HELPS THE
DELTA WHICH HELPS. IT INCREASES
WATER. AND WE HAVE NOT BUILT ANY
WATER STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA
SINCE PAT BROWN WAS. OUR
GOVERNOR. AND WE'VE ADDED TWENTY
MILLION PEOPLE WE CANNOT JUST
CONTINUE TO CONSERVE OUR PAY
COMMUNITIES TO OUR PAY FARMERS
TO LEAVE THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE BEST
WITH FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THIS
IS RE PURPOSING LAND IT'S
BASICALLY. GIVEN THAT MONEY SO
THEY CAN GO TO SOME OTHER STATE
WINNERS WATER SOME OF THE
COUNTRY AND THAT LAND ON THE
ISLAND WE WILL PUMP WATER ON. SO
WHAT IS THE OVERALL PLAN IF
WE'RE GONNA HAVE BOOM AND BUST
HOW DO WE SUSTAIN OVER THE BOOM
AND BUST. THROUGH CLIMATE CHANGE
AND ACTUALLY PROVIDE A WATER
THAT IS RELIABLE AND GOOD FOR
THE FISH FOR THE PEOPLE FOR
AGRICULTURE FOR ALL THOSE THINGS
WHAT IS THE LONG TERM PLAN
INSTEAD OF JUST THROWING MONEY
AT IT AND NOT ACTUALLY
INCREASING THE WATER YOU'LL-
ANYBODY WANNA JUMP IN. YEAH SURE
IN ORDER. OBVIOUS ARE A BIG. BUT
I'LL I'LL TAKE A CRACK AT LEAST
THIRTY EXPLAIN. YOU KNOW FIVE
WHICH I BELIEVE IS OUR VIEW.
BRING IT OUT. THERE IS CLEAR. A
NUMBER. OF ACTUALLY WE NEED TO
TAKE YOUR- RECHARGE BAKUL- IN
THESE WAY YEAR. WE KNOW WE-
AMPLE. STORAGE UNDER. IT NEEDS
MORE. AND WE NEED DO A BETTER
JOB. CAPTURING THE RAIN DOES. IN
THOSE YEARS THANK ATWATER UNDER. I THINK THERE PROGRESS BEING
MADE. BUT STREAMLINE THE AVAIL
TO DO THAT IN TWO THROUGH. THE
PROCESS SO THAT IT AND OR OTHER
FOLKS WATER RIGHT BUT SOMEBODY
WANTS TO DO THAT THAT'S WHY
IMPORTANCE FORWARD SHE- AFTER
THOSE WHAT THE EXAM WHEN WATER
UNDERGROUND. NUMBER TWO AND WE
NEED TO FILL UP LIKE TO OF JUST
AND A GOOD. IS TO CREATE MORE
FOR. IN A ROW. REPORTER FOR
RATHER MORE. ARE UPDATING THE
ARMY CORPS WHAT HERTZBERG IN
MANY CASES ARE- OVER FIFTY OLD.
HELLO FOR MORE BLACK USED TO BE
IN. THAT WE ARE BILL. I IN WAY
THAT BOTH PROTECT OUR THE PUBLIC
FROM BLOOD BUT- PROVIDE. OUR
WATER SO. WE'VE SEEN THAT- MORE
I YOU KNOW WE WAY AND WILL DO
FIX THAT PAPER LIKE FOR A BILL
AND- YOU COLOR ARE. YOU A
CURRENT AREA IS THIS QUESTION OF
A GROUND STORAGE AFTER RIGHT
PROP WINDING COULD OVER TWO
BILLION TO. OR UNDER AND SURFACE
. DOT BAD BOND MEASURE THAT
ULTIMATELY PER A LET HAD. QUITE
A LOT OF REQUIRE FOR THE PROJECT
. AND THE COMMISSION UNDER AGE
IS SPOKE ON OUR BUT GOING THOUGH
REQUIRE. TO ENABLE THAT STATE
INVESTMENT IN THOSE. WHICH ALSO
PUT YOUR COURSE YOU TYPE RATHER
MORE. THAT WE RACKED THE BAN
ALONG TIME IN COMING IN TERMS
GETTING A PROP ONE DOLLARS- YOU
KNOW TO WITH ALL THIS. OF THE
PROPER BOND IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
BUT MORE FOCUSED ON AND WE CAN
TO MAKE. ON THAT I'LL BE THAT
YEAH BANTERED OUT OF. YOU KNOW
ALL YOUR QUESTION BUT I WOULD
WANTED TO GET YOU A BUNCH INTO
SOME OF OUR. BUT I PERSONALLY
THAT AND I. THE YOU KNOW HERE
TEN YEARS TO DOING. BEEN WELL I
WAS TALK ABOUT FIVE THE YOU KNOW
THE BIG WITH THE BIG RESERVOIR
WE HAVE ACTUALLY BY THIS WE IS
THAT WHICH IS THE ONE THE WE
BURN ALMOST A MILLION A AND ONE
FOR. IN MY DISTRICT WHICH IS THE
WATERSHED OF FEATHER RIVER WHAT
IS GONNA TAKE SIXTY YEARS TO
RECOUP AND WE AND WE- SAW WHAT
THE I'M A CO WITH THIS. I KNOW
IS AN EASY. WE WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
FACED WITH SOME REALLY CRAZY
THINGS BUT ACCOUNTABILITY IS
WHAT I HEARD FROM ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS. WE HAVE TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE WE HAVE TO ACTUALLY
DELIVER SOMETHING. FOR THE
AMOUNT OF THE BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS HAVE BEEN
DUMPED IN THE CALIFORNIA SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE THERE'S BEEN NO
SHORTAGE OF MONEY. THERE'S MORE
MONEY IN THIS LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THAN THERE'S EVER BEEN
IN THE HISTORY OF THE STATE. WE
GOT MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE'RE TACK OVER
TAXING PEOPLE MORE MONEY HERE
THAN THERE'S EVER BEEN. BUT WHAT
ARE WE GETTING FOR I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE PUBLIC IS
ASKING WE IF. IF WE DON'T DO A
BETTER JOB OF LIKE MANAGING
GETTING THE MONEY TO THE GROUND.
I MEAN. MY WHOLE CAREER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF BEING ELECTED I'VE
BEEN LOOKING FOR MONEY TO FIX A
PROBLEM AND WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF
MONEY. AND WE CAN'T SEEM TO GET
THE MONEY TO THE GROUND AND
ACTUALLY ACCOUNTABLE AND HAVE IT
AND HAVE IT. PROCESSED IN A WAY
WHERE WE ACTUALLY GET SOMETHING
DONE AND SO I JUST WANT TO
THAT'S MY FRUSTRATION WITH.
MARIJUANA IT'S LIKE WE GOT ALL
KINDS OF MONEY. WE GOT TO THE
FARMER BUT WE CAN'T SEEM TO GET
UPSTREAM TO GET WHERE THERE'S A
I BELIEVE A BIGGER PROBLEM SO I.
I'M AT THE TABLE I WANT TO WORK
WITH YOU- I'M SHARE I'M LIVING
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT I'M LIVING
IN MY DISTRICT IT'S 60% OF THE
WATERSHED FOR CALIFORNIA I
REPRESENT. AND IT GRIEVES ME
DEEPLY TO WATCH IT BE DESTROYED.
AND I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER I
WANT TO BE I WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU TO GET IT DONE WE HAVE TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE- THERE'S NO
LACK OF MONEY. IS IT IT'S LACK
OF GETTING STUFF DONE SO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE TODAY
OKAY BEFORE WE GO TO THE NEXT
SENATORS WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO
I'D LIKE TO ESTABLISH IT
OFFICIALLY. MISS ROY COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT
TASKING. HERE ALLEY. REQUIRE
STERN- FORMS A STAB WISH SENATE
MCGUIRE GO HEAD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- IN APPRECIATE
THAT EVERY. AT FROM- EACH OF THE
REPRESENTED OF THE AGING TODAY
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO THROUGH
FOR I'D EXCUSE THREE AT ITEM FOR
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AS WELL AS ITEM
SIXTY. THIRTY IN ITEM FOR- IN
REASON YOU NAY GREATLY. CHAIRMAN
SKIS- BELIEVED TO BE REMOVED
ITEM FOR ACTION. LOOK IN IN I
ALSO WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO. DR BONHAM THIS IS
RELATING TO- ITEM FOR IN THE
DUNGEONS FISHERY. I THINK THAT
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT. HOW
SERGEANTS CRAP FLEET HAS BEEN
STRUCK TO SAY THE LEAST- ENTIRE
SEASONS OF THE DUNGEONS CRAB
FISHERY BEEN CLOSED OR
SIGNIFICANTLY CURTAILED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. IN THE
HARD WORKING WOMEN AND MEN OF
CALIFORNIA'S CRAB FLEET ARE IN
DIRE STRAITS. YET EVERY YEAR FOR
DECADES THE STATE HAS EXPECTED
THAT THE FLEET GO OUT COLLECTED
THE SUPPLIES OF FRESH CRAB THAT
MUST BE TESTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH FOR
DEMO GAS IT IN OTHER HEALTH
RELATED TESTS AS WELL. THE END.
I'M GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO MEET
WITH THE FLEET EVERY QUARTER AS
CHAIR AT FISHERIES AQUACULTURE
COMMITTEE I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
PARTICIPATION OF TERROR BONHAM
IN THOSE COMMITTEES IS WITH
FLEET THE FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
PROCESSORS AND ONE OF THE ITEMS
AND IT'S THE TOP ITEM IN FACT
THAT THE FLEET HAS CONTINUED TO
BRING UP. NUMBER ONE. IS THIS
REALLY IS STRUGGLING THE CRAB
FISHERY IS WHAT HELPS KEEP RURAL
COASTAL COMMUNITY ALIVE AND
THEY'RE EXPECTED ON THEIR OWN
DIME TO GO COLLECT THE CRAB TO
BE ABLE TO GET TESTED THAT'S A
MANDATE BY THE STATE. IN FOR
LESS THAN ONE MILLION DOLLARS WE
COULD COMPENSATE THEM ONE TIME
AS THE FLEET GOES OUT TO BE ABLE
TO GO COLLECTED MANDATED TESTS
IT'S AN UNFUNDED MANDATE SO
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT I'D LIKE TO
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATION ON AND
AGAIN I JUST WANT TAKE A MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO CHAIRED BY
CASKEY- DEPORT TABLING THAT ITEM
FOR TODAY KNOW THAT WE'LL HAVE
THAT COME BACK. AND I CAN NOW
MOVE TO ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. HI IN
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN SPEED. I'D LIKE
TO TALK ABOUT HATCHERIES- THE
CALIFORNIA BERMAN FISH WILDLIFE
IS MADE PROGRESS OVER THE LAST
YEAR I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
FIFTY MILLION- WAS AGREED UPON
LAST YEAR BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR IN
COUNCIL APPOINTMENTS FISH
WILDLIFE AND ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK YOU TO- SECTOR
CROWFOOT FOR HIS FOCUS ON THIS
AS WELL AND THE FIFTY MILLION
PART OF IT WAS TO BE INVESTED IN
OUR STATE TEXTURES TO BECOME- AN
INCREASE CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND
CANDIDLY SAVING. A SPECIES THAT
IS ON THE BRINK OF EXTINCTION
ESPECIALLY IN THE SACRAMENTO AND
THAT'S CALIFORNIA'S SALMON. TO
HISTORIC- IT'S A TO HISTORICALLY
. IN MY PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE-
LIKE EVERYTHING IN LIFE RIGHT
NOW IN THIS TRANSITION PERIOD AS
WE TRANSITION TO A HOTTER DRIER
WORLD. WE MUST MOVE FASTER AND
WE HAVE TO MOVE WITH SPEED TO
ENSURE THE SURVIVAL OF
CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC SALMON
SPECIES. AND AGAIN IT IS
ESPECIALLY ON THE SACRAMENTO WE
ARE ON THE BRINK OF EXTINCTION.
I'D LIKE TO GO TO DIRECTOR
BONHAM ON HATCHERY- FROM THE
HATCHERY PROGRAM. BY BELIEF
MISTER DIRECTOR IS THAT WE NEED
TO UPGRADE ALL OF OUR SALMON
HATCHERIES. AND YES YOU HAVE
MADE PROGRESS AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I DR BONHAM WAS
LITERALLY ON THE GROUND IN THE
RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED. TAKING
SALMON FROM A HATCHERY IN CINEMA
COUNTY BECAUSE IT DIDN'T HAVE A
CHILLER. AND WE'RE GONNA LOSE IN
ANY HEAT WAVE. IN BOTTOM TO A
HIGH SCHOOL. WHERE THE HIGH
SCHOOL CASA GRANDE WAS ABLE TO
KEEP THEM BECAUSE THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE A CHILLER NOW THAT'S A
GREAT STORY BUT IT'S ALSO AN
EMBARRASSMENT. THAT A FRIGGIN
WHO ARE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD IS DEPENDING ON
CASAGRANDE SOPHOMORES TO SAVE.
THESE ICONIC SPECIES IN IDEAS
USE THAT IS AGAIN THIS IS NOT OF
A POCK ON THE DIRECTOR BECAUSE
HE MOVED IT NEEDED WHATEVER THE
HELL WE NEED TO DO TO BE TO GET
IT DONE. AND WE CAN'T RELY ON
HIGH SCORES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE TO BE TO SAVE THIS
SPECIES. SO LOOK MISTER
DIRECTOR. WE NEED TO TAKE A
HOLISTIC VIEW. OF THE HATCHERY
SYSTEM WORKING WITH OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS AS WELL SO. I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
INVEST MORE WELL WE'VE MADE.
PROGRESS UNTIL CREATION AND
CHILLING SYSTEMS WE NEED TO DO
MORE I WANT TO GET YOUR COMMENT
ON THAT BECAUSE I JUST DON'T
THINK WE'RE DOING ENOUGH IN I
DON'T SEE THAT INVESTMENT IN-
IDENTITY SEVEN. SOON AND CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR THE- QUESTION AND
ALSO THE EMPHASIS ON OUR
HATCHERIES. I AGREE WITH YOU.
THEY PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE FOR
RECREATIONAL. AND COMMERCIAL
FISHING MEN AND WOMEN BUT ALSO
FOR SPECIES CONSERVATION IN THAT
ROLE HAS REALLY DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED AND EXPONENTIALLY KIND
OF INCREASE THE PRESSURE ON OUR
HATCHERIES. BECAUSE OF THIS
CLIMATE WISHED LASH AND THE
EFFECTS ON OUR FISH. SO THERE'S
A COUPLE OF BASIC FACTS I JUST
WANT TO ESTABLISH WE OWN OR
MANAGE TWENTY ONE TOTAL
HATCHERIES IN THE STATE. AND
THERE'S KIND OF TWO TYPES WONDER
FOR TRIAL INLAND. THE OTHER IS
FOR OUR ANADROMOUS SALMON STILL
HAD. AND I THINK YOUR QUESTIONS
ARE ABOUT THE ANADROMOUS ASPECT
AND THERE'S TEN OF THOSE
HATCHERIES IN THE STATE. IN
REALITY WE ONLY OWN ONE OF THEM
. AND THAT'S THE MERCED RIVER
HATCHERY SO WE'VE GOT THIS
DYNAMIC WHERE ALL THE OTHERS ARE
OWNED BY THE BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION THE ARMY CORPS WHICH
IS THE RUSSIAN RIVER RESERVOIR
YOU GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
EAST BAY MUD. SO THINKING ABOUT
REAL UPGRADE ISN'T ALWAYS JUST
CONTROLLED BY US BUT I CONFESS
WE LEARNED. LESSONS LAST YEAR
WHICH WERE DISTURBING AND WE'RE
MAKING IMPROVEMENTS UPON THAT.
SO WE'RE CURRENTLY AND THIS IS
WHAT WE WOULD BE DOING WITHIN
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S LOOKING ACROSS EVERYONE
OF OUR ANADROMOUS HATCHERIES.
DEVELOPING FOR THOSE HATCHERIES
ALL OF OUR CONTINGENCY PLANNING
AN EXAMPLE. WE KNOW THESE
RESERVOIRS MAY NOT HAVE COLD
WATER IN THE FUTURE TO SUPPLIER
HATCHERIES WHICH ARE BELOW THE
DANCE SO IT'S A GREAT STORY AS
YOU MENTIONED WE COULD EVACUATE
WARM SPRINGS HATCHERY TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL. BUT WE ALSO TO
HATCHERY IN SANTA CRUZ THAT WAS
IMPACTED BY THE LAST ROUND OF
FIRES CALL KING FISHER. WE'RE
TRYING TO GET IT BACK UP ONLINE
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE MAKING
SURE WE HAVE THE ALL THE
CONTRACTING AND FINANCING. THE
SUPPORT THE HIGH SCHOOL IF WE
NEED IT FOR A SECOND YEAR. WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH ALL KINDS OF
CONTINGENCIES FOR EACH MATCH.
AND THERE ARE OTHER PARTS OF
THIS QUESTION A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT US TO DO. DIFFERENT TYPE OF
TAGGING THE FISH. THAT USES DNA.
AND I THINK THAT'S THE FUTURE
IT'S CALLED PRINTED STACKING. IT
REALLY ALLOWS US TO OUR VERY.
FINALLY DETERMINED THE PARENTS
OF A FISH. RELATIVE TO HATCHERY
OR WILD. BUT IT'S NOT AN
OVERNIGHT TRANSITION ALL OF THE
WEST COAST ALASKA AND CANADA
USING EXISTING TECHNOLOGY ALL
CROWDED WATER TAX. SO THAT'S
PROBABLY OUR FUTURE. BUT THERE
MAY BE A WAY WE USE THIS DNA
PARENTAGE TACKING TO DO FINER
SCALE WORK THAT SUPPLEMENTS AND
COMPLIMENTS. THOSE ARE THE KINDS
OF THINGS I THINK THAT ARE IN
OUR FUTURE. I APPRECIATE YOU
RAISING THE QUESTION I'M I'M
COGNIZANT TODAY'S ITEMS HOLD
OPEN GET. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR NOW I
APPRECIATE IT BUT THE GUY I
THINK THAT THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS MONEY IS NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO USHER IN THE UPGRADE CENTERS
ARE NEEDED AND THAT'S- THERE'S
JUST NO WAY. AND WHILE I
APPRECIATE IT MAY COMPLETE AN
ASSESSMENT IT'S NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO PUT IN THE FILTRATION
SYSTEMS THE CHILLERS THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED. AND LOOK AS MUCH AS
WE MAY NOT OWN THE FACILITIES WE
DEPEND ON THE FACILITIES. FOR
THE STOCK SO IN WE ALSO DEPEND
ON THE FACILITIES FOR THE
SURVIVAL OF THE SPECIES AND I
THINK IT'S ALSO. IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT FEDERAL SIDE THE
COLEMAN HATCHERY IS ALREADY
ADVANCED THIS PARENTAGE- TAGGING
AND IT WERE IF YOU TAKE A LOOK
AT OREGON AND WASHINGTON YOU
TAKEA LOOK AT ALASKA. THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN DOING THIS FOR
YEARS AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO.
MOVE INTO THAT SO I WOULD JUST
HOPE THAT WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
FOCUS ON THIS AND WE'RE GONNA
NEED ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IN WE
HAVE TO MOVE WITH SPEED. ON THAT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION MY LAST ITEM. IF IT
WORKS MISTER CHAIR IS IDEN ON
ITEM SIXTY IN THIS IS DIRECTED
TO CHAIR ASK ABOUT. IN FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT. WE WILL GET A
SIXTY WHAT ARE. AGAIN JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU SO MUCH- MISTER
MISTER CHAIR FOR THAT AND LOOK
FOR THE CONVERSATION ON THE
ISSUE HATCHERIES IN THE FUTURE.
WE'LL GET TO THAT AND SECOND
CENTER STERN. I RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND TAKE YOU
TO THE MINISTRATION FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IN YOUR LEADERSHIP- WE
ALL KNOW THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
DROUGHT IN THE CLIMATE EMERGENCY
IN GENERAL IT'S VERY EASY TO HIT
. THE SNOOZE ON THE ALARM CLOCK
AND ASSUME THAT JUST BECAUSE IT
RAINED AGAIN- WE'RE OUT OF THE
WOODS AND IT'S ALL OVER- I DO
APPRECIATE THE AYE ON. THE SORT
OF LONG TERM. RESILIENCE AND
KNOWING THAT THERE'S NOT A SORT
OF YEAR TO YEAR DROUGHT CYCLE
ANYMORE BUT RATHER A GREAT
DRYING WE'RE IN AN ERA OF A
REDUPLICATION FOR THE ENTIRE
WEST. AND THIS IS NOT THE KIND
OF THING THAT. WILL GET LUCKY ON
SAY IN ONE BUDGET CYCLE AND-
PERHAPS NOT HAVE TO SPEND ON
THIS I THINK THAT. YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY CONCERN I HAVE IS
THAT WERE UNDER INVESTING HERE
IN GENERAL. I APPRECIATE THE
CONTINGENCY FUNDS ON THE TWO AND
A FIFTY MILLION- AND IF THERE IS
FEDERAL FUNDING POTENTIALLY
COMING IN AS WELL. BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE SCALE OF. OF WHAT
THE DROUGHT. THAT IS GOING TO
CONSUME THE ENTIRE WEST FOR. THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE- ENTAILS EVEN
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION
LIKE MINE- THE SCALE OF
INVESTMENT IS MASSIVE I WANTED
TO I KNOW SECRETARY BLUMENFELD
SPOKE- LAST MONTH ABOUT. THE
SCALE OF NEEDED IN ONE OF THESE
CATEGORIES AND WATER RECYCLING
IN PARTICULAR- WHERE I THINK
THERE'S A BILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE TO ALL WESTERN STATES
IT'S ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR- BUT THAT. THE
SECRETARY POINTED OUT LAST MONTH
DID THE NEEDS FOR RECYCLED WATER
IN CALIFORNIA EXCEED TEN BILLION
AND IN FACT THE NEEDS JUST FOR
THE LA BASIN ALONE EXCEED TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS IF YOU LOOK AT
OPERATION NEXT TO THE UPGRADES
TO HYPERION THAT ARE GONNA BE
REQUIRED IN CARSON- FOR THE
LARGER MET PROJECTS- WE DON'T. I
DON'T REALLY SEE A LOT HERE ON.
CONTINUING THAT THAT WATER
RECYCLING PUSH AND EVEN LAST
YEAR'S FUN WELL APPRECIATED I
DON'T I THINK. DIDN'T BEGIN TO
MEET THE NEEDS MAYBE OF BOTH THE
VERY LARGE PROJECTS LIKE THE
ONES I JUST MENTIONED BUT ALSO-
SOME OF THE SMALLER WATER
DISTRICTS. IN RURAL OR- SEMI
RURAL AREAS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
TO FINANCE THIS. THIS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ATTEMPT TO BE WATER
RESILIENT OURSELVES SO THAT WE
DON'T HAVE TO IMPORT AS MUCH
FROM THE NORTH WE CAN TAKE
PRESSURE OFF AGRICULTURE WE CAN
TAKE PRESSURE OFF OF. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PRESSURE OFF THE
DELTA- THESE ARE NO REGRETS
INVESTMENT SO I JUST WANT TO
GET. A QUICK. COMMENTER FEEDBACK
FROM. YEAH WHOEVER'S APPROPRIATE
SECRETARY BLUMENFELD MAY BE
BASED ON YOUR YOUR PREVIOUS
COMMENTS OR ANYONE ELSE- IN THIS
INTEGRATED WATER WORLD THE
ADMINISTRATION HOW YOU ALL ARE
LOOKING AT- AT WATER RECYCLING
STRATEGY GOING FORWARD. CAN I
TAKE THAT THEIR SENATOR AND
THANK YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR EMPHASIS HERE ON WATER
RECYCLING- AS CENTER DOLLY UP.
TO ANSWER PART OF HIS QUESTION
WHAT IS OUR STRATEGY HOW ARE WE
ADDRESSING THESE LONG TERM
TRENDS AS AS YOU SAID THE
CERTIFICATION THAT'S HAPPENING
BUT ALSO THIS BOOM AND BUST
CYCLE AND WATER RECYCLING KEVIN
IT'S CONSISTENT NATURE- AND-
ABILITY TO REUSE WHAT'S
OTHERWISE UNUSED- AND NOT PUT TO
BENEFICIAL USE WATER CURRENTLY
IS REALLY. CRITICAL IN THE FACE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE SO WE HERE AT
THE STATE WATER BOARD- ALTHOUGH
THERE AREN'T I KNOW THERE WAS A
POT OF WATER RECYCLING DOLLARS
IN THE LAST BUDGET CYCLE FIFTY
MILLION OF WHICH WENT TO- SAN
DIEGO AND I THINK THERE'S- STILL
THAN AROUND FIFTY OR SO THAT
WILL BE. LEFT TO CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE THEIR SITES THAT
DIRECT POP IN THE STATE AND AS
YOU MENTIONED A POTENTIAL
FEDERAL POT FROM INTERIOR. WE
ALSO FUND WATER RECYCLING
PROJECTS OUT OF THE STATE
REVOLVING FUNDS SO THE CLEAN
WATER STATE REVOLVING FUND THE
DRINKING WATER STATE REVOLVING
FUND AND THEIR- IN THE COMING
YEAR I BELIEVE JUST THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR WE'RE LOOKING TO
FIND ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION WORTH WATER RECYCLING
TWENTY SEVEN. DIFFERENT WATER
RECYCLING PROJECTS ACROSS THE
STATE- AND THOSE ARE ALL. AND
YOU KNOW REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS AS WELL ON ACCOUNTABILITY
THOSE ARE ALL ENUMERATED ARE
INTENDED USE PLAN THAT'S OUR
YEARLY LIST OF WHICH PROJECTS
WILL RE RECEIVING FUNDING AS A
ROLLING LIST BASED OFF THE
APPLICATIONS THAT WE HAVE. TO
THE STATE REVOLVING FUNDS AND
THAT'S HOW WE'RE ACTUALLY
FUNNELING THE ONE POINT THREE
BILLION WE RECEIVED LAST SUMMER
AS WELL UP FOR DRINKING WATER
WASTEWATER AND THERE THERE IS
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL FOR FUNDING
RECYCLING OF WATER RECYCLING
PROJECTS SO IT'S A HUGE- TOP
PRIORITY HERE DEFINITELY OF THE
STATE BOARD. AS WE EVEN FUND
SEPTIC TO SEWER PROJECTS THAT
HELP CREATE THE FLOWS AND REALLY
CONNECT THE DROPS IN A COMMUNITY
AND ALLOW RECYCLING TO BE A
CRITICAL. SOLUTION AND IN MANY
COMMUNITY IS THAT ARE A LOS. OR
SAN DIEGO IS FRAN. YOU KNOW THE
BIG- YES MINISTER. ARE ABLE TO
REALLY FIND THIS WORK WE WILL
TRYING FOCUS AND MAKE SURE WE'RE
WE'RE- THOSE. AND MEDIUM SIZE
COMMUNITY. WERE RECYCLED CAN AND
IMPORTANT. REALLY IT STRETCHING
REPLIES AND BE A CRITICAL SO AND
I THINK WE SEE A- DOCTOR-
EXAMPLE OF THAT- WHERE TURLOCK
SHERRY AND BUT ESTO YOUR ANSWER
IS. ACTUALLY PROVIDE THEIR WATER
ADULTS. RECYCLED WATER MAKES IT
INTO THE- DOCUMENT. CANAL YOU
KNOW THAT IS- THOSE ARE EXAM OF
OCT AT. WE THAT WE TO WRAP THE
STATE LEADERSHIP. TESTIFY AND AN
EXCEL- WHAT RISK AS ONE OF THE
MORE CRITICAL WE COULD POSSIBLY. FIVE THANK YOU FOR THE- CHURCH
- SO WHAT WE'LL LOOK TO THAT
INTENDED USE REPORT AND- AND
THEN DRILL DOWN DEEPER THERE BUT
DO APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION OF
THIS- IN THE SCALE OF NEED AT
CERTAINLY OUTSTRIPPING OUR
SUPPLY IN THE NEAR TERM HERE I
WANTED TO ASK YOU ONE OTHER
QUESTION- I THINK IT MAY BE FOR
DIRECTOR NEMETH- BUT THE OTHER
ANOTHER CRIME IMPACTED WE OFTEN
DON'T TALK ABOUT CERTAINLY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FLOODS-
DESPITE BEING IN A MASSIVE FLOOD
PLAIN AND HAVING TREMENDOUS
RISKS WE KNOW THAT. THEY ALSO
EXIST- IN THE FAR NORTH- WE'VE
SEEN THE MODELS AND ANDERSON
DAM- WE KNOW THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE EVERYWHERE BUT PEOPLE
OFTEN DON'T THINK OF THE LA AREA
BEING AT RISK I WAS CURIOUS HOW
I KNOW THE RESULTS WE DID THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN FLOOD
MANAGEMENT LAST YEAR THERE'S
ALSO BEEN SOME TO ME SOME
EXCITING PROGRESS OCCURRING IN
YOUR PART VERY COLLABORATION
WITH HE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
ON THIS ENGINEERING WITH NATURE
INITIATIVE I JUST WANTED TO GET
YOUR TAKE ON WHETHER. YOU THINK
THERE ARE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FLOOD CONTROL INVESTMENT
STRATEGY AND I DON'T SEE A LINE
ITEM FOR THAT IN THE CURRENT
PROPOSED DROUGHT RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES BUT MAYBE JUST GIVE
US A SENSE OF WHAT WHAT YOU'RE
UP TO THESE DAYS ON THAT POT
FROM THE FLOOD CONTROL FRONT AND
WHETHER THERE'S ANY HOPE FOR US
AND SEVEN CALIFORNIA TO
POTENTIALLY PARTNER WITH WITH T.
W. AREN'T EVEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN A PLACE LIKE CITY-
YOU KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT LAKE
BALBOA THE- AS THE SPOT WHERE
YOU KNOW THERE'S STILL A MASSIVE
DAM- AND WE TO SPREADING
GROUNDS- RIGHT IN THE AREA BUT-
THAT. YOU KNOW WE WE'D RATHER
NOT JUST HARD ENGINEER OUR WAY
THROUGH ALL THIS AND JUST BUILD
UP FLOOD FLOOD- CANALS AND
INSTEAD TRY TO FIND WAYS TO SAY
EXPAND NATIVE WETLANDS OR USE
OTHER. CERTAIN NATURE BASED
INFRASTRUCTURE SO. K. YOU JUST
GIVE A LITTLE MOVE INSIGHT ON
HOW THINGS ARE UP FLOW CONTROL.
AND MAYBE OUTLOOK FOR SEVEN.
ABSOLUTELY SENATOR AND THAT'S A
TERRIFIC QUEST SO. A COUPLE OF
THINGS THERE- YOU KNOW AS A
GENERAL MATTER- THE DEPARTMENT
IS COMPLETING- OR AT LEAST
STARTING ON ITS UPDATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER PLAN. AND THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT'S LEGISLATED-
HAD MANDATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
THAT D. W. R. UPDATE EVERY-
EVERY FIVE YEARS. SO THE THRUST
OF THIS- THIS UPDATE IS IT IS
REALLY CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND
TAKING A WATERSHED SCALE LOOK.
AT HOW WE NOT ONLY PROVIDE FOR
AWHILE- THESE MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS THAT ALSO- ENHANCE
FLOOD PROTECTION FOR COMMUNITIES
SO- YOU ARE GOING TO SEE A LOT
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT HOW THESE
PIECES FIT TOGETHER. AND THAT
WILL SUGGEST- FUTURE APPROACHES
TO FUNDING THAT- MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS EVEN STRONGER- THAN
THAN WE'VE BEEN DOING REALLY IN
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS- AS
PART OF PROPOSITION ONE- YOU MAY
REMEMBER THAT WE HAD- HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN THERE FOR
WHAT WE CALL MULTI BENEFIT FLOOD
PROTECTION- AND THOSE ARE THE
DOLLARS THAT- THE DEPARTMENT HAS
BEEN. EXPANDING ON- OUR URBAN
WRIST WORK URBAN RISK FLOOD
REDUCTION PROGRAM- AND OTHER
KINDS OF GRANT PROGRAMS THAT CAN
DO THE THINGS THAT- THAT YOU
DESCRIBE WE HAD WE ARE HAVING
GREAT CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CORPS OF ENGINEERS. AND ON THEIR
ENGINEERING WAS WITH NATURE-
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM TO
IDENTIFY SOME PILOT PROJECTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY'RE
VERY INTERESTED IN THAT- THERE
IS A- THE- A LIST OF- KINDS OF
PROJECTS THAT THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS IS LOOKING TO FUND-
THROUGH THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. BILL AND WE ARE
RIGHT NOW PARTNERING WITH THE
BOARD OF ENGINEERS TO UNDERSTAND
THOSE BETTER AND IDENTIFY THOSE
PLACES IN CALIFORNIA THAT- THAT.
ARE OPPORTUNE. FOR THIS KIND OF-
ENGINEERING WITH NAY BUT ALSO. A
REAL TIGHT- INTEGRATE BETWEEN.
BENEFITS AND WATER SUPPLY IN
OVERALL CLIMATE. RESILIENCY I
WOULD SAY. AS A AS A GENERAL
MATTER THE OTHER THING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS TRACKING VERY
CLOSELY WHICH IS GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA IT'S
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S- THAT
WATER RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO IS
UNDERSTANDING- BETTER WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE NATIONAL
FLOOD INSURANCE PROGRAM- AS A
GENERAL MATTER CALIFORNIA PAYS
MORE INTO THAT PROGRAM AND THEN
WE SEE COMING BACK TO
CALIFORNIA- AND- PART OF WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHEN WE LOOK
AT- THE- SORT OF NEXT. STRATEGY
FOR FUNDING NEXT GENERATION
FLOOD PROTECTION PROJECTS IS.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO- RELATIVE TO-
INTERACTINGWITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THAT NATIONAL
FLOOD INSURANCE PROGRAM- THE
DEPARTMENT IS WORKING WITH THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA'S
OFFICE TO- AGAIN IT TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE PROGRAMS-
COULD WORK IN THE FUTURE
ESPECIALLY WITH INCREASED RISK
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE. SO WE ARE
VERY MUCH MOVING THROUGH THE
DOLLARS THAT- HAS BEEN HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED FOR
THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS- AND
ULTIMATELY THROUGH THE WATER
PLAN BUT ALSO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FLOOD PROTECTION PLAN. IT'S THAT
DOESN'T EXTEND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND ITS FOCUS ON YOU
KNOW OUR OUR WITH OUR MAJOR AT
ST- PLAN A FLOOD CONTROL WHICH-
COVERS THOSE SAN JOAQUIN IN THE
SACRAMENTO SYSTEMS BUT- I SAY
THAT AS A- AN EMPHASIS ON. THAT
DOCUMENT COMBINED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATER PLANT OUR OUR
GO FORWARD- DOCUMENTS TO DO THE
THINGS THAT YOU- THAT YOU ARE
POINTING OUT AS- REALLY THE NEXT
GENERATION OF PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS FROM FLOOD- I'D BE
GLAD TO HAVE MORE CONVERSATION
WITH A YOU AND YOUR STAFF-
OFFLINE TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE PROJECTS LOCAL TO YOUR AREA.
OR THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE'RE
SEEING THERE'S REALLY
INTERESTING ONES. UNDER WAY- IN
MERCED COUNTY- WE'VE HAD SOME
NOVEL APPROACHES- IN THE PAPAROA
AREA- AND SENATOR LAYER DISTRICT
WHERE WE HAD. MULTIPLE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO
GROUNDWATER RELATED TO SALMON
RESTORATION AND RELATED TO FLOOD
PROTECTION SO THERE'S A. LOT OF
GOOD THINGS HAPPENING IN THE
STATE. YOU CAN- LOOK TO THE TO
BRING TO BE PROVIDING A BRA- GO
FORWARD THROUGH THESE THESE TWO
PRIME- LET'S JUST MANDATE PLAN
DOCUMENTS THAT THE- IS PREPARING
RIGHT NOW- THANK YOU FOR THAT-
RE DIRECT AND WE WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT TO
APPRECIATE THE WALK THROUGH. I
KNOW. I KNOW THE ALAMEDA CREEK
PROJECT WHICH THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES IN THE STATE
WATER. RESOURCES BOARD HAVE BEEN
WORKING THROUGH THE PERMITTING
PROCESS I THINK WE'RE ON THE
THIRD YEAR AND ESSENTIALLY THIS
IS A PROJECT THAT TAKES EXISTING
RIVER. AND SO THAT WE CAN TO
WATER QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
FISHERIES IMPROVEMENT- ALSO SEA
LEVEL RISES WORKED THE
CALCULATIONS IS GONNA CUT IS
GOING TO MODIFY UP TO ONE FOOT A
C. LEVEL RISE. AND WHILE THE
COURT HAS SIGNED OFF ON THE
PERMITTING. THE WATER RESOURCE
BOARD THE D. W. R. HAVE NOT AND
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT THERE'S
CEMENTED. RIVERS STORE AUTHORED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE'D LIKE
TO SEE THOSE PROJECTS TO WIN AND
WE DON'T WANT TO REALLY WAIT
THREE OR FOUR YEARS FOR.
REGULATING COMMUNITY TO DO THAT
SO THAT'S JUST SUCH. A WEIRD OF
CONCERN. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE HOLD
THIS ITEM SO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
SEVEN WE WILL HOLD AND MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTY. EIGHT
WHICH IS THE FARMS- THE FARM TO
SCHOOL PROGRAM SECRETARY ROSS-
GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK WITH OUR
FOLKS I SEE THAT THE CALIO
RECOMMENDS THAT WE REJECT THE
OFFER. FOR INTERESTED ON YOUR ON
THAT. WHAT IS THE PROPER TO
THANK YOU FOR MUCH ON THE FARM
PREP IS- PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BY. I DON'T KNOW MAN
OF THIRTY TWO POINT EIGHT FIVE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THIS IS
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
GRANTS TO SCHOOLS AND I WILL
TALK ABOUT THAT IN JUST A MOMENT
IT ALSO INCLUDES- AT FUNDING FOR
STAFFING SIXTEEN REGIONAL STAFF
MEMBERS TO HELP BUILD OUT THIS
NETWORK TO TRULY MAKE THIS
PROGRAM SUCCESSFUL. SO I WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY THIS
PROGRAM IS SO IMPORTANT AT ONE
MAJOR REASON IS THAT LAST YEAR
WE STARTED ONE BILLION MEALS IN
SCHOOLS AND THAT WAS IN THE
MIDST OF A OF A PANDEMIC BUT
THAT MANY MANY CHALLENGES THAT
OUR SCHOOL NUTRITION DIRECTORS
HAD ADMINISTRATORS AND FAMILIES.
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE SCHOOL
MEALS AS AS EVEN MORE ACUTE. NOW
THAN IT EVER HAS BEEN. THIS
PRESS. IS ABOUT NENE'S. WHO THIS
IS GAME OF INTEREST MILK THEY'LL
GET AND CASES UNFORTUNATELY IT
MAY NOT IT MAY BE THE ONLY KNOW
THAT THEY GET. IN THE SCHOOL DAY
AND SO IT'S AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM
FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS AS WE
FIGHT HUNGER AND IMPROVE
SECURITY. BUT WHAT I REALLY WANT
TO EMPHASIZE ABOUT THIS IS THAT
IS A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO SCHOOL
MALES. TO BUILDING OUT AND
IMPROVING THE RESILIENCY OF
LOCAL FOOD SYSTEMS BY EXPANDING
LOCAL PROCUREMENT BY OUR LARGEST
INSTITUTIONS. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING THAT
CAME OUT LAST YEAR ONE OF THE
EARLY COMMENTS THAT WAS MADE AND
THAT. IS THAT THIS NEEDS TO BE
ABOUT HEALTHY AGING IN EVERY
DECADE. AND THOSE YOUNG DECADES
ARE THE PLACES WHERE WE CAN MAKE
THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE I'VE
CITING HEALTH CARE'S HEALTHCARE
COSTS BY REDUCING CHRONIC
DISEASE BY IMPROVING NUTRITION
AND HOW WE EAT AND HOW WE
EXERCISE STARTING FROM THE
YOUNGEST AGES- BCP WOULD ALLOW
US TO EXPAND ON A PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT WE HAD IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR OR TEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT
PROGRAM WAS OVER SUBSCRIBED WE
HAD OVER EIGHTY APPLICATIONS AT
THAT TIME. AND TWENTY TWENTY WE
WORK AT FIRST PARTNER JENNIFER
SIEBEL. NEWSOM TO REALLY. BRING
TOGETHER STAKEHOLDERS IN A
WORKGROUP PROCESS SO IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE ADDED AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE LEARNING ABOUT THIS ONE TO
BE A PART OF THAT. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE HOSTED A STATEWIDE
CONFERENCE FOR SCHOOL APPS FARM
TO SCHOOL PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
SCHOOL GARDEN PROGRAMS. AND
ADDED ANOTHER THREE HUNDRED
STAKEHOLDERS THE PARTIES WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN DOING BEST- AND SO
WE WILL WITHIN THE NEXT TWO
WEEKS BY RELEASING A GRANT
PROGRAM THIS YEAR FOR THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THIS. FISCAL YEAR'S
BUDGET WE EXPECT THAT TO BE.
HEAVILY OVERSUBSCRIBED BASED ON
THE INTEREST WE HAVE. BASED ON
THE ADDITION STEAK OUT AND- THAT
WE DONE. AND WE FEEL THAT HAVING
A TOTAL OF SIX MILLION NEXT AS I
DID THE RIGHT TIME NOT ONLY
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE THIS
ADDITIONAL STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AND WE NOW HAVE THAT
CHANCE INTEREST IN THIS PROGRAM.
BUT ALSO THE PANDEMIC REALLY
COMPOUNDED FOR PEOPLE THE
FRUSTRATIONS THAT MANY OF US ARE
FEELING WITH OUR SUPPLY CHAIN
AND PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO
SHORTEN THAT SUPPLY CHAIN THE
BRING IT CLOSER TO HOME TO BE
ABLE TO FIND AN SOURCE MARK
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA GROWN
PRODUCTS THAT ARE CLOSER TO
HOME. AND VERY IMPORTANTLY TO
COMBINE THAT WITH NUTRITION
EDUCATION WITH EXPERIENCE OLD
LEARNING EDUCATION THAT REALLY
TREATS THE WHOLE CHILD AND
LEARNING ABOUT WHERE FOOD COMES
COMES FROM ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
ABOUT ALL OF THE WAYS THAT WE
CAN TEACH MATH AND SCIENCE MY
SCHOOL GARDENS AND THAT KIND OF
EXPERIENCE A LEARNING. EQUALLY
IMPORTANT THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT
ALSO PUT EMPHASIS ON SOURCING
LOCALLY FROM SMALL HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED FARMERS SO THAT THEY
HAVE AN OUTLET FOR THE FOR THEIR
PRODUCTIVITY CLOSE TO HOME WHERE
THEY KNOW THAT THEY KNOW WHO
THEY'RE SELLING IT TO WE'RE
HELPING TO BUILD OUT COMMUNITY.
AND WE FEEL THAT WITH JUST
ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S PROPOSED FOR THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR WE CAN MAKE A
TRULY HAD START TRANSFORMING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT WE CAN MAKE THIS KIND OF
HEALTHY FOOD OFFERINGS AVAILABLE
FOR THE LONG TERM FUTURE- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE
OPPORTUNITIES. WITH THESE KINDS
OF GRANT DOLLARS THE POSITION
OUR LOCAL EDUCATION UNITS ARE
LOCAL SCHOOLS WITH THEIR
NUTRITION DIRECTORS AND WITH OUR
LOCAL PRODUCERS ALSO BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THESE FUNDS FOR
INDIVIDUAL GRANTS THAT WE
ANTICIPATE WILL BE COMING
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE UNITED
STATES DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE. I KNOW THAT WE'VE
DONE OVER TIME TO GET A AND SO I
BRUSHED THROUGH THAT
PRESENTATION- BUT I VERY OFTEN
THIS BASED ON THE THAT WE DONE.
THAT WE WILL BE OVER. FOR A
PROBE AND CURRENT FISCAL YEAR.
AND WHAT WELL MESSAGE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS AS BEING AS FOR
NEXT FISCAL YEAR THANK YOU. AND
BEFORE I GET TO THE L. A. L. YOU
YOU SET THE CURRENT YEAR'S GRANT
APPLICATIONS ARE GOING OUT CAN
YOU GIVE US AN UPDATE OF WHAT
THE LANDSCAPE LOOKS LIKE PUT THE
FARMERS MARKETS I KNOW YOU
TALKED ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED FARMERS
CITY DO THAT BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
ALL THESE FARMERS MARKETS ARE
ALL OVER. THE ALL OVER THE STATE
THEY GET TO THE END OF THE
MARKET AND THEY GOT ALL THAT X.
X. X. AS- VEGETABLES IN EXCESS.
SOMETIMES A PACK UP SOMETIMES
YOU TRY TO. READ THE DUMP IT
OFFERED I DON'T KNOW WE'RE THE
GRANT APPLICATIONS WHAT YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT INTERSECTION
BETWEEN. YOUR DEPARTMENT THE
SCHOOLS THE MAIN MARKET MANAGER
FOR THESE FARMERS MARKET SAID
THAT IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S SOMEBODY
TO CONNECT THE DOTS THERE. I
DON'T KNOW. THAT'S A GREAT
OBSERVATION AND ONE OF THE WAYS
WE'VE DONE WELL THERE'S SEVERAL
WAYS THAT WE HAVE DONE THAT ONE
IT'S WITH A REALLY STRONG
PARTNERSHIP CALLED FAMILY. FARM
TO FAMILY THAT IS A PARTNERSHIP.
WITH OUR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS. AND WE'VE REALLY
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE THE
OFFERINGS AND THOSE FAMILY TWO
BOXES BY PUTTING SO MUCH MORE
FRESH PRODUCE INTO BAT. AND SO
MANY OF OUR FARMERS MARKETS DO
YOU HAVE AN EXISTING PARTNERSHIP
THERE FOR THOSE FARMERS WHO WANT
TO DONATE THAT. PRODUCT AND MORE
AND MORE SHOULD BANKS ARE ALSO
BEING ABLE TO BECAUSE OF THE
INFUSION OF INVESTMENTS UNDER-
SOME OF THAT FEDERAL LEGISLATION
AND BEEN ABLE TO DO MARK
PROCUREMENT. AND THEY'RE TRYING
TO SOURCE NOT ONLY FROM THE
LARGER FARMS WHICH IS A VERY
EFFICIENT WAY OF GETTING BULK
PURCHASES MADE. BUT ALSO TRYING
TO SOURCE MORE AND MORE LOCALLY.
WHICH IS ANOTHER WAY OF. OF
SUPPORTING PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND ALSO OFFERING MORE
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE TYPES OF
OFFERINGS AND ALSO BOXES. BUT
BEING ABLE TO INSTITUTIONAL
INSTITUTIONAL BUYING AT THE
SCALE OF THE SCHOOL'S. OF
FARMERS MARKET IS NOT WELL
SUITED FOR THAT THEY NEED TO
BUY. A CERTAIN SCALE THEY NEED
TO HAVE SOME. RELIABILITY OF HOW
MUCH THEY CAN GET AT WHAT TIMES
OF THE YEARS WHEN THE SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN AND SERVING HIS
LUNCHES. AND SO THIS IS REALLY
TRYING TO BUILD OUT. A LOCAL
FOOD SYSTEM. THAT CAN BETTER
MATCH WHAT'S BEING GROWN IN THAT
AREA. AND NOW WITH THE MARKETS
ARE. INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE
WEEKLY FARMERS MARKET AND
HELPING THIS IS WHAT I STYLE AND
ALSO ALL OF THAT. IT'S REALLY
MATCHING WHERE THE DEMAND YES.
AND ALIGNING THAT WITH WHAT'S
BEING GROWN IN THE AREA. THIS WE
ALSO HAVE A FOOD AB PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WAY FUNDED THIS
YEAR. THAT WILL HELP WITH SOME
OF THE AGRIC. BUT THAT'S REALLY
BEEN THE MISSING LINK TO REAL
TRY CLOSE. SCHOOL NUTRITION
DIRECTOR. PLANNING APPLES FOR
THE YEAR BEING A TO CONNECT.
WITH LOCAL FARMERS TO KNOW
WHAT'S AVAILABLE AND THEN A LINE
THAT DEMAND. AND WHAT'S
AVAILABLE- FROM THE- FROM THE
FARMERS- THAT'S THAT OUR FARMERS
MARKETS ARE VERY IMPORTANT. BUT
THAT'S NOT THE GREATEST AT FOUR
FOR THE KIND OF INSTITUTIONAL
BUYING THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING
YOUR FOR THE SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM. OKAY I KNOW AND I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW DURING THIS CAN
GET MAKE MANY OF MEMBERS HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN FOOD GIVEAWAYS
BECAUSE THAT. THE FOOD BANKS
HAVE EXPLODED AND I KNOW THAT
THE GROCERY STORES IT SAID-
LITTLE KNOWN FACT THAT DATE WHEN
THEIR VEGETABLES REACHED THE
POINT WHERE THEY DON'T WANT TO
SELL THAT THEIR DONATING SOME OF
THAT TO THE FOOD BANKS IN GOING
IN S. BUT IF I'M SURE WE WANT
TO KEEP AN EYE ON THE NEED IS
GREAT THERE IS A LOT OF HUNGRY
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU
KNOW CHIPSTER. ONE OPTION FRESH
FRUIT IS ANOTHER OPTION- SO.
WHAT WILL BE INTERESTED IN AND
HOW THAT GOES ON- LET'S HEAR
FROM THE ALLEY- BEFORE HERE'S
WHAT FINANCING GIVE. IF YOUR
COMMENTS ARE CHAIR ON THIS
PROGRAM. YEAH AM GOING MISTER
CHANG COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRANK
MENACE AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- SO THIS
PROPOSAL HAS TWO COMPONENTS
THERE'S TWO POINT NINE MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND AN ONGOING
FOR SIXTEEN REGIONAL STATUS
SECRETARY ROSS MENTION. AND
THIRTY MILLION ONE TIME FOR THE
FARM TO SCHOOL INCUBATOR GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDES. GRANTS
TO SCHOOLS TO PARTICULAR QUICKLY
SEARCH FOODS AND ALSO PROVIDE ON
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES THAT-
BRIDGE THE CAFETERIA IN THE
CLASSROOM- FOR THIS PROPOSAL
RECOMMENDED THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED FUNDING FOR THE SIXTEEN
REGIONAL STAFF. WE FIND AT THE
REGIONAL STAFF COULD BETTER
SUPPORT SCHOOLS AND IMPLEMENTING
FARM TO SCHOOL PRACTICES BY
TELLING TAILORING MEANS THE
SCHOOL THEY HAVE SIMILAR
REGIONAL BARRIERS IN
IMPLEMENTING THESE PRACTICES.
HOWEVER WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THE
ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION FOR
THE FARM TO SCHOOL INCUBATOR
GRANT PROGRAM- AS YOU RECALL THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PACKAGE PROVIDED- THEIR TRAINING
FOR THE GRANT PROGRAM THIRTY
MILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR. AND
THIRTY MILLION IN THE BUDGET
HERE SO THERE'S FUNDING FOR THE
GRANT PROGRAM- IN THE BUDGET.
YEAR BASED ON ACTIONS TAKEN LAST
YEAR- BUDGET ALSO INCLUDED
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING. FOR THE
TO REPORT BACK ON PROGRAMMATIC
OUTCOMES BY TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
WE FIND THAT PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD BE
PREMATURE BEFORE THESE OUTCOMES
ARE REPORTED ON- WE ALSO FIND
THAT THERE ARE UNCERTAINTIES ON
WHETHER THEY'LL BE DEMAND FOR
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
AVAILABLE GRANTS AT THE
LEGISLATURE WERE TO APPROVE THIS
ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION. I'M
FOR THE FIRST- GRANT CYCLE FOR
THE PROGRAM BACK IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE DEPARTMENT MADE
AVAILABLE IN A HALF MILLION IN
GRANTS AND ONLY RECEIVE TWELVE
MILLION. AND TOTAL REQUEST- SO
WE DON'T KNOW IF THE DEMAND IS
GOING TO BE THERE FOR THE
ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION FOR A
TOTAL OF SIXTY MILLION NOBODY
HERE. AND THEN WE FIND THAT A
TWO YEAR INCREASE FROM IN A HALF
MILLION TO SIXTY MILLION AS A
RELATIVELY LARGE INCREASE FOR A
NEW PROGRAM- THEN THOSE ARE
COMMENTS AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS- MR DEALER FINANCE.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE
SORT OF. HOLD THE ITEM WE SEE
WHAT. HAPPENS IN TWO WEEKS WITH
THE GRANT PROGRAM WILL ALLOW YOU
GUYS TO COME BACK. TO PROVIDE US
WITH SOME MORE INFORMATION SO WE
LOOK AT THE- TOTALITY OF THIS
BRAND NEW PROGRAM- YOUR COMMENTS
. YES SIR DO EITHER BY AND
LITTLE ROCK DID A GREAT JOB OF
HIGHLIGHTING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE INVESTMENT THE ONLY THING
ALL ALL AT ON YOU. IS THAT THIS
IS PART OF A LARGER- YOUR
NUTRITION INVESTMENT
ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING AND
THERE'S OTHER COMPONENTS WITHIN
THE EDUCATION BUDGET BUT
DEFINITELY. THERE'S ADDITIONAL
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
ONE I PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND OVER THREE YEARS THE HELP
OF A BRIEF ALTERCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EQUIPMENT.
THAT BETTER INCORPORATE MORE
FRESH AND MINIMALLY PROCESSED
CALIFORNIA GROWN SCHOOLS WILL
MEAL AND LIVE PART OF A OF A
LARGER ADMINISTRATION EFFORT-
THE COMPUTER ACCORDING TO
CHRISTIAN AND- CALIFORNIA I'M
GOING TO THAT THOUGH- I AGAIN
YOU KNOW WILL WILL BE KIND OF
WHAT THE APPLICATION LOOK LIKE
BUT I. MENTIONED YOU KNOW GIVEN
THE OTHER INCREASE DISCUSSION WE
HAD OUR LAST SEVERAL YEARS THAT
PROGRAM AT REALLY KIND OF YOU
STARTED YOU KNOW WE THERE'S BEEN. REGROW SOME OF OUR SCHOOLS
MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS. NOT ONLY
HAVE LETTER. METAL SHOP SOME
WHICH ARE AND- DEPART. THE- BE
LIQUIDATED BUT ALSO THEIR CAPITA
THEY GONE TO YOU KNOW THEY JUST
BRING IT ON DON'T KNOW HOW TO
BOY WATER ON THIS SIDE OR THE-
TRAIN PEOPLE WHICH IS ANOTHER.
YOU KNOW SO WE GREAT TO. IT'S
GREAT TO WANT THEM TO TEACH BUT
A LOT OF FROM OUR WILL BACK AND
SAY WE NOW WE HAVE SOME STANDARD
OR WHATEVER WE WANT TO DO SO
IT'S THAT LIKE A NO. TO THOSE OF
US WHO ARE IN THE TRENCHES TO
SEE REALLY YOU DON'T PREPARE THE
FOOD IN THE CAFETERIA BUT-
THAT'S A TO BE DONE. TO ADDRESS
LATER I DON'T SEE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS MATTER OPEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INPUT ON HERE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO IT HI-
HEARING ON THE UPDATES. SILVA
I'VE NEVER FIFTY EIGHT FOR ISSUE
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT IS DEALT WITH
LET'S BRING BACK A DIRECTOR
BOTTOM AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE WE HAVE. ITEM
NUMBER IF ISSUE NUMBER FIFTY
NINE THE WHALE AND SEA TURTLE
SEA FISHERIES AND NISHA TO-
YOU'RE ASKING FOR MONEY FROM THE
E. L. P. F. F. RATHER THAN AN
INCREASE IN FEES WHILE THE
QUESTIONS OF STAFF IS. ASKED
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU CHAIR.
SO IT IS THE BOTTOM LINE. AS OF
TODAY CALIFORNIA IS POISED TO BE
THE FIRST STATE IN DIS UNITED
STATES DAPPER TRULY. WHALE AND
SEE TOTAL SAFE COMMERCIAL AND
RECREATIONAL FISHERIES. WE ARE
THE FIRST STATE THAT'S EVER SAW
. TO GET FEDERAL APPROVAL UNDER
THE FEDERAL ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT FOR HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLAN THAT COVERS SUCH LARGE
MAJESTIC YOU KNOW MARINE MAMMALS
AS WHALES AND SEA TURTLES. WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF THAT EVERYONE
ELSE. HAS IT BEEN HARD
ABSOLUTELY. HAS IT BEEN FULL OF
CONTENTION AND OFTEN VERY HEATED
ARGUMENT BETWEEN IMPORTANT
COMMUNITIES FOR THE DEPARTMENT
NO TELL. SENATOR MCGUIRE
DESERVES A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
WORKING THROUGH THIS WITH THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES IN THE
DEPARTMENT. WE SEEK THREE YEARS
OF FUNDING. AND. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX THOUSAND FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE FUND
THE SAME IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR AND. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND THIS WOULD SUPPORT
THREE LIMITED TERM. STAFF TO
START THE INITIAL. AND WHAT IS
THE INITIATIVE LET ME ANSWER ALL
THE STAFF QUESTIONS ON PAGE
SIXTY FOUR SO WHY V. E. L. P. S.
WELL IT ACTUALLY SAYS PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE SECTION.
210-001-0090 SUBSECTION D. IT
AUTHORIZES THE USE OF THE
LICENSE PLATE FUND FOR
PROTECTION OF NON GAME SPECIES
AND THREATENED AND ENDANGERED
PLANTS AND ANIMALS. PERHAPS
IRONICALLY YOU CAN ALSO HAVE A
LICENSE TAG IN THIS STATE THAT
AS A WHALE TAIL ON IT- THE
QUESTION ALSO CONTINUES WHY NOT.
BE INCREASE MMHM THREE REASONS.
FIRST THE DEPARTMENT ONLY HAS
ONE SPECIFIC ACCOUNT FOR
DUNGEONS CRAB AND THAT'S FUND IS
LIMITED TO ADMINISTRATING- CRAB
TRAP PROGRAM AND IT'S NOT
ALLOWED TO BE USED FOR ANY OTHER
PROGRAM. FOR PURPOSE SECOND
REASON WE TRIED TO RAISE
COMMERCIAL LANDING FEES A FEW OF
YOU WERE ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE AT
THE TIME THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND JUST
SPEAKING PERSONALLY I BARELY
SURVIVED WE REMEMBER. OUR
MEMBERS. LASTLY. YOU KNOW YOU
COULD MAKE A LEGITIMATE CASE
THEY'RE JUST NOT INDUSTRY FUNDS
IT'S A CHALLENGING TIME TO BE A
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN OR
WOMAN LIVING ON THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA TRYING TO MAKE A
LIVING. ENGINE THINGS IN THE
OCEAN. THERE'S A BROAD PUBLIC
BENEFIT TO PROTECT THAT
ANNECTENS FEDERALLY PROTECTED
WHALES AND SEA TURTLES. AND AT
THE SAME TIME ENSURE A- VIABLE
AND EQUALLY ICONIC DUNGEONS
SCRIPTURE. NEXT QUESTION WHAT'S
UNIQUE ABOUT THIS WELL I'VE
ALREADY MENTIONED ITS FIRST IN
THE NATION KIND OF WORK THAT'S
STUFF WE SHOULD BE PRODUCT BUT
MOREOVER. ITSELF PIONEERING
APPROACH I MEAN IT'S THIS IS
CUTTING EDGE. WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DO AND HAVE BEEN
DOING FOR A COUPLE YEARS IN A
TEST PROGRAM WHICH WOULD NOW BE
APPROVED. WE HELD BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE'RE DOING WELL
OBSERVATIONS FROM MULTIPLE
SOURCES INCLUDING OCEANOGRAPHIC
AND CLIMATE DATA SOCIOECONOMIC
SUITE DYNAMICS AND IMPROPER
INPUTS SCIENTISTS. FISHERMEN
WOMEN AND NON PROFITS TO
EVALUATE THE RISK OF OUR FISHING
IN TANGLING THESE MARINE MAMMALS
IN THE REAL TIME MOMENT. IN FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS EACH YEAR WE ARE
LOOKING THIS DATA REAL TIME AT A
WAY THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE
ANYWHERE I WOULD ARGUE IN THE
WORLD. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
THAT'S WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT THIS
APPROACH. WE'RE LEARNING FROM IT
OTHER STATES ARE CONSIDERING
FOLLOWING OUR LEAD. AND WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING ON THE DUNGENESS
CRAB FISHERY. COULD EVENTUALLY
BE APPLIED TO OUR OTHER STATE
FISHERIES. BETTER FIXED GEAR
LIKE LOBSTER ROCK ROBIN SPOT
PRAWN WHICH MAY ALSO HAVE
LIABILITY EXPOSURE IF ANYONE
WERE TO DECIDE TO CHALLENGE.
LASTLY STAFF ASKS IS THERE A
GUARANTEE IF WE DO THIS THEY'LL
BE NO LEGAL RISK NOW I CAN'T
OFFER YOU THAT GUARANTEED WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU IS. WE WERE SUED
CALIFORNIA THE DEPARTMENT AND ME
PERSONALLY IN MY OFFICIAL
CAPACITY. FOR POSSIBLE LIABILITY
UNDER THE FEDERAL ESA. BECAUSE
WHAT'S CALLED TAKE ARM THE
WHALES AND SEA TURTLES WAS
HAPPENING. THE STATE'S LIABILITY
FOR THAT ALLEGED VIOLATION
CONTINUES UNTIL WE GET A FEDERAL
PERMIT. AND THIS FUNDING IS FOR
THE PURPOSES OF GETTING THAT
FEDERAL PERMIT. COULD I GET
STUDENT FUTURE PRESSURE I'LL
TELL YOU. SOME OF THE MOST
MADDENING PARTS OF THE JOB WE'RE
PRETTY REGULARLY SUED ON AN
ISSUE AT THE SAME TIME ONE
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS WERE NOT
PROTECTIVE ENOUGH FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND THE OTHER
COMMUNITY MAY SAY WE'RE TOO
PROTECTIVE FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
SO THERE'S RISK IN THE FUTURE.
BUT THIS FUNDING REALLY REDUCES
THE RISK BECAUSE IT ALLOWS US TO
GET THE FEDERAL PERMITS. HI
THERE THANK YOU I GUESS I CAN
TAKE JUDICIAL NOTICE THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN NAMED AS A DEFENDANT
FOR PURPOSES OF A ISSUE FOR
FIFTY NINE. LET'S GO TO MS
ASSERT THOUGH- WITH FINANCED YOU
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD ON THAT OF
THE DIRECTOR'S PRESENTATION. I
AM KAPLAN ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THANK YOU
. I I'M I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
PARTICULAR TO ADD BUT I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS. BROUGH LET'S
GO TO A- THE L. A. L. PERFECT
COLOR. MISTER CHAIR RICH EITHER
SO DALY OUT I WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL THAT GIVEN IT IS A
REALLY NEW INITIATIVE AND NEW
APPROACH THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY LEARN FAMILY MIGHT
SUGGEST THAT IT WOULD BE WORTH
IT COMMITTEE ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT TO COME BACK AND
PERCENT- YOU KNOW SOMEWHAT
REGULARLY ANNUALLY PERHAPS- ON
ON PROGRESS AND WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING- AND- CHALLENGES FOR
ENCOUNTERING. COULD BE COULD BE
THROUGH FORMAL BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE OR JUST INFORMALLY-
GIVEN THIS COULD BE A PROMISING
PRACTICE WE CAN PURSUE IN THE
FUTURE BUT NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. UNDERSTOOD
ASSEMBLY WIRE YOU HAVE A
QUESTION. ARTISTIC A COMMENT
HERE- ON THE ISSUE OF FEES AND I
JUST AND I THINK THAT WE ALL
LIVED. THE DREAM THAT YEAR WHEN
AS THE POTENTIAL OF RAISING FEES
TO ASTRONOMICAL AMOUNTS ON A
STRUGGLING FLEET SO- I AGREE
WITH THE DIRECTOR THAT HOPE THAT
WE DON'T SEE THAT COME BACK
AGAIN ESPECIALLY SINCE WE PUT
THAT CALL IN THEIR NUMBER ONE IN
THE NUMBER TWO I THINK FROM THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY BEEN A LOT OF
COORDINATION. AND IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE TO SEE THE FLEET
COMING TOGETHER EVEN WHEN
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE ENVIRONMENTAL FRIENDLY-
ALTERNATIVES TO POTENTIAL. OF
THAT GEAR ADDED TO OTHER PIECES-
THEY'VE ACTUALLY CLOSED
PROACTIVELY WHEN THEIR WHALES AT. PRESENT IN THE- HARTMAN ALONG
WITH THE FLEET ARE AND-
COMMUNICATION- AND I'LL JUST USE
THIS YEAR AS AN EXAMPLE- THE
DIRECTOR AND I WERE ABLE TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE FLEET THREE TIMES
PRIOR TO OPENING. AN IN REAL
TIME THANKS TO THE INVESTMENTS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE ALONG WITH
THE GOVERNOR I'D BE ABLE TO GIVE
REAL DATA WHERE THE WELLS ARE
AT. WHEN THEY ANTICIPATE THERE
CAN BE MOVING OUT AND IT WORKED
AND I THINK THAT- I DO SO BUT WE
NEVER GO BACK TO THE RAISING OF
FEES. BECAUSE THAT WAS. CHURCHES
THANK YOU. CENTER STERN IF
APPROPRIATE LIKE MAKE A MOTION
ON THE ITEM THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE AS-
AS BUDGET ARM. THAT WILL TREAT
IT AS A MOTION TO APPROVE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY NINE. IF THERE'S NO
OTHER COMMENTS BY DIRECTOR
BOTTOM. CLEARLY- SEEING NONE.
BUT WE WERE LATER OTHERS MOSHE
OKAY WE'LL TAKE THE MOTION BY
SICK BY CENTER STERN WILL DEAL
WITH THAT WE DO ALL THE VOTES
BECAUSE WE HAVE ONE MORE ISSUE
AND THEN WILL OPEN UP A PUBLIC
COMMENT. FROM LOOKS CHECK A
SURE- ASK OF ALL AND THE DELTA
DELTA PROGRAM FUNDING CONVERSION
IN OPPOSITION TO TORY THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTY. PETER
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
ITEM- SO AS YOU WELL KNOW WE ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF UPDATING THE
WHAT BAY DELTA WATER QUALITY
CONTROL PLAN UPDATE- THIS
REQUEST IS TO TAKE WHAT ARE
OTHERWISE CONTRACT RESOURCES AND
CONVERT THEM TO PERSONAL UP
PERMANENT PERSONNEL- BECAUSE
WE'RE REALLY NEEDING TO HAVE
THAT LONG TERM CONSISTENCY AND
IN THE WORK THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE ENGAGING AND- AND CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE AND- AS WE UPDATE THE
WATER QUALITY CONTROL PLAN- AS
WE TALK ABOUT DECISION MAKING
AROUND. GROUND WATER RECHARGE OR
ANY POTENTIAL STORAGE HERE IN
THE STATE I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE HOW REALLY IMPORTANT
IT IS THAT THE WATER QUALITY
CONTROL PLAN UPDATE IS UPDATED
SO WE HAVE UPDATED STANDARDS TO
MAKE DECISIONS ON THOSE CRITICAL
PROJECTS THE LAST TIME THE WATER
QUALITY CONTROL PLAN UPDATE- WAS
UPDATED WAS IN THE MID NINETIES
SINCE THEN THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT HAS TAKEN OVER AND
REALLY. PROVIDED A SINGLE
SPECIES APPROACH TO WHAT WE KNOW
OUR WATERSHED Y. CHALLENGES IN
THE DELTA WATERSHED SO- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THIS ITEM AND. CUT- TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. FORGET
FINANCE. YOU'RE EITHER PART OF
MINE IS GOING TO COMMENT AT THAT
POINT BUT TO HELP AND- OKAY- L.
A. R. Y. THE FIVE DIGIT FIVE PER
POSITION WITHIN THE STATE WATER
FOR YOU HAVE COMMENT. AND WE
THAT AGAIN RETAILER ARE DOING WE
DIDN'T ANY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSED IT SEEMS
JUSTIFIED AS THERE MAY THAT TO
INTO THE NEXT OF. WORKING ON THE
PLAN AMENDMENTS IT MAKES SENSE
TO HAVE MORE RESOURCES
INTERNALLY RATHER THAN CONTRACT
AND I THINK AS IT AS NOTED IN
YOUR AGENDA THE MAIN POINT WE
WANTED TO MAKE IS JUSTICE THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT EFFORT FOR
THE STATE ESPECIALLY GIVEN
WHAT'S HAPPENING. TO THE NATIVE
SPECIES IN THE DELTA AS WELL AS
CONCERNS ABOUT UNCERTAINTY FOR
WATER USERS ABOUT WHAT WENT ON
THE HORIZON SO GETTING THIS DONE
IS REALLY SHOULD BE HIGH
PRIORITY AND HAS TAKEN A LONG
TIME SO ARE THERE OTHER STEPS
LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE TO HELP
ESCALATE THIS PROCESS AND MOVE A
LONG. WAY JUST REALLY IMPORTANT
OVERSIGHT ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE THINK PERHAPS
AREAS TO PURSUE IF THERE ARE
STEPS TO GET THIS IMPORTANT.
STATE PRIORITY ACCOMPLISHED.
WHAT ABOUT THAT YOU'RE A
CABALLERO FLETCHER I. SOME
FUNDING IS NEEDED TO FINISH THE
JOB WORK WE WILL GET IT IS A
CHANGING- SEEN THAT WE HAVE WITH
WITH THE TROUT AND DIFFERENT
TENSIONS THERE THAN IT WAS IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE WHEN THE
LAST BE PLANNED BUT- NO STAFF IS
ASKING EITHER INTERIM STEPS THAT
WE CAN DO TO GET SOME SORT OF
RESOLVE TO MOVE US TO. A
MEANINGFUL BAY DELTA PLAN. I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION WHAT WE
HAVE RECENTLY IS SORRY
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS ACTUALLY-
JUST THIS PAST DECEMBER
REGARDING WHERE THE STATUS IS OF
THE UPDATE WHAT THE TIME LINES
ARE. AS WE LOOK AT THAT TO THE
YEARS AHEAD HERE- AND MOMENTS
FOR ENGAGEMENT IMPORTANTLY SO
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE ARE MAKING
PROGRESS YEAR ON MOVING ALONG
THE DISCUSSION AND YOUR POINT
PROVIDED SOME CLARITY JUST ON.
HOW HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE- VIEWING THE PROJECT AND
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT ANY
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE REQUEST
WILL. WELL AT THIS POINT WHERE
WE ARE WAITING TO SEE- BUT
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS MATERIALIZE
AND OF TH SECRETARIES ARE VERY
MUCH PRIORITIZING THOSE. THAT
ALSO WILL HAVE IMPACT ON WHAT
WHAT EXACTLY ARE PROJECT
COMPLETELY LOOKS LIKE YES THIS
REQUEST FOR THE CONVERSION FOR
THE PERMANENT. FIVE PERMANENT
POSITIONS AT THIS POINT REALLY
FULFILLS WHAT THIS RESOURCE NEED
THERE WHERE WHERE AND A FINE.
BUT NOW AS ALWAYS WILL WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE PROJECT
AND WE NEED ADDITIONAL. THAT
WILL WILL HAVE DISCUSSION. I'M
SURE ALL KEEP OUR EYES THOSE
THAT TO CAPE- WATER RIGHT
PROCEED CENTER. ON FIVE CONTINUE
. MEMBERS OF. THE CHAIR. IN A
REQUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHER I'LL BE TWO MINUTES
OR LESS- ON ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
FIRST AND FOREMOST I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO CHAIR ASK
ABOUT. A TERRACE GROSSMAN IN
TOUCHING INVOLVED IN NOT JUST IN
OUR NECK OF THE WOODS WITHIN THE
KLAMATH RIVER WATERSHED THE
RIVER WATERSHED THE RUSSIAN
RIVER WATERSHED BUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE- A&E HE'S EVERYWHERE
IN TO THE GRATEFUL FOR HIS HARD
WORK ESPECIALLY. IN THIS PAST
DIFFICULT YEAR IN FACT I WANNA
TALK ABOUT. THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE
ESPECIALLY SINCE THE RUSSIAN
RIVER WATERSHED WAS ONE OF THE
HARDEST HIT NOT JUST IN THE
STATE BUT IN THE WEST. AND
CONTINUES TO HAVE INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES IN THE CHAIRS. ARE
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THIS SO THIS
MAY BE A QUESTION FOR THE CHAIR
OR FOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.%
BUT THE FIRST CURTAILMENT ORDERS
NEED TIRE CITY CALIFORNIA WAS IT
WITHIN THE RUSSIAN RIVER
WATERSHED- THEN WE HAD THE
GOVERNOR I CAN STAND ON THE
CRACKED BED. OF LAKE MENDOCINO
TALKING ABOUT THE INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES THAT WE SEE WITHIN
THE RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED
TWITTER CURTAILMENT ORDERON THE
KLAMATH BSIN LAST YEAR BUT IN
PARTICULAR. ON THE RUSSIAN RIVER
WATERSHED- IT IS A UNIQUE AND
VULNERABLE WATERSHED AND IT ALSO
IS THE DRINKING WATER SOURCE TWO
MAIN DRINKING WATER SOURCE TO
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOLKS IN. COUNTLESS ADD USERS-
IN IT IS THE BASIN OF LIFE FOR
THE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR. WINE
INDUSTRY WHICH WE ARE SO PROUD
OF AND I'M I'M TRYING TO GET A
UNDERSTANDING ON. WHY WERE ONLY
FOCUS ON THE BAY DELTA AND NOT
RESILIENCY WITHIN THE RUSSIAN
RIVER SINCE WE KNOW IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE. MISTER
CHAIR OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER- SENATOR IT HAS BEEN AS
YOU SAID VERY CHALLENGING- IN
THE RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED
INCREDIBLE A CATASTROPHIC
CONDITIONS FACING THE
COMMUNITIES AS WE EXPAND AND
ENACTED WATER RIGHTS SYSTEM FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
THE STATE BEAR IN THE RUSSIAN
RIVER WATERSHED HAD A RESPONSE
RATE FROM WATER. OF DIVERT HERS
THAT'S ABOUT 92% SO- THAT TRUST
THAT THAT WORK IS DONE BY
LEADERS SUCH AS YOURSELF AND SO
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK IN
THE SUMMER THERE- AND KNOW THAT
ALTHOUGH YOU KNOW THIS IS HERE-
AT THE REQUEST ABOUT THE MIDDLE
TOOK PLAN AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
COMPLETE IT- IT IS IT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT WE ARE ALSO. HAVING
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS IN THE
RUSSIAN RIVER WATERSHED BOTH
THROUGH OUR WORK AROUND WATER
RIGHTS BUT ALSO DRINKING WATER
OR THEIR- PART DIVISION OF
DRINKING WATER AND DIVISION OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO RESPOND WHAT TO A NUMBER
OF COMMUNITIES AND HELP FIND-
I'VE EITHER PROGRAMS OR PROJECTS
OR OR HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEEDS FOR
FUNDING IN THOSE COMMUNITIES AND
SO- YOU KNOW. IT AND I DON'T
KNOW YOU KNOW I'M NOT UNLIKE A
POINTS WE MADE EARLIER THAT THIS
IS SHOULD REALLY BE SEEN AS PART
OF THE YOU KNOW THREE OVER THREE
PACKAGE THAT WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR AND THAT THOSE ACTIVITIES
THAT I SAT IN OF THE BOARD IS
ENGAGED IN AND THAT CAN BE-
WATER SET HAVE BEEN FUNDED AND
SO- I TAKE YOUR POINT I SEE HOW
YOU KNOW AMONGST ALL THE
POSSIBLE REQUESTED WE COULD BE
HAVING WHY JUST BE DELTA HERE IN
THIS MOMENT. BUT YOU KNOW IT IT
IT IT DOESN'T HERE BOB S.
REFLECT WHAT ARE A LOT OF
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE EXPENSES
LAST YEAR AND CONTINUE TO ADOPT
PLAN EXPENDING AS TO YOUR POINT
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT WHAT IS
GOING TO BE FACING THE COMMUNITY
THIS SUMMER HOW BEST WE PREPARE
OUR RESOURCES AND YOUR SUPPORT
THE LOCAL THE LOCAL DECISION
MAKING IN RESPONSE TO. THAT IS
THE KEY TO ADEQUATE DROUGHT
RESPONSE NOT COMMUNITIES AND.
WE'RE HERE TO SIMPLY STOP ORDER
AS BEST WE CAN SO I APPRECIATE
THAT WOULD START. THAT NOTHING
YOU SO MUCH IN MY LAST. ON THIS
IN A- I. THANK B. S. I. AM
GRATEFUL TO THE- G. IS BEING IN
. IN IN HE BEEN TO LIVE. THAT
SAID. ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUE
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT MISTER
CHAIR. WELL YOUR LOCAL SO. IN
OUR OFFICES ABOUT HIS A LONG
TERM PLAN. AND THERE IS NO LONG
TERM PLAN- AND WE ARE IN A
REACTIVE MODE. AND THAT'S WHY I
BRING THIS FORWARD. IS WHAT CAN
HOW IT IT'S GOING TO MAKE THE
BAY DELTA REGION MUCH MORE
RESILIENT. IN ONE OF OUR MOST
IMPAIRED WATERSHEDS IN THE
STATE. I WOULD JUST EXPECT THE
SAME SO LOOK FORWARD TO THAT I.
CONTINUED CONVERSATION ON THIS
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE RESEARCHER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO RISK OF ALL
ALL RIGHT THAT WILL WILL WILL
CLOSER DISCUSSION ON ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTY A SEPARATE
CONDITION IS TO HOLD AN OPEN WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH IT-
THE MINISTRATION ON THAT- BEFORE
WE VOTE PLEASE NOTE THAT WE HAVE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS- THE
WILDLIFE CONNECTIVITY ACTIONS
COMPENSATORY MITIGATION CREDITS
FOR S. B. SEVEN NINE ZERO HAS
BEEN- ALSO- PULLED SO WE ITEMS
NUMBER FOUR AND ITEMS- NUMBER
EIGHT ARE REMOVED FROM THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR AND- THEY'LL BE
DISCUSS. AT A LATER DATE WHEN
THE COMMITTEE COMES IN BEFORE WE
OPEN THE PUBLIC HEARING. CENTER
STERN- IF YOU THIS IS YOUR
LEGISLATION ON ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT. AND SEVEN NINETY IF YOU
WOULD HAVE WOULD LIKE QUICK
COMMENT OR NO COMMENT IT'S OK-
SURE OUT MIKE MY QUICK COMMENT
WHICH IS BEING ANALYSTS-
DIRECTOR BOTTOM STILL WITH US AT
I APPRECIATE THE WHAT I
UNDERSTAND TO BE THE PROACTIVE-WORK GOING ON- OVER IT. AT- D.
OF W. ON IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- YOU KNOW THE PART
THAT I MEAN I JUST HAVE
QUESTIONS ON- IN TERMS OF
WORKLOAD AND WHETHER WE'VE GOT
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES HERE TO
ACTUALLY GET- THIS PROGRAM
ONLINE HAS TO DO WITH THE
COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT THAT THIS
BILL ANTICIPATED BETWEEN CDFW.
AND CALTRANS DEPARTMENT
TRANSPORTATION AS A WHOLE- WE
KNOW THAT IF WE'RE GONNA BE
INVESTING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE-
OVER THE COMING YEARS- THAT.
THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE
INEVITABLE IMPACTS ON HABITAT
CONNECTIVITY ON A WILDLIFE.
MIGRATION AND SO YOU KNOW I
THINK IS THIS THE IMPLEMENTATION
IS LEGISLATION TO GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GET AHEAD OF THAT
AND I KNOW THAT. IN SB ONE WE
HAVE IN THE WE HAVE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL MITIGATION FUND-
THROUGH CALTRANS THAT'S BEEN
LOOKING AT. WAYS TO DO
CUMULATIVE ADVANCE ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION BEYOND JUST A PROJECT
BY PROJECT BASIS SO I'M HOPING
IN THE FUTURE HERE AND WE CAN
KIND OF TALK ABOUT WHAT THAT
COLLABORATION LOOKS LIKE
BETWEEN- CDFW AND WHAT CALTRANS
IN THE DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION
HAVE BUDGETED ON THEIR END TO
MAKE THIS. IT'S ALL POSSIBLE-
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO SEE ALL THIS
GET MOVING THIS YEAR'S SELFLESS
DOESN'T SLOW DOWN. PROGRESS ON
IMPLEMENTATION BUT- JUST GETS
UPSET SOME BEARINGS TO GET A
REALLY CLEAN CLEAR PLAN FOR
SPEEDING UP AS I BELIEVE IT'LL
ALSO EXCEL. HELP ACCELERATE THE
GOVERNOR'S THIRTY BY THIRTY
INITIATIVE- TO GET A LOT OF THE
UNDERLYING TENSIONS THAT ARE
GOING TO EMERGE AROUND-
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
IMPLEMENTATION ESPECIALLY AROUND
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MOUNTAIN
LION- AND I'M- HOPEFUL THAT- YET
WITH A LITTLE FURTHER DISCUSSION
THAT WE CAN DIG IN AND- GET SOME
EXPOSURE TO WORK. IT'S VERY
PRODUCTIVE AND ACTION ORIENTED.
THIS YEAR SO THANKS MISTER.
THIRTY BONDAGE YOU- HAVE A
COMMENT I'M LOOKING FOR THE
FEATHER AYE AYE J. A. PART OF
MONEY THAT IS FOR- WILDLIFE
HABITAT I DON'T HAVE IT AT MY
FOOT MY FINGER TIPS. AS CHAIR
THERE IS SUCH A PART OF BELIEVE
IT'S PRIMARILY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE INTERIOR AND-
BROADLY SPEAKING. THE OTHER
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL-
ACKNOWLEDGES CORRIDORS IN THE
CONTEXT OF INFRASTRUCTURE
MODERNIZATION. CENTER STERN I
LOOK FOR THE CONVERSATION I
THINK THAT KIND OF. DIVE IN A
SUBSEQUENT HEARING IS A GREAT
PRECURSOR TO HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING IN JULY ONE.
CRISSCROSSED WITH THIS KIND OF
BUDGET PROPOSAL BEING APPROVED
BY THEM. THANK VERY GOOD ALL
RIGHT LET'S SOME MOVE ON TO THE
OF PUBLIC HEALTH COMMENT PORTION
OF OUR- AT A HEARING TODAY AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPATE.
PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. THIRTY FIVE THIRTY ONE TWO
EIGHT THREE AND TO THE-
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. I MAY HAVE TO
INSTITUTE SOME TIME- LIMITS I'M
ASKING THAT FOLKS SAID THE BRIEF
WITH THE COMMENTS ON THE
VARIOUS- AT THE HEARING ITEMS I
SEE NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE AT THE HEARING SO
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT. ON DURING THE OVER THE
A TELECONFERENCE OUR SYSTEM AND
YOU MAY START NOW. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE YOU COULD PARTY PRESS ONE
THEY'RE NOT PRESS AGAIN YOU CAN
REMOVED FROM THE QUEUE. ONE CALL
ON THE SPEAK YOU WILL BE
REFERRED TO BY YOUR LINE NUMBER
AND PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION LEGISLATIVE RECORD
WE FIRST GO TO LINE NUMBER
NINETEEN MY NINETEEN YOUR OPEN
IS GOING OUT. BUT SHARON MEMBERS
THIS IS ROBERT GORE FROM THE
GLAUCO GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD CONTROL
AGENCY WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH. THE W. R. ON ISSUES ELEVEN
AND THIRTEEN ON YOUR AGENDA
WHICH WE STRONGLY SUPPORT I
WOULD NOTE ON ISSUE ELEVEN IT IS
A GOOD. BEGINNING TO INVEST IN
IN SLIDE- AND- ONE ISSUE
THIRTEEN TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE
RAISED BY THE CHAIR. OF SAFETY
IS WORKING CLOSELY. WITH THE
AFTER THE FEDS IN LEVERAGING
FUNDING AND WE HAVE AN
AGGRESSIVE- AND SUCCESSFUL-
RELATIONSHIP WITH LOCAL
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION AND IN
OBTAINING. FEDERAL FUNDS SO
AGAIN. STRONG SUPPORT AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF THANK. YOU
THANK YOU NEXT. ON A SPEAKER
LINEUP TWENTY TWO LINE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS
IS BASS- ALSO ON BEHALF OF WATER
BE IS CALIFORNIA ONE START BY
THANKING SENATOR STERN CHRIS
COMMENTS- IN SUPPORT OF WATER
RECYCLING. I WANT TO TAKE A
QUICK MOMENT TO CORRECT THE
RECORD OF IT- SECRETARY CROAK
BUT NOTED THAT WATER RECYCLING
ASKING A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR AS PART OF LAST YEAR
THREE YEAR GROWTH PACKAGE. WITH
RESPECT THAT FIND HIGHLY
ACCURATE- WATER RECYCLING IS
SHARING A. HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WITH GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP. THE NOTED THAT A RECENT
STAKEHOLDER LAST WEEK. BUT THERE
ARE TWO GROUNDWATER CLEANUP. AND
ONE WATER RECYCLING PROGRAM. SO
THING HASN'T BEEN WORKED OUT.
WORKING IN WATER RECYCLING WILL
BE LUCKY TO RECEIVE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- AND DINNER
STERN NOTED YOU KNOW THE STATE
BOARD HAS SAID THERE IS A LIST
OF ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS MORE RECYCLING. RECYCLED
WATER PROJECTS LOOKING FOR
FUNDING JUST BETWEEN NOW AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IN ADDITION
TO OVER TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
AND LONG TERM NEEDS- THE IN IN
THE STATE. A FINAL NOTE ON THE
FEDERAL. CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW
IT'S GREAT THAT WE- SEE THE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FIVE YEARS
FROM THE FED- BUT WE ARE
COMPETING WITH THIRTEEN OTHER
STATE. FOR THAT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
RECYCLED WATER FROM THE- SHOW
THE NUMBER OF ALL SOUND REALLY
BIG AND PROMISING- BUT BUT IT'S
TURNING OUT TO NOT BE AS MUCH AS
IS. AND AS ROSY AS IT COULD BE
SO WE RESPECTFULLY WATER RUSE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST INCREASED
HER BACK MEANT IN RECYCLED WATER
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY RECYCLE
WATER FUNDING THIS YEAR- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE COMING MONTHS. THANK. YOU
NEXT. SPEAKERS LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX LINE TWENTY SIX YEAR
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE JENNIFER HEARING- CALLING
IN ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN
LION ST VALIDATION AND THE
NATIONAL WILDLIFE FEDERATION AND
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR ISSUES TWO NINE IN FIFTY
SEVEN- WE THINK IT'S SUPER
IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE MAKING THE
THIRTY NINE BIODIVERSITY
RESILIENCE PACKAGE TRANSITION
PERMANENT AND WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND HELPING.
BRING MOUNTBATTEN BABY
ADMINISTRATION FOR PROPOSING
THAT REVERSION ISSUE NINE AWARE
WELL FAMILIAR WITH THE WORKLOAD
AT WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
AND APPRECIATE THE NEED TO
SUPPORT THEIR ACCOUNTING NEEDS.
AND FINELY ON ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN
THAT CDFW IS- DROUGHT PROPOSAL
FOR AUGMENTED FUN DRESS UNIMOG
MIGHT CONFLICT WE'RE GRATEFUL
THAT THE ON AND URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER MAKING
THAT EVEN FURTHER AS YOU GO AND
FINALLY I JUST LIKE TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ESPECIALLY THANK
SENATOR STERN BUDGET COMMITMENT.
AND LEADERSHIP- HE'LL BE EFFORT
TO INCREASE CONNECTIVITY IN
CORNERS ALLOWED LIKE ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU. X. THANKS UP
IS ONE TWENTY POINT TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO TO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND COMMUNITY
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES. I
JUST WANNA MAKE COUPLE QUICK
COMMENTS ON ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
SEVENTY DROUGHT RESILIENCE AND
RESPONSE PACKAGE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE TO INVEST
IN DROUGHT WATER ISSUES- IT
CERTAINLY THAT THE FUNDING FROM
LAST YEAR WAS GREAT TO SEE. THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE RECORDS- THIS YEAR
SOME SOME GREAT CATEGORIES AS
WELL AS SPECIFIC CLEAN THE WATER
CONSERVATION FUNDING THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED THE HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT FINDING IT WOULD
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR WATER CONSERVATION.
ARTICULATELY IF WATER AGENCIES
ARE GOING TO BE REQUIRED TO
FURTHER REDUCE INDOOR WATER USE
WHICH IS BEING PROPOSED- AND
IT'S ME TO STUDY BY THE-
DEPARTMENT WATER RESOURCES. ALSO
WON'T IDENTIFY A COUPLE OF OTHER
CATEGORIES THAT WE HOPE TO SEE
SOME INVESTMENT THE FIRST BEING
DAM SAFETY. YOU KNOW THERE WAS A
LOT OF TRIMMING LAST YEAR- AND
PROPOSED FUNDING THIS YEAR NONE
OF WHICH IS BEING DIRECTED
TOWARDS DAM SAFETY. INCOME AND
HIGH HAZARD DAMS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE IN NEED OF
REPAIR OR RETROFIT. THESE ARE
DAMS THAT THAT D. W. R. HAS
IDENTIFIED AS HI HAZARD IN
EITHER IN CORPS UNSATISFACTORY
CONDITION SO WE WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE I'M FUNDING FOR. THAT
ISSUE. WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATION OF
INVESTMENTS. IN THE AREAS OF A
CONVEYANCE. THAT'S YOUR
MEDIATION WATER PROJECTS AS WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE- GROUNDWATER
PROJECTS AND PUT PROTECTION SO
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT- AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. ZACKS I LEARNED
MONEY WHEN YOU LINE IN THIS CALL
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION TO LEGISLATIVE
RECORD COLLECTIONS LINE THIRTY
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ON IS JAMIE THE NEW AFTER THE
COMMUNITY- WITH FAMILY FARMERS
CAL. AB REPRESENT THE EIGHT
THOUSAND SMALL AND MID SCALE
BACK FARMER INCOME AND HAS
WORKED OVER FORTY TO PRESERVE
SCALE AGRICULTURE AND PROMOTE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY.
POSTED BY THE GOVERNOR MILLION
DOLLARS TO SEE FOR SMALL COMPACT
FIFTEEN ON WATER USE THAT. WILL
CERTAINLY BE HELPFUL BUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDS WILL CERTAINLY
BE NEED AND- ESPECIALLY IF MORE
RAIN DOESN'T FALL THIS YEAR
WHICH WERE EXPECTING VERY LITTLE
IT WILL BE EVEN MORE URGENT TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DROUGHT. AND
THOUSANDS OF AND USUALLY THAN
FARM WELL HAVE AND WILL GO DRY
AND WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE WITHOUT ASSISTANCE- WE
AT CAFE REQUESTING FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS- FROM THE
DROUGHT RESERVE FUND TO GO TO
EFA'S. CALIFORNIA UNDERSERVED
PRODUCER PROGRAM WHICH CUTS.
GRAHAM HAD HELPED MANY SMALL
FARMERS- BUT THESE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS OR CRITICAL TO HELP MANY
MORE STAY IN BUSINESS AND TO
PROVIDE FOOD TRUCK COMMUNITY. I
ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT CAP
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ALLOCATE ADDITIONAL
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM I
SECRETARY ROCK DESCRIBED EARLIER
CDFA DIVISIONAL TRAFFIC REQUEST
TO ADDRESS THESE- LARGE VOLUME
OF APPLICANTS AND THE DESIRE FOR
THIS PROGRAM- IT'S CRITICAL- AND
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF DEMAND
FROM SCHOOLS FOR THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL AS FARMERS. THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. AND YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANKS WE HAVE LINED
NINE LINE TWENTY NINE MINS AGO
TO. GOOD MORNING SHARON'S AND
LOOK AT FAIR ON BEHALF NATURE
CAN. WE APPRECIATE IT YEAR'S
BUDGET CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
DROUGHT RESILIENCE ESPECIALLY
ASSIGNED THE POINTING TO
CONTINUED SEVERE DROUGHT
CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA. WITH
REGARD TO ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
PROPOSED DROUGHT RESILIENT
PACKAGE TNC SUPPORT INVESTMENT
OF TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AND HE NEEDED FOR THE DIVISION
OF WATER RIGHTS AT THE STATE
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
FIRMLY ESTABLISH A DROP SECTION
AND TO SUPPORT REAL TIME
MANAGEMENT RELATED TO DROUGHT
RESPONSE AND PROCESSING
REGULATORY APPROVALS FOR DROUGHT
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS. CONSISTENT
WITH THE WATER RIGHTS DROUGHT
AFTER WE WILL BE WITH POOR OR
MORTAR RECORD. SENATE BUDGET SUB
TO INCLUDED FUNDING LAST YEAR IN
MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
PROPOSAL ADVERTISEMENT THE
DROUGHT TRACTION ALTHOUGH THE
FINAL WATER RESILIENCE BUDGET
PACKAGE LAST YEAR DID NOT
INCLUDE THE SENATE PROPOSAL. THE
PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
DROUGHT RESILIENCE PACKAGE THIS
YEAR INCLUDE THAT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR WHICH
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT YET
SPECIFIED USES WE BELIEVE THAT
THE NEW DROUGHT SECTION SHOULD
BE PROPOSED AS PART OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
NOT ALLOCATED FUNDING. FINALLY
IN ONE ALSO EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR ITEM FIFTY NINE GFW AS WELL
INTERNAL SAY FISHER IN THE
NATION WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET W. COULD PUT
TOWARDS THIS ESSENTIAL ISSUE AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THE FUNDS TO BE
SPENT ON THE CONDITION OF OUR.
WIDE INVESTMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT THANKS IS ONE NUMBER
TWO LINE COULD GO AHEAD. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LEADERSHIP COUNCIL AND
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS ON THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ARE FIRSTLY TO
PORT THE FUNDING FOR FIVE
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY STAFFER IN
THE DIVISION OF DRINKING WATER
TO ENSURE THAT CRITICAL PUBLIC
GUIDANCE IS NOT DELAYED WILTORD
BECAUSE FUNDING FOR STOPPING AT
THE WATERBOARDED SURE THAT IT
HAS THE RESOURCES NEEDED FOR
PROBATIONARY SEGMENT. WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE APPROPRIATION OF AT
LEAST SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION AND ADDS THAT THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION CONTINGENT
DROUGHT FUNDING IN THE GENERAL
BUDGET BE APPROPRIATED TO
PRIORITIZE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES AT
RISK. OF EXPERIENCING DROUGHT
IMPACT. AGUIAR-CURRY THE
CRITICAL WATER. PROVISIONS
RELATING TO WATER FOR WOULD
INCLUDED THE PACKAGE. IN LIGHT
OF THE HISTORIC THIRD WE MUST
BUILD A LONG SAFETY NET GAP
OTHER STATEWIDE LAW INCOME FOR
THE PRO WE WERE THE NEW STATE
FUNDING BE DRY TO DIRECT INSTALL
WATER EFFICIENCY. TO HELP LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE DROUGHT
THE CURTAINS EFFORTS. LET
THOUGHT EXPLANATION OF WATER
SAVING MEASURES PORTION OF THE
FUNDS CAN BE DRY TO EACH ARE
SUPPORTING DIRECTOR. OF ENERGY
SAVING UPGRADE INCLUDING
PREVIEWS THE ENERGY SAVING
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THE- LIKE YOU
. WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORK WITH
ALLEGE. AND MISS IN THAT WE
CLOSER TO THE FROM EVEN TO WATER
THE BRIDGE OUT THERE THANK YOU
THANK YOU ZACKS. THANKS TO
FIFTEEN ONE. YOUR LONG OPEN GO
HEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBER OF THE IS ROGER
DICKENS- SAID WELL FORMERLY THE
LOW BUT COMMIT. JAI THIS YEAR
FOR ON THE- DROUGHT AND WHY
RESILIENCE. BACK I'M MAKE
COMMENTS ON TO. COME OF IN ISSUE
FIFTY. THE FIRST OF THE GROUND
BE PROPOSAL FOR THIRTY MIN
DOLLARS TO THE OF WATER AS HEARD
TRACTOR NAME AND- DESCRIBED THAT
THE TRULY CRITICAL PRO AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IT ACTUALLY SHOULD
BE PLUS UP TO AT LEAST FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THERE'S-
CERTAINLY A NEED- AND THE
CAPABILITY OF DEPLOYING THAT
MONEY FOR THAT THAT PURPOSE THE
SECOND. ITEM IS THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION MULTI BENEFIT
LAND REPURPOSE THINGS PROGRAM
ARE YOU ARE THE DIRECTOR
DESCRIBED THAT YOU EXPECT THAT
PROGRAM TO BE OVERSUBSCRIBED
LAND GRANTS ARE MADE THIS YEAR
WITH THE FIFTY MILLION WE THANK
THE FORTY MILLION PROPOSED FOR
NEXT YEAR IS ACTUALLY. TO LIGHT
WE THINK THAT OUGHT TO ALSO BE
AT LEAST. FIFTY MILLION WE DON'T
WANT TO LOSE THAT MOMENTUM IN
THAT PROGRAM BY WAITING TO SEE
IF IT WORKS WE'RE CONFIDENT IT
WILL WORK ALL INDICATIONS ARE IT
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL AND AGAIN IT
IS INSTRUMENTAL IN OUR EFFORTS
TO TRY TO REDUCE. ON WATER USAGE
AND TO INCREASE THE EFFORTS
TOWARDS SUSTAINABILITY OF
GROUNDWATER WITH THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR CONTINGENT
BEING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
THAT CATEGORY. CERTAINLY THOSE
INCREASES CAN BE EASILY
ACCOMMODATED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU NECKS. UNLESS WE GO TO
LINE THIRTY THREE LINE THIRTY
THREE THE DISCLOSURE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU LUTHER TURN NUMBER AND
ON BEHALF OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VERY
SIMILAR COMMENTS TO THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER. WITHOUT WALKING PUBLIC
WORKS DEPARTMENT BELIEVES THAT
IF THEY HAD ACCESS TO IT THAT
THE MOST FUN AS PART OF THEIR
CAMPAIGN THEY CAN DO A LOT MORE
PLANNING WORK RELATIVE TO OUR
COMPLAINTS AFFECT A LOT. AND I
IN A KNOWLEDGE ONE OF THE MONEY
THAT WAS APPROVED AS PART OF
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET BUT- THEY DO
GO THAT ADDITIONAL FUNDING AS
WARRANTED SO THESE. ARE JUST
THEIR THEM ARE INDIVIDUAL
PARTNER CAN DO THE IMPORTANT
WORK AS I IMPLEMENT TEAM SAID
LAST SO ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND LOOK INTO THE
LEGISLATURE COMPLEX THAT OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND HAVE A
GREAT DAY. THANK YOU NEXT. IN
OTHER WORDS WHEN YOU LINE UP
CALLED TAKE A THE MEDICAL FOR
BLEDSOE RECORD NEXT AS TWENTY
SEVEN WANT TO SEVEN GO TO. BUT
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS BUT IS DON
GILBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BEEN THIS BILL YOU
TILL THE END SITUATION. LIKE
OTHERS WE I'LL BE SPEAKING ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN- LIKE OTHERS WE
APPRECIATE. THE FUNDING
COMMITMENTS FOR DROUGHT
RESILIENCE IN THE AND- THIS THIS
YEAR AND THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR
WHAT. FOLLOWS BUT FRANKLY GIVEN
. GIVEN WHAT FACED WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE WE THINK THAT BILLIONS
MORE INVESTMENT OUR OUR NEEDED-
AS SUGGESTED BY SENATOR STERN-
EARLIER TODAY- THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AS WE ALL KNOW HAVE BEEN
EXCEPTIONALLY DRY AND IN TWENTY
YEARS FROM NOW WE MAY HAVE NO
SNOW PACK AND WE THINK. WE NEED
TO START PREPARING FOR IT FOR
THAT VERY AGGRESSIVELY NOW- SO
WE WOULD LIKE- TO FOR YOU ALL TO
CONSIDER MAKING INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE. EXISTING DAMS ARE SAFE
SECURE AND FULLY FUNCTIONAL.
THIS HAS BEEN RAISED IN THE
STATE AUDITOR'S HIGH ITS REPORT.
FOR A TIME NOW BUT THAT'S FAR WE
HAVEN'T SEEN ANY FUNDING. IN
THIS AREA WE STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
FUNDING FOR OR DAM SHAPE DAMS.
TO SEE MORE FUNDING. FOR
RECYCLED WATER IN OTHER REVIEWS-
ACTIVITIES. WE THINK THE DEMAND
IS MUCH MORE THAN IS PROPOSED TO
BE FUNDED THAT OUT RIGHT NOW.
ALSO AS OTHERS HAVE SAID WE'D
LIKE TO SEE MORE FUNDING FOR CDC
SUCH AS P. FIVE SO THAT EXISTING
SUPPLIES ARE FULLY AVAILABLE.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE- THE
SENATE HISTORY OF BEING VERY
PROACTIVE AND LEADING ON THESE
ISSUES. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL AS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU THANKS.
LINE THIRTY LINE THIRTEEN IS
GOING. HI MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF SOME MARK HENRY WITH CAL
WATER ASSOCIATION- ON ISSUE FIVE
I JUST WANT TO SAY WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
SUPPORT. OF THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR THE NESTING BIRD
HABITAT INCENTIVE PROGRAM A
PROGRAM THAT PAYS FARMERS AND
OTHER LANDOWNERS TO CREATE OR
MAINTAIN I'M NESTING HABITAT
YOU'RE A SMALL SURCHARGE ON
HUNTING STAMPS WHICH ARE PAID BY
OUR MEMBERS AND OTHER HUNTERS.
IMPLEMENTATION IS PROGRAM IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESS DECLINING
POPULATIONS OF OUR LOCAL
WATERFOWL AND UPLAND GAME BIRD
SPECIES. WHICH DON'T HAVE THE
SAME QUANTITY AND QUALITY OF
NESTING HABITAT AVAILABLE
ESPECIALLY IN AGRICULTURAL AREAS
OF THE STATE LIKE THEY DID
THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND THEN ALSO
ON ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE TO. EIGHT- THE
IMMEDIATE THAT DROUGHT- DAMAGES
TO ISSUE WILDLIFE RESEARCH. AND
ALSO BILL RESILIENCE AS DIRECTOR
BONTA ALLUDED TO DROUGHT HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY AFFECTED OUR
WETLAND AND WATERFOWL RESOURCES.
AND FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
SECURE WATER DELIVERIES. A FROM
WATER BLOOD IT ESPECIALLY. IN
AGRICULTURE AREAS OF THE STATE.
THE ADDITIONAL HABITAT PROVIDED-
FROM THE FUNDING NOT ONLY HELPS
THE SPEED WILL BE ARRAIGNED
STAGING WATER PROBLEM. BUT
REDUCES THE SEVERITY OF
WATERFALL DISEASES LIKE AVIAN
BOTULISM IN. CAN KILL TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF BIRDS WITHIN JUST A
FEW DAYS SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. THANKS LINE THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS WE GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND ON BEHALF OF
THE WATER FOUNDATION FOR CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING
THOSE BUDGET ITEMS PERSONAL ITEM
TWENTY TWO RELATED TO THE FIVE
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY STAFF FOR
THE DIVISION DRINKING WATER TO
ENSURE THAT CRITICAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND NOT THE LATE. WE ALSO
REQUEST FUNDING FOR STAFFING AT
THE STATE WATER BOARD TO ENSURE
THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES NEEDED
OR THE PROBATIONARY SIGNAL BASED
ON. AVERAGE WE SUPPORT THE
APPROPRIATION OF AT LEAST SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION AND THAT
AT THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
CONTINUE FUNDING WE APPROPRIATED
TO PRIORITIZE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES AT
RISK OF EXPERIENCING DROUGHT
IMPACT. OR SELLING DROUGHT AND
IS EXPERIENCED THE SECOND DRIEST
JANUARY ON RECORD WE HAVE
RECENTLY SUBMITTED OUR BUDGET
ITEMS. RECOMMENDATION LETTER AND
- FOR SHORT TERM PEAK WATER
EMERGENCY. HOW LONG TERM DOLLARS
BILLION. HOWEVER WATER COULD
PUBLIC RELATING THE WATER. OR
NOT IF IT IN THE ACT. WHICH OF
THE STATE. GOING SOMEWHAT REPORT
PRO. WHICH CAN BE INITIATE BY
USING ANY REMAINING FROM THE-
WAY WATER WASTEWATER AT STATE
WATER BOARD. ALSO INCLUDE
DOCUMENTED FAMILIES WITH. ALL
THE NINETEEN RELEASED HER I WILL
THE APPLICATION LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LATEST INDIANA
. TO ENSURE THE WE LOOK TO THE
BILLING RIGHT WATER IS ABOUT
PROCESS IF YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
THANKS THIRTY SIX LINES OF SIX
TO GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MEMBERS
THE CIVIC ACROSS BUT THE SEEK
YOUR CALL THAT YOU. FINDING
PROGRAMS THEIR LOW COST CAPS
MAKES THEM UNSUITABLE TO SUPPORT
LARGER AND MORE TRANSFORMATIVE
PROJECTS THE NEW FUNDING STREAMS
EACH PROJECT WITH WARRANTY YEAH
WILL THE COURT AUGMENTED FUND
FOR WATER USE. INCOME INCLUDING
THE WEEK PROGRAM WHAT ARE YOU
PROGRAMS TURN MOBILE AND
DIRECTED LESION OF WATERS
APPLIANCES IN LOW INCOME HEALTH
. IMPROVING WATER USE IS THE
QUICK MOST COST EFFECTIVE AND
SUSTAINABLE WAITING WATER SUPPLY
IN CONTRAST TO PART ON THE NEW
DANCE WATER STILL CROPS LIKE
SITE MARC. WE ALSO SUPPORT
INCREASED FUNDING TO A THE
PORTABLE DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
K. EXHIBITED A LETTER RECENTLY
WITH OUR LAB IN OUR JUSTICE
PARTNERS OUTLINE IT WRECKED TO
PROTECT THE HUMAN RIGHTS TO
WATER FROM FINDING A STATE LOW
AND WATER ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS TO
PRIORITIZE LOAN TO COMMUNITIES
THE DROPS. AND FINALLY A PSBS TO
SCHOOL PROGRAM- ENERGY FEET OKAY
ABOUT CAN CALL THAT HELP SPEAKER
. STRONGLY SUPPORT THE THIRTY
COULD IN THE JENNY BUDGET. AND
BOTH THREE MILLION ONGOING. TO
ONE. REVERSIBLE THE CAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL PER TO THIRD NASH MODEL
HOPE SCHOOL DISTRICT BRING HOPE
YOU'RE TO GET IN SURE STABLE
CHAIN FOR SCHOOL CREEK MUCH
NEEDED NEW MARK FOR OUR FARM.
MUCH. IN PARTICULAR GRATITUDE
FOR THE WATER UTILITY THAT
RELEASED IN THE LAST BUDGET
CYCLE IN THE INVESTMENT IN
DROUGHT RESPONSE AND LONG TERM.
SOLUTIONS LIKE EFFICIENCY AND
SUPPLY- RELATED TO TODAY'S
AGENDA WE WANTED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT FOR THE ADDITIONAL STAFF
IN ITEM TWENTY TWO AND FOUR AN
ECHO R. ALLEY SPOKEN IN SUPPORT
OF THAT COMMITTED FUNDING FOR
STATEWIDE WATER AFFORDABILITY
AND INCLUDING FOR UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES. AND RELATED TO ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE
PROFESSIONAL RECURRENCES IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET AND WE KNOW A
LOT MORE IS NEEDED ALONG SOME OF
THE COMMENTS MADE TODAY IN TERMS
OF LOCAL WATER RESILIENCE FOR
AREAS LIKE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA-
FOR PROJECTS LIKE WASTE WATER
RECYCLING STORMWATER. CAPTURE
AND GROUNDWATER CLEANUP. THERE'S
A LOT MORE CAN DO. AS- SENATORS
MENTIONED IN TERM OF BEING.
LOCAL SOUTH FROM. IN SETTING CAL
. AND A LOT OF- THOSE ARE LARGE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE BUT CAN
ALSO ARE ALSO REQUIRED DIG. ON
INVESTMENTS AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE CONVERSATION
AROUND HOW WE CAN WORK
COLLECTIVELY AS A STATE TO BOTH-
PRIORITIZE COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
AT RISK OF LOSING WATER- AS WELL
AS- THAT. LONG TERM INVESTMENTS
WE NEED FOR- FOR WATER REFILLING
THANK YOU. YOU NEXT. THANKS IS
LINE THIRTY FIVE LINE THIRTY
FIVE BECAUSE- ALEX LIMMER ON
BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENT AND
COME AGAIN ISSUE FIFTY SEVEN I
THINK I CAN PREVIOUS COMMENTS
MADE BY CIVIC WHILE ANOTHER
COLLEAGUE. FIRST CHURCH INCREASE
FUNDING FOR THE PARTNER
CONTRIBUTIONS BALK AT THAT
LANDRY PURCHASING PROGRAM
INCREASING THAT'S FROM. THE
MILLION. THERE'S A LARGE METAL
LAND OF THE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM AND
USE THE NOTED THERE IS STRONG
INTEREST CHARGES EIGHT- THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN SHOWN. UNDER ITS
IMPORT PROJECTS INCLUDING
CREATION RESTORATION HABITAT
MULTI BENEFIT GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE. ASSEMBLY TO LESS
INTENSIVE WATER USE IS WHILE
MAINTAINING NATURAL MARKING LAND
. AND CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BEES AND IMPORTANTLY BENEFITS
MANAGE COMMUNITY FALL FARMERS
RANCHERS ARE PRIORITIZED. AND
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED TO SEE THAT
GROWTH PROGRAMMING YEARS COMING-
SECOND WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
INCREASED FUNDING FOR D. W. OURS
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE GOING FROM
THIRTY MILLION TO FIFTY MILLION.
AS NOTED AS NOTED IN THE
DISCUSSION PROMPTED BY CENTER
DOLLARS QUESTIONS INCREASE
RECHARGE AND STORAGE IS CRITICAL
TO ADDRESS THE BILL OPEN DUSTIN
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THESE
PROJECTS- BUT WE CAN GROUND
WATER. RECHARGE CAN BE ESSENTIAL
. EVEN MORE SPECIAL GOING.
STRUGGLING AND FUNDING FOR BOTH
OF THESE FIFTEEN THANK. Q. X.
THANKS LINE THIRTY EIGHT LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ABOUT
THE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AGRICULTURE
NETWORK AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED OR
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS AND
THE CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE WE
SUPPORT THE COMBINED TOTAL OF
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
STATE WATER EFFICIENCY NETWORK
THAT PROGRAM AT THE LAST MINUTE
THE GRANT REQUEST ALLEN STREET
THERE IS A CRITICAL NEED FOR THE
PROGRAM. WE ALSO SUPPORT ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT THIRTY
BILLION FOR THE FARM TO SCHOOL
PROGRAM ADDITIONALLY WE REQUEST
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FARMLAND. I AM AT THE
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION THE NEED
TO PROTECT OUR STATE FARM LAND
EVEN MORE. NOW TO MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND EQUITABLE AND
WE'RE GOING. TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE EX. I LEARNED MINOR TO
COMMON I'M NOT YET DONE SO PRESS
ONE ZERO THREE THREE ONE NUMBER
YOU TAKES IN Q. EXTRA LINE
THIRTY NINE LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER
COMMENTING ON BEHALF OF CINEMA
WATER ON ITEM FIFTY SEVEN OR
DROUGHT RESILIENCE- LIKE MANY OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WE SUPPORT
THAT GOVERNOR'S ATTENTION AND-
AND PROPOSED INVESTMENTS IN
DROUGHT RESILIENCE. I WANT TO
CALL ATTENTION THE NEED FOR
CONTINUED FUNDING ADMISSION.
ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS RESEARCH AND
FORECAST INFORMED RESERVOIR
OPERATIONS OR SPIRO. AT
SECRETARY CROWFOOT POINTED OUT
CURRENTLY SHOWING A LOT OF
PROMISE. THAT'S EVIDENCED BY
WHAT HAPPENED IN OUR SYSTEM
WHERE WE WORK WITH THE ARMY
CORPS. YOU GET A DEVIATION AT
LAKE MENDOCINO AND ENABLED US TO
HOLD BACK AN ADDITIONAL TEN
THOUSAND ACRE FEET THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE BEEN
RELEASED. THAT COULD CRITICAL
CONSIDERING THAT LIKE MENDOCINO
THOSE LEVELS BELOW TWENTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET NEPAL'S MORE
THAN HALF WAS. ABOUT WAS RESERVE
BANKS TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT WOULD
POINT OUT THAT THERE'S NO
FUNDING IN THE CURRENT PROPOSAL
FROM THE GOVERNOR. OR THIS WORK
TO GO FORWARD SO WE WOULD ASK
THAT AS YOU LOOK AT THE DROUGHT
RESILIENCE PACKAGE WE FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO GET. ME TO WORK ACT
CONTINUED AND HAVE OTHER
RESERVOIRS BE ABLE TO ENABLE
CARO INCLUDING. ANOTHER ONE IN
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY LIKE
CINEMA WHICH IS GOING TO BE
CRITICAL FOR OUR DROUGHT
RESILIENCE OF. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION AND THE COURTS TO
DISCUSSION GOING. FORWARD THANK
YOU NEXT. THE NEXT LEVEL FOR ONE
FOR PLEASE GO. ONE FORTY LINES
OPEN CHECK AND SEE COULD NOT BE
THAT ON YOUR SIDE. NATURAL SO
LAST COMINTERN Q. AND THEY'RE
AND THEY'RE NOT RESPONDING OR NO
ADDITIONAL COMPETITION Q. TO THE
BEST. OKAY HAVING BECAUSE OF THE
FACT THAT THE ACCOUNT CAN YOU. I
CAN HEAR YOU GO AHEAD PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU SORRY CHAIR WHY
CAN'T YOU JUST CAN'T BEAT AT THE
END HOW ON BEHALF OF
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
WENTY SIX NUMBER AGENCIES THAT
WE PROVIDE WATER Q. AND THEY
TOOK NINETEEN MILLION PEOPLE IWANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY- WE
SUPPORT- ITEMS SIX MODERNIZING
AGING BETHEL FLEET ITEMS TEN
AGAINST THE OPEN DATA FOR
TRANSPARENT. WATER RESILIENCY
ITEM THE WEAPON FOR VALLEY FLOOD
MANAGEMENT BECAUSE. AND
CONSERVATION AND ITEM SEVENTEEN
THE DOCTOR LET ME IN. FOR THE-
PREPAREDNESS THANK CLIMATE FOR
BILLION EACH AND AGAIN WE ARE SO
OF I THAT YOU. MATCH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED HUNDRED
FIFTY NO SPENDING PLAN FOR WATER
DROPPED. SH AND WE YOU FOR THE
FOR THAT WOULD ALL THEM YEAR'S.
WE WANT TO SUPPORT AND STERN'S
COMMENT AND HIM FOR. HIS
LEADERSHIP. WE THINK WE NEED TO.
FUNDING FOR WHY AND FIX AND
THAT'S JUST FROM SCALE. WATER
LIKE OURS AND DOCTOR MAXED.
HELLO WATER AGE. AND THAT YOU
KNOW HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN CONSERVATION I
KNOW. THE FIGHT OVER THE YEARS.
HELP DESK MANAGED TO THE
DROUGHT- WE REPORT ON THE
TREATMENT EVERY YEAR TO THE
LEGISLATURE HOWEVER WE ARE
FACING NEW UNEXPECTED CHALLENGES
THIS YEAR. PARTS OF OUR SERVICE
AREA- MORE SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED THAN OTHERS STORE DRY
CONDITIONS AND STATE WATER
PROJECT SHORTAGE SUPPLY. THAT
WE'RE WORKING TO ACCELERATE
SOLUTIONS AND WE HAVE INCREASED
OUR CONSERVATION INCENTIVES AND
EXPANDED OUR CONSERVATION
MESSAGING. BUT THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH AND WE URGENTLY NEED TO
MAKE UPGRADES TO OUR REGIONAL
DISTRIBUTION INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ACCELERATE THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION OF OUR REGION
RECYCLED WATER PROGRAM SH. THE
NEW LOCAL SUPPLY THAT WE ARE
LOOKING TO DEVELOP IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH L. A. COUNTY
SANITATION DISTRICT. AND WELCOME
TO OUR PROGRAM COULD PRODUCE UP
TO A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
GALLONS PER DAY OR A DOCTOR.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND HELPFUL.
WE THINK THAT STATES CAN HELP
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ACCELERATE
THESE URGENTLY NEEDED MEDICAL
SUPPLIES. LIKE OURS IN THE CITY
ABOUT ONE EIGHT. AND WE NEED TO
DO THAT FOR ALL TO ADD TO WHAT
EXPECT TO BE. DROUGHT IN THE
BECAUSE THE CRIME CHANGE THEY'RE
ALL GOING TO HELP US ROUTE OUR
RELIANCE ON. FROM TOWN. AND THE
COLOR BURGERS AND THOSE THAT
NEED SYSTEM AGAIN NO LONGER WITH
TO MANAGE THE DEMANDS. THANK YOU
VERY. VOTE ONLY CALENDARS DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON ISSUES NUMBER
ONE. SIX AND SEVEN. NINE THROUGH
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SIX THROUGH
THIRTY FORTY ONE AND FORTY TWO
AS WELL AS FORTY SEVEN THROUGH
FIFTY. AN ITEM NUMBER FIFTY
FIVE. MONTHS FOR THE MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY ON THOSE. MATTERS
MISS ROY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
CASKEY BY ONLY. FIVE REQUIRE
STERN HI THOSE MOTIONS ARE PROOF
FORTY ZERO SENATOR- MCGUIRE IS
THERE A MOTION ON ISSUES NUMBER. FIVE TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE THROUGH FORTY AND
FORTY FOUR THROUGH FORTY SIX.
SOME MOTION BY SENATOR- MCGUIRE
THOSE MISS ROY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL UP ROLL. I CAN'T SCHEME BY
FAMILY. REQUIRE STERN HI THOSE
MATTERS PRESS BY THREE TO ONE
AND FIND- CENTER STERNEST ON
ISSUES TWO ONE THREE EIGHTEEN
THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY TWO THROUGH
THIRTY FOUR FORTY THREE FIFTY
ONE THROUGH FIFTY FOUR AND ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY SIX SO. STIRS
EMOTION BY SENATE STERN MISS ROY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CASKEY.
FIVE NINE. REQUIRE DOLLARS ALL
RIGHT THE THIRD BY. THE MOTION
SIR THREE TO ZERO IN FINALLY
THERE'S A MOST ON I NUMBER AND
IT DID ITEM NUMBER NINE WILL
SEIZURE ASIF IN. IS THERE A
MOTION CENTER TO. SENATE ALWAYS
HAS THE MOST MYSTERY PLEASE CALL
ROLL CASKEY HI HOLLY I GOT.
THIRD THE COLUSA RULED YOU VOTE
THE AYES HAVE IT FOUR ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS FOR ALL
THE IN THE SUPER IN THE PUBLIC
TEST TODAY IF YOU WERE NAY ABLE
TESTIFIED SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
SUGGESTIONS OR BORN TO US AND WE
WANT TO. INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU FOR
EVERY ONE FOR THEIR PATIENTS AND
FOR THE SECRETARIES AND
DIRECTORS SHOULD PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATED THE WE WILL
CONCLUDE TODAY'S AGENDA THE
FISCAL- SUBCOMMITTEE TO OF THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE. IS ADJOURNED.